Almost heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
One's moved on, but I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes, long ago, made you feel, you're not a Lappapuck champ, keep a forehead, Bible thumb.
Twitch emotes, typing Dan's games, forehead swift rage, PJ salt and fail fish.
Life was easy, spamming all the time, TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine.
Twitch emotes, long ago, made you feel, you're not a Lappapuck champ, keep a forehead, Bible thumb.
Twitch emotes, still hear his bark in the morning hour, he calls me, his doggy emote reminds me of a time far away.
Looking at a chat, I get a feeling that I miss emotes from yesterday, yesterday.
Twitch emotes, long ago.
Made you feel, you're not a Lappapuck champ, keep a forehead,
Twitch emotes, table hand.
Twitch emotes, Bible thumb.
das passt jetzt richtig gut warum auch immer das läuft wunderbar also ich habe
ein paar sachen übersehen im chat der hype train ist über dem chat ich sehe
den chat nicht leute der hype train ist noch drei minuten 50 über dem chat ich
sehe den chat nicht richtig ich kann nicht ganz hoch scrollen das game train
überlagert das bei mir in der vorschau generell besteht mein ganzer twitch
chat gerade nur aus irgendwelchen benachrichtigungen dass ich irgendwelche
emotes erhalten habe und der scam train für drei minuten 30 oben drüber
ich würde jetzt gern sagen wer alles subscribt hat und und schön dass ihr
alle da aber ich sehe es nicht das ist natürlich richtig big brain von twitch
dass man das bei sich auf dem eigenen channel angezeigt bekommen
weil man möchte sich ja mit sicherheit selbst abonnieren geht das überhaupt
muss jetzt mal ausprobieren ich habe schon an stufe 3 abonnent seit
sieben monaten nach twitch muss ich muss jetzt leider
warten bis vor was passiert denn wenn ich auf abonnieren clique okay was
passiert da jetzt was passiert da jetzt hoch
nein ich wusste dass das passiert ich habe mir gedacht zur feier des tages kann
ich mal fünf abos verschenken die werden random verteilt das heißt wer als erstes
da ist hat größere chancen dass er eins bekommt und jetzt ist jetzt sogar ich
habe meinen eigenen eigenen scam train auf 100 prozent gepusht das ist die
frage ist wie hype das ist wenn man seinen eigenen hype train bezahlt übrigens wir haben paar neue emotes leider nicht
übrigens wir haben paar neue emotes leider nicht
leider nicht
leider nur ffz und bei der twitch tv emotes ein ganz tolles emote was ich
finde ist das hier zum beispiel keck wait für um zeigt es bei mir die forschung
nicht an für die für die leute die immer schon hier im channel gammeln wenn der
stream off ist haben wir das hier und für die weeps unter uns haben wir hier
sogar ein monka toss emote das habe ich eigentlich
nur für den seba roe eingefügt weil es ein lieblings modus disputiert und jetzt
ist der hentvent schon wieder drüber okay ich guck mal wie weit ich hoch
ges consume also irgendwas auf japanisch weil ich nicht aussprechen kann
abonniert stufe 1 aber dankeschön für drei monater gucken auf welcher seite man
raus kann aber das anklickt hier trägt es sehr schön steht sogar dahinter 3
monate dankeschön dann haben wir noch wollte denn die sechste monate am start
BigBrainHRQSub
GWOZ13
Kuschrenada
ist wieder am Start. Ich werde es
nie aussprechen können. Sieben Monate
sogar schon. Das ist ja richtig. Heute
geht es ab.
Dann haben wir noch.
Achso, meine
fünf selbstverschenkende Abos natürlich.
Wer hat
sie denn bekommen? Zeigt mal her.
UmutKypeli
Der Akte
BushPurple
Eccle und CrashFluffy
haben wir jetzt abgekriegt.
Ja, so schlägt halt
der Random Generator zu.
Dann haben wir Arkenas99
Zwei Monate in Folge. Dankeschön.
KuschBrainSub
Und
zum Schluss haben wir noch FaceGesicht
In dein Gesicht, in your face
Zwei Monate
Und auch die Twitch-Meldung
ist gerade zu kompliziert für mich.
Äh, Moment
FaceGesicht
Abonniert mit Twitch Prime
Der Benutzer hat bereits
für drei Monate
abonniert und ist momentan
zwei Monate in Folge
Ah, okay, verstehe
Das war jetzt gerade zu
lowbrain bei mir
Das heißt, du hast
insgesamt schon mal dreimal gesappt, allerdings
gerade zweimal in Folge. Verstehe
Sehr nice
Das war jetzt gerade zu lowbrain bei mir
So, ähm
Und ChooseMyName ist auch wieder am Start
Drei Monate, heute geht es aber
Schlag auf Schlag, ey. Stonks gehen hoch
Wo wir gerade beim Thema sind
Ich habe mich immer noch nicht um meine Geldanlagen
gekümmert, so um mal die Sachen
vom letzten Stream aufzugreifen
KioKund ist auch am Start
Der Scam-Train läuft
78%
Level 3 kriegen wir auch noch hin, wenn wir schon bei 78%
sind
Oder was passiert bei Level 3 eigentlich?
Außer, dass ich Geld bekomme
Da kann ich mir auch eine Rolex kaufen
Und mit Jesus in Hamburg abhängen
Wollte ich schon immer mal machen
Das geht nur, wenn man genug Twitch-Abos hat
Der Hype-Train, der Hype-Train, der hat
einen eigenen, einen eigenen
eigenes Emote, aha
Ähm
Hahaha
Ikenas99
Ja, das ist ja ewig her
Ewig her, kennt das noch?
Ja, das ist ja ewig her, kennt das noch?
Ewig her, kennt das noch jemand?
VPNésus
Ich Count On It
Hallo Jungs und Mädels.
Quiet.
Ja, ist da Dein Fastway yet
Uh
Gegner Teleportation durch den Boden
Jetzt kommt's hier, Achtung
Achtung, Achtung, jetzt sterbe ich
Und jetzt kommt der Gegner
Der kommt durch den Boden gefahren
Ohne Scheiß, jetzt das spiel ich doch nicht
Weiter in den Dreck
Was soll denn das?
Also ganz im Ernst, das ist für mich das
Failspiel des Jahres 2012
Wer sich das freiwillig kauft, der braucht echt gute Nerven
Also ich halt's nicht aus, geht nicht
Ich kann ja von mir nicht erwarten, dass ich den Scheiß bring
Ganz im Ernst
Und dafür Werbung machen sie jetzt recht nicht ein
Ich weiß schon, warum ich nicht auf dieses dämliche Event gefahren bin
Nach Dings, wo war das? In Köln
Das ist ja ganz ver...
Stimmt, da hatten sie mich damals sogar eingeladen
Da bin ich nicht hin
Ich hatte schon irgendwie im Urin, dass das Spiel zacken wird
Oh, der Hypetrain ist erfolgreich gewesen
Wahnsinn
Und warum jetzt?
Warum?
Ich seh überhaupt nicht
Ich check überhaupt nicht, warum der Hypetrain erfolgreich war
Ach nee
Der Hypetrain
Der Hypetrain war nicht erfolgreich für Stufe 3
Deswegen gibt's jetzt nur ein
Ein Level 1 Hypetrain
Aber wir waren auf Level 2
Vor Level 3
Und warum gibt es jetzt ein Level 1 Emote?
Das Twitch
Hä?
Egal, ich muss das ja nicht verstehen
Es gibt ja
Es gibt überhaupt keinen Grund
Das ist nicht notwendig, dass ich das verstehe
Twitch Prime Community Server Hosting
DrEvilCookie, was genau
Probierst du da?
Schon von der 500 Watt Intel CPU gehört
Nee
Hab ich nicht
GPU
Nee
Was soll man damit machen?
Außer Stromverbrauch
Intel XE HP4
GPU
Was?
Was für ein...
Das ist...
Okay, keine Ahnung, was Intel da macht
Aber...
Äh, ich bin um alles froh, was...
Wartet mal
Oh, wo ist du aus?
Ähm, ich bin um alles froh, was AMD...
Äh, Schwachsinn, nicht AMD
Was erzählt...
Was Nvidia ein bisschen Konkurrenz macht im Grafikkartensektor
Können den Emote nur bestimmte Leute benutzen?
Äh, ich weiß nicht
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das für ein Emote ist
Wie sagt das Emote nix?
Was soll das für ein Emote sein?
Also, bei mir im Channel ist es nicht
Also, ich weiß gar nicht, was das für ein Emote ist
Ich seh, ich guck mir grad meine Channel-Vorschau an
Da ist nix davon drinnen
Genau, bis wir ein paar neue Emotes haben
Bis ich es aber irgendwann schaffe
Die, die Fiverr-Jungs zu nerven mit Channel-Emotes
Soll ich mal gucken, wie viel, wie viel Subs
Aktual, wie viel Subs ich grad aktuell stehe
Ich hab jetzt ja die letzten 1-2 Monate
Nicht ganz so oft gestreamt
Ich weiß, dass das runtergegangen ist
Aber ich kann mal kurz gucken
Ich guck mal kurz
Ähm
Ja, Kiokon hat gleich wieder das Emote gefunden
Das war mir schon klar
Dass sofort irgendjemand auffallen wird
Ähm
Wo seh ich meine Subs?
Die haben das Dashboard umgebaut
Oh, Leute
Ich muss öfter streamen
Absturz
Ich hab nur noch 130 Abos
Pepehands
Das war an Weihnachten, glaub ich mal
Da, wo ich, also die Zeit, wo ich richtig viel gestreamt hab
War das, glaub ich, bei 240 oder so
Aber das Gute ist bei Twitch
Es ist eigentlich, also für Emotes und so
Ist es vollkommen egal
Wie viel man, wie viel man aktuell hat
Es zählt nur, was man maximal mal hatte
Weil, ich mein, ist ja auch klar
Wenn man Emotes reingebracht hat
Und die dann einfach wegfallen würden
Wär blöd
Mein Subcount kommt und geht ja auch so ein bisschen
Je nachdem, wie viel man streamt
Und welche Jahreszeit
Und was man so streamt
Und alles mögliche
130 mal 2,5 Euro ist doch nice
Natürlich ist
Hyper nice
Allerdings, natürlich muss ich ja Steuern drauf bezahlen
Das heißt, da kommt noch mal
Die ganze Ecke von weg
Ne, also
Twitch
Nimmt sich ja die Hälfte
Und, und
Das Finanzamt nimmt sich auch noch mal die Hälfte
So, oder ein Drittel dann
So, mit was fangen wir denn heute an?
Äh
Akenas fragt nicht
Den, den Channel, da guck ich nicht rein
Weil der nicht safe for work ist
Und ich guck zum größten Teil auf der Arbeit
In, äh, ins Discord
Ich skippe das immer
Ich markier den Channel immer
Also, ich guck den Channel immer
Alles, alles gelesen
Das ist, dass die ganzen
Dass unsere ganzen Anime-Fans
Äh, sich austoben können
Und das nicht in anderen Channels machen müssen
Eigentlich hat da früher hauptsächlich der Sebaro rumgeswärmt
Aber der ist wohl grad mit seinem Studium so beschäftigt
Dass der wenig Zeit dazu hatte
Zu übernehmen, dass andere
Das ist quasi, genau
Das ist der Sebaro-Chat
USP45 Silence No Chopper Nuke Challenge
Ich glaub, ich glaub
Wir müssen ein bisschen MW2 gucken
Einfach auf MW2 gucken
Einfach, einfach
Weil's geht, jetzt mal
Einstieg
Was, es gibt einen neuen Arduino?
Ich glaub, das ist jetzt nicht sowas, hier im Stream
So viele Leute interessiert
Ich mein, Linus hat's auch irgendwie gepackt, ne?
Der macht auch die Videos von ihm
Die ich absolut uninteressant finde
Haben Millionen Abo, äh, Millionen Aufrufe
Moin, Matt
So, mit was, mit was fangen wir an?
Ich muss euch übrigens noch was erzählen
Wusstet ihr, dass Microsoft Teams
Microsoft Teams
Das ist dieser, dieser
Discord-Abklatsch
Für, äh, Enterprise
Business, äh, Firmen
Ja, wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt
Der sieht sogar schon ein bisschen aus wie Discord
Ja, guckt euch das mal an
Das ist, es ist quasi
Es ist quasi Discord für Business
Was, weil die keinen Bock haben
Discord zu verwenden
Es ist, es ist, naja
Es ist nicht Skype in Elektron
Skype ist ja schon in Elektron
Wobei nicht in Elektron, aber in irgendeinem Browser-Client-Site
Framework
So, und, ähm, was mir da aufgefallen ist
Slack ist Discord für Business
Ja, genau, das ist
Und Teams ist quasi das, was Microsoft versucht
Als Slack-Konkurrenz
An, an, an Start zu bringen
So, ähm, was, was ich jetzt euch
Wir haben das jetzt auf der Arbeit
Und eine Sache, die mich schon, die mich, die mich
Äh, also erstens, was mich verwundert ist
Mittlerweile, das läuft ja nicht lokal
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob man
Ob man überhaupt Teams lokal installieren kann
Weiß, weiß das jemand?
Kann man den Teams-Server lokal überhaupt installieren?
Zumindest die, die meisten Leute verwenden das hier in der Cloud
Also sprich, das ist dann irgendwie bei Azure gehostet
Mit, halt nicht zugänglich für andere
Außer von der jeweiligen Firma, aber, aber halt in Azure
So, und die Sache ist jetzt die
Dass man, dass man, dass man, dass man
Dadurch darfst du das ja eh schon in der Cloud laufen
Man könnte auch gleich Discord verwenden, ja
Wahrscheinlich ist das gar kein großer Unterschied
Man, man, man
Pusht seine sensiblen Sachen eh schon
Ähm, in die Cloud
Das heißt, eigentlich, eigentlich macht es keinen großen Unterschied
Na gut, zumindest
Was ich, was mich begeistert hat ist
Das Ding hat, und das hat auch schon für erste Verwirrungen bei uns auf der Arbeit gesorgt
Das Ding hat
Ich, ich hoffe dazu gibt's nen
Äh, gibt's nen Video
Ein Meme-Generator eingebaut
Ähm
Genau, hier, so
Und
Ich glaube
Das haben sich die ganzen Leute, die bei uns
Quasi darüber entscheiden, dass sowas eingeführt wird
Gar nicht angeguckt
Weil, bei uns sind die Leute noch ein bisschen
Äh, so
Äh, 90
Stehen geblieben
Und, also was, was, äh, ne
So den, so die Ansicht angeht
Was, was professionell ist, was Business ist, was Enterprise ist
Ähm
Und
Ich hab ja, wir haben jetzt übrigens nen Boomer-E-Mode, ne
Nochmal angemerkt
Und
Ich glaube, das haben die gar nicht gesehen, dass das was drin ist
Aber das Beste an dieser Funktion ist
Übrigens, Giphy und so haben wir ausgeschaltet
Aber
Das Gute ist, also leider kann ich kein, kann
Ich hab's noch nicht geschafft, dem Ding
Äh, Twitch-E-Modes beizubringen
Aber ich bin auch dabei, weil dazu, dazu muss ich unser, unser Team überreden
Die das administrieren
Ähm, die ganzen GIF
Äh, die Suche für die, die Integration für die ganzen GIF-Seiten
Freizuschalten
Und dann, dann das Beste
Was das für ne Musik ist, das ist hier die
Epic Chillstep Collection 2020
So
Und zumindest
Eine Sache, wie man das umgehen kann, ist
Ähm
Man kann hier auf den Meme-Generator gehen
Und dann geht man hier auf das Plus
Und dann kann man krasse Bilder hochladen
Und ich hab mich dazu hinreißen lassen
Genau dieses Ding da
Ähm
Bei uns zu posten
Allerdings in den
Wahrscheinlich ist das
Ist das in dem Channel nicht so gut angekommen
Ähm
Gibt's da, gibt's da einen Online-Generator für
Genau
Und so, so ein Ding hast du jetzt halt auch in Teams drin
Da hab ich mich ein bisschen lustig gemacht
Über die Leute, die bei uns Software deployen
Wenn es nicht funktioniert
Eigentlich überhaupt nichts schlimmes, ja
Ich wollt mal das
Den Meme-Generator in
In Teams testen
Und
Ich wollte, ich wollte auch schon
Ich wollte auch schon Twitch-Emotes rein
MonkaS-Bildchen hab ich auch gepostet
Aber irgendwie, da reagiert keiner drauf
Die sind da glaub ich einfach zu ähm
Zu oldschool
Und zu steif dafür auf sowas zu reagieren
Ich fand's eigentlich ganz lustig
Wenn man
Wenn man das in unseren
Software-Deploy-Channel postet
Aber zu viele Boomer wahrscheinlich
Ja
Zu viele Boomer, zu wenig Zoomer
Aber wir haben, nachdem wir
Nachdem wir ja in der
In der Finanzbranche tätig sind
Haben wir einige Doomer am Start
Der Untergang ist, ist ja
Auf dem Weg
Immer gleich mit Weep-Spam im Team
Nee, wenn ich mit Weep-Spam im Team empfange
Dann ist MonkaTos Abmahnung ist raus
Das kann ich nicht machen
Aber normale, aber normale Sachen
Kann ich machen
Ich glaube, es dauert ja nicht lang
Weil das ist einfach zu
Zu modern für uns
Diese, diese, diese ähm
Diese Meme-Generator-Funktion
Die ist zu modern für uns
Ich glaube, das dauert
Einen Monat
Dann ist die Funktion abgeschaltet
Falls man sie abschalten kann
Wenn man sie abschalten kann
Dann ähm
Ist sie bald weg
2020 genug dafür
Hey Max, was
Oh, Moment, ich muss
Sekunde, Leute, ich muss die
Ich hab, ähm, mein, äh, bei der Twitch-TV die installiert
Und FFZ bei mir auf dem Vorschau-Rechner installiert
Ich muss jetzt erstmal einschalten
Dass, ähm, Sachen an mich
Wieder highlightet werden
Äh
Wie geht denn das hier?
Chat
Chat, Highlight
Highlight an mich
Die mich erwähnen
Erwähnen
Äh
Moment, wie geht denn das jetzt?
Ich muss mal kurz, weil sonst sehe ich nicht
Hier
Zuschauerkarten
Aktiviere das Öffnen
Fuck, ich weiß nicht
Wo ich mich selbst hervorhebe
Ähm, weil
Weil deswegen sehe ich die Chat-Nachrichten nicht, die ihr an mich schreibt
Chat
Filterung, hier
Äh, Vorheben, die mich markieren
Könnt ihr mal ausprobieren
Spamt mal bitte eine Runde
Im Chat und dann gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert
Ob ich es jetzt wieder sehe
Nice
Ja, funktioniert, wunderbar
Perfekt, Dankeschön
Nice, jetzt, jetzt wird natürlich
Das kann sich jetzt keiner nehmen lassen, eine Runde
Was hältst du von
Mail
Globe
Ähm, hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert
Keine Ahnung, jetzt wo ich das
Logo sehe, ich hab das schon mal gesehen, aber ich kann dazu
Überhaupt nichts sagen
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht
Nicht ausprobiert
Ähm
Twitch-Integration
Und dann lulw-Spam
Ja, ich, das wäre gut, wenn Teams
Eine Twitch-Integration hätte
Die Mitarbeiterzufriedenheit hat sich
Dank GIFs extrem verbessert
Ey, man glaubt gar nicht
Wie
Viel Einfluss so kleine Kleinigkeiten
Haben
Sonst nix mehr übersehen
Wenn ich was übersehen hab, müsste ich das grad nochmal
Nochmal schreiben
Ey Max, was hältst du von Mail
Hab ich doch grad gesagt, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab's noch nie ausprobiert
Meta-Teams-Emote
Oh, das wär natürlich was
Ähm, die
Eine Sache bei Teams ist ein bisschen merkwürdig
Man kann eine Integra-
Also das Ding hat ganz viele Plugins
Ja, also was man Jira integriert
Ticketsystem integriert, aber meistens
Nicht mit den lokalen Installationen, sondern
Nur mit der Cloud, was sehr merkwürdig ist
Okay, also
Komm Leute, wir gucken mal
Was
Brutal FPS Masterpiece
Created by one person
Was, was ist das
Ach, das doch
Das haben wir doch schon mal gesehen
Das ist dieses Ding, wo sie jetzt einen zweiten Teil von produzieren wollen
Mit mehr Geld
Ubi, du hast so viel Black Desert gespielt, ey
Das ist
Die einzige Community, ja
Die ich kenne, die auf diesem
Programm hängen geblieben ist
So, wir gucken uns jetzt erstmal
Zum Einstieg in Ollis
So alt ist das Ganze, ein Jahr alt
Äh, ist Black Desert immer noch so toxic
Keine Ahnung, ich hab das schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr gespielt
Das einzige, was ich aktuell
Spiele, ist das hier
Und das ist auch hauptsächlicher Grund
Warum ich in letzter Zeit so wenig streame
Weil ich gerade den übelsten
Den übelsten
Äh, äh, Season-Crime mache
In Path of Exile
Jeden Tag, wenn ich heimkomme, bis ich ins Bett gehe, mache ich Maps
Oder irgendwelchen anderen sinnlosen Content
Stream doch, das ist langweilig
Zuzugucken
Das, also Path of Exile zuzugucken ist übelst
Ist übelst lame
Ich guck's mir auch nicht an
Das einzige, wo ich mir Path of Exile mal auf Twitch angeguckt habe
Ist, wo letztens diese
Diese ZDPS League oder so gestartet ist
Weil ich mir einfach mal angucken wollte
Wie es die Pros hinkriegen, einen guten League-Start
Hinzulegen
Und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass es die richtig guten Leute schaffen
Das quasi in
Zwei bis drei Stunden so Endgame-mäßig
Am Start zu sein
Oder, zumindest in die Richtung
Nach vier Stunden quasi schon
Ganz guten Clearspeed
Wo ich mir so denke, okay, da habe ich zwei Tage für gebraucht
Oder drei Tage
Wenn ich soweit war
Mit Tech Talk nebenbei, ja
Das, das, man muss bei Path of Exile
Wenn man Maps macht, ein bisschen konzentriert sein
Also man kann nicht komplett
Also vor allem, wenn man Maps macht, die sich lohnen
Man kann nicht komplett
Wobei, ich spiele Summoner
Und ich guck mal
Diesmal ist das Essen das zweite von rechts
Sagt euch Leute, Essen ist immer oben rechts
Die haben schon irgendwelche Analysen durchgeführt
Dass Essen immer oben rechts sein muss
Okay, komm, wir gucken uns mal zum Einstieg
Ein richtig olles MW2-Video
Hier, da war es, Leute, habt ihr es gesehen?
Deswegen war die Map
Deswegen, wegen dem Bild
Was hier oben hing
War die Map kurzzeitig gesperrt
Erinnert sich noch jemand?
Ich bin ja immer noch begeistert
Dass so viele Leute den Kram spielen
Ich mein, das Game ist wie alt jetzt?
2013 oder so?
Wann kam das raus?
2010?
2010, oder?
Was auch erst nach vielen Jahren
2010, das ist so alt
Warum spielen das überhaupt noch Leute?
MW2 ist ein richtiges Rage-Game gewesen
Botatch
Also, please
News
Wo 가격
Weiter
Wie man sé
Der
Das ist
We writers
My God
Da hat er, das hat er schon irgendwie in 10 Gameplays gehabt, wo er da Waste, ne nicht Wasteland, äh, äh, äh, äh, Villa, ne, oh, fuck, Estate, ne, meine Güte, ne, Estate war die, die CS-Map, ähm, wie heißt die Map nochmal? Doch, Estate, oder?
Hahaha, hat das Controller gegen die Wand geschmissen.
Ah, die Gegner sind auch schon immer noch, immer noch richtig brain-dead.
Halt, Konsole.
Ja, und auch die, die wir hier haben.
Und?
What? Was macht der da oben?
Kann man deine Emotes irgendwo runterladen?
Hä?
So wie bei allen anderen Channels auch.
Oder du meinst in Hi-Res?
Hast du dir schon Wolzen, Wolzen, oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht, angeschaut?
Ähm, ja, allerdings, ähm,
warte mal, allerdings, ähm, haben mich die Bugs ein bisschen abgeschreckt, und dass es wohl online nicht richtig läuft, weil ich, wenn ich so ein Spiel spiele, dann wenn schon nur online, und es noch total unklar ist, wie das Endgame wird, und es, es, also ich meine, in Path of Exile gibt's auch total viele unbalanced Builds, aber da gibt's halt welche, die sind, die sind komplett broken.
Du musst einfach nur die richtigen paar Skills auswählen, und du machst quasi zehntausende Damage, und das auch nicht.
Auch ohne jetzt wirklich sonderlich großes Gear, was ich bisher gesehen hab.
Also ich warte mal ab, wie das Ganze, Ganze wird.
Zumal ich sagen muss, dass ich halt aktuell, was Path of Exile angeht, halt echt viel Spaß dran hab, weil ich bin ja noch recht neu, ich mein, ich hab das zwar schon lange gespielt, mal vor, vor, vor fünf Jahren oder so, schon ewig her, aber das Coole ist, es gibt so viel krass neues Zeug, du brauchst eigentlich eins, zwei, äh, komplette Leaks, bis du überhaupt durchblickst, was es alles gibt.
Das ist so krass mittlerweile, was du in Path, was, was...
Was du alles machen kannst, und wo überall irgendwie noch was drinsteckt.
Ich glaube, das ist eines der komplexesten, äh, so Hack'n'Slash, oder, nee, das ist das komplexeste Action-RPG-Hack'n'Slash-Game, was es gibt.
Ist Stadia schon dead?
Es ist verdächtig ruhig um Stadia, ja.
Jetzt kam ja diese, oh, das müssen wir im Stream übrigens ausprobieren, Leute.
Nvidia GameStream wollte ich mal ausprobieren im Stream.
Und nicht, GeForce Now heißt ja nicht GameStream.
GameStream ist ja das Lokale.
Oh, Stadia wird abkacke...
Ich hab's ja schon oft gesagt, also...
Hahaha, U-Boot, nee, ich hab, äh, ich hab nur eins in Hi-Rez.
Außerdem, Emotes brauchst du ja maximal in 128x128, das reicht für Emotes.
Haben die auch negative Latenz?
Die haben RTX on.
Alter, ist doch gut.
Oh, Alter.
Wir haben auch unsere Payflow.
Rippen den Traum.
Wie, Payflow?
Da oben steht, wir werden skamast, Leute, guck mal.
Silenced, USP, no chopper.
No chopper, was ist das erste, was ich sehe?
Ein Heli.
Komm schon, Baby.
Der ist hier.
Haha, Leute, der Chopper ist ein Heli.
Der Chopper Gunner ist der Elfer-Killstreak.
Ja, ich weiß, dass er Chopper Gunner meint.
Aber, wenn wir mal ganz genau sind, bedeutet...
... dass er No Chopper natürlich auch, dass er kein Payflow nimmt?
Jet, ihr müsst mir das nicht erklären, wie das Spiel war.
Ich hab das lang genug gespielt.
What the F*********?
Ich weiß, dass er Chopper Gunner meint.
I, IQ.
Ich dachte auch, dass der Harrier Payflow oder Harrier AC130...
...weil, der könnte, der könnte genauso gut...
...Harrier AC130 verwenden und es wäre easy.
Es wäre überhaupt kein Unterschied zwischen...
...haha...
...zwischen Chopper Gunner.
ein Chopper Gunner und so. Umut, du musst auf Better Twitch TV und FFZ gehen, da kannst du dir
anzeigen lassen, welche Emotes ich auf dem Channel habe. Flo690, der Benutzer hat bereits sieben
Monate abonniert. Alter, jetzt geht's aber los hier. Ups, ich hab falsch gedrückt. Ich wollte
eigentlich den da drücken. Und Max, wie läuft es bei dir mit der Zugverwendung? Bei uns ist die
Höllentalbahn seit Montag gesperrt, sie hat ganze vier Wochen funktioniert, wieder am Arsch. Aktuell
funktioniert das bei mir tatsächlich ganz okay mit dem Zug. Die Skype-Sounds? Achso, bei ihm da,
ja. In der, in der, in der, in dem Voice, in dem Audio, ja. Ja, damals hat man,
ja, auch noch Skype verwendet. Skype war so 2007 bis 2014 so das Ding, danach war's Discord. Warst du
vom Sturm betroffen? Ja, war ich, war ich. Also nicht von dem, der jetzt gerade ist, sondern von
Sabine. Ich war von Sabine betroffen. Und zwar, weil der Zaun im Garten bei uns, da kann ich jetzt
unten drunter durchlaufen.
Was? Was? Ah, ne, das war der Payflow. Ich wollt grad sagen, wie hat er den denn erwischt? Wenn das fertig ist, erzähl ich was zum Sturm.
Ach, der hat's bisschen bei uns im Garten verwüstet, aber ansonsten nix, nix Wildes.
Ja, komm, jetzt, jetzt gibt's Nuke und gut ist, weil ich mein, von der Zeit her, des Videos, das ist, das ist halt so ein Video, wo man sagen muss, die, die Video, die Laufzeit spoilert, was passiert.
Ich hab' gerade den Jungen im Garten gesehen. Ich hab' wirklich nicht so viele Töne, ich glaube, vier, fünf. Ich hab' viel Zeit, um mit ihm zu arbeiten.
Komm schon, wo sind die?
Das muss jetzt, das muss jetzt klappen.
Puh, das war nah. Ich höre jemanden stoppen. Das ist ziemlich nah.
Halt!
Junge, ich weiß nicht, wo ich gehen soll.
Ich hab' einen Trip-Bank.
Ich hab' keine Ahnung, wo sie sind.
Nicht eine Person spawnt hier.
Halt!
Die Feinde der Feinde sind gespawnt.
Gut, sie rennen umdrehen, für eine Minute und eine halbe.
Ich hab' mich nicht mehr gefreut.
Juk?
Nee.
Wo ist er? Unter mir?
Das war nah.
Es gibt den letzten, den letzten FFR-Kill gibt in Nuke, oder irgendwie sowas.
Weil viel kann das nicht mehr sein.
Die Leute, wer ist wir? Ich hab' doch schon...
Wow.
Ja, ich hab' auch. Ich hab' auch gedacht, er kriegt das auf den Sack.
Ich hab' das in.
Hoffentlich hat euch das Video gefallen.
USP, silenz, technische Nuke.
Kein AC-130, kein Chopper.
Wir werden UAV und Pave Low benutzen.
Es hat ein bisschen Erfolg, das zu tun.
Es hat mich ein bisschen gefällt.
Er hat es gerade gestorben.
Der hat es rausgeschnitten, dass er gestorben ist, oder?
Guck mal.
Es hat ein bisschen Erfolg, das zu tun.
Mir hört die Claymore noch.
Pass mal auf hier.
Wolltest du nicht, dass man sieht, dass er noch gestorben ist oder so?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ist gar was.
Moin Max, du hattest ja mal ein Video über Homeoffice in der IT gemacht.
Ja, stimmt.
Ich habe einen Job, der komplett remote ist.
Heißt gar kein Büro.
Können wir gerne mal drüber quatschen, wenn du willst.
Warum?
Warum gibt es da so viel zu zu sagen?
Also ich finde das prinzipiell nicht verkehrt.
Vor allem, wenn man sowas Richtung Programmiert, also Richtung Softwareentwicklung geht,
wo man halt hauptsächlich den ganzen Tag damit beschäftigt, irgendwelche Sachen zu programmieren.
Warum nicht? Ich finde das gut.
Und vor allem, dass es immer mehr in die Richtung geht, dass man komplett remote arbeiten kann.
Da sind wir in Deutschland ja ein bisschen hinten dran, was das Ganze angeht.
Und wenn man sich da Jobs anguckt, beispielsweise in den USA, da ist das gang und gäbe, dass Entwickler komplett remote arbeiten können.
Die suchen ja teilweise auch Entwickler, die komplett remote arbeiten.
Da gibt es viele Firmen, die haben gar kein Gebäude in dem Sinn, was alle Mitarbeiter aufnehmen könnte.
Was das Beste an Homeoffice ist, dass du weniger für Strom plus Internet zahlen musst.
Ja.
Das Beste an Homeoffice ist eigentlich, dass man nicht morgens auf die Arbeit fahren muss.
Und ein bisschen länger pennen kann.
Deswegen mache es.
Bei uns gibt es ja so einen Gag, weil es gibt Leute, die machen Homeoffice offiziell.
Und man hat allerdings halt das Gefühl, sie machen quasi Home minus Office.
Also wenn man Home minus Office rechnet, bleibt halt nur Home übrig.
Und genauso fühlt sich das bei manchen Leuten an, wenn die Homeoffice machen, dass die einfach nur Home machen und kein Office.
Weil sie versuchen teilweise zu erreichen, antwortet keiner.
So.
Äh, also ne, versuchst du anzuschreiben über Skype, Teams, sonst was, antwortet keiner.
Und du siehst auch Abwesenheit irgendwie seit 5 Stunden.
Ähm, dann rufst du mal vielleicht irgendwann an, so nach dem Wort, ja, ich bin gerade beim Mittagessen.
Dann ist, wird irgendwie mal so alibi-mäßig ein Ticket angeklickt, wo ich dann echt das Gefühl habe, der macht halt einfach nur Home.
Ohne Office.
Aber, auf der anderen Seite, eigentlich ist mir das wurscht.
Ähm, ich fände es bloß blöd, wenn, ich weiß nicht, ob dort irgendwas im Hals war.
Warte mal.
Ich fände es halt nur blöd.
Wenn das zu viele Leute ausnutzen, dass man bei uns Homeoffice machen kann und halt nichts machen, sodass dann irgendjemand mal auf die Idee kommt und zu sagen, hey, ne, ich weiß nicht, Homeoffice sollten wir lieber doch nicht mehr erlauben, weil da habe ich keinen Bock.
Ja.
Ich, ich finde das super, dass man ab und zu Homeoffice machen kann und ich würde es auch gerne weitermachen, deswegen wäre es ziemlich kacke, wenn das manche Leute so offensichtlich ausnutzen würden, daheim halt zu chillen und nichts zu machen, dass man es dann selbst nicht mehr machen darf.
Das wäre doof.
Ich sitze seit einem Jahr im Homeoffice und arbeite mehr als früher.
Das habe ich auch bei manchen Leuten schon festgestellt.
Das, es, es, es, also es kommt natürlich auf die Arbeit, also es kommt auf die Firma an und es kommt auf die jeweilige Person an, weil, ähm, mir ist es auch aufgefallen, dass manche Leute der Meinung sind, ähm, dadurch, dass sie halt nicht vor Ort sind, ähm, müssten sie jetzt besonders dann zeigen, dass sie was machen.
Und da könnte ich mir vorstellen, wenn man so jemand ist, dass das halt dazu führt, dass man sich nicht mehr so auf die Arbeit stellt.
Dass man Homeoffice-mäßig halt voll übertreibt, so.
Und vielleicht noch nicht mal alles aufschreibt.
Hm.
Äh, Knallgas-HD muss ich auch sagen.
Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich muss nochmal kurz husten.
Äh, der, erstmal, erstmal T einstecken hier.
Excellent.
ASMR-Plätscher-Sounds.
Ne, nicht Corona.
Das ist bestimmt nicht Corona, ey.
Das ist ja auch so in der Zwischenzeit im, im, äh, im Twitch-Chat gewesen, überall, ne.
Wenn irgendwie einer gehustet hat, war sofort Corona am Start.
Äh, Knallgas-HD, ja, finde ich auch.
Also, für mich, also für mich ist ein Riesenvorteil bei der ganzen Homeoffice-Geschichte, dass so diese, die Bahn-Geschichte wegfällt, zwischendurch.
Also, man kann quasi eine Stunde länger pennen, ist dann auch logischerweise fitter, was natürlich auch, äh, wichtig ist.
Weil man, weil man ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ne, weil man ein bisschen nachdenken muss bei dem, was man macht.
Und, ein, ein Vorteil, der auch nicht zu unterschätzen ist, wenn man, wenn man, äh, dann seine Mail schreibt, so nach dem Motto, Homeoffice fertig für heute, dann ist man halt sofort daheim, ne.
Dann hat man Homeoffice minus Office, dann ist ja nur noch Home am Start.
Ähm, Flo96, in der Theorie her schon.
Ähm, ähm, Alter.
Ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm.
Praktisch gesehen, umso größer die Firma ist, umso weniger merkt man das.
Also, je nachdem, umso größer die Firma ist und umso, umso verzweigter das Ganze ist, umso weniger merkt man das.
Was meinst du, warum es bei vielen großen Firmen so viele Bullshit-Shops gibt, wo man sich fragt, okay, für was ist diese Position eigentlich da?
Das wissen die Leute teilweise selber noch nicht mal richtig.
Ähm, ähm.
Ähm.
abteil einer richtigen position ist du hättest theoretisch die chance den ganzen tag nichts zu
machen das würde keiner merken problematisch ist halt nur wenn das zu viele machen würden
und man und das irgendwann mal festgestellt wird dann ist halt doof weil das betrifft an alle bei
uns ist das chinesische zweig der firma geschlossen ja einer der stellt der stellvertreter von meinem
chef habe ich gehört da hat sich auch auf corona testen lassen nicht trost also sprich wenn ihr
es bei dem festgestellt hätten dann hätten sie bei uns auch dicht gemacht die sprechen
die cisco leute eigentlich corona aus warum rona keine ahnung kokona warum sollten die das
anders aussprechen aha ja alex dass das das ist dann nimmt der trend der trend nimmt zu ich wusste
nicht dass in deutschland mittlerweile auch schon verbreitet ist aber ich weiß dass es in den usa
ziemlich verbreitet ist dass es dass es viele firmen gibt die nur die nur komplett home office
machen die haben gar kein gebäude mehr wo die leute reinpassen zur rona die cisco leute cisco
sagen cisco das ist eine komische aussprache ich bin immer noch für cisco cisco aber es ist ja auch
router und ich router der cisco router kisco kisco klingt irgendwie wie irgend so ein rapper aus dem balkan oder so kisco einer meiner profis
sagt auch immer router ja ich würde fast sagen es ist so 50 50 hatten wir nicht sogar mal eine
abstimmung im chat gemacht ob router oder router und das kam ziemlich 50 das machen wir jetzt mal
leute das müssen wir jetzt mal machen wartet mal wobei ich ich create das glaube ich besser auf
dem zweiten bildschirm weil ich bin mir nicht sicher ob man da nicht irgendwas sieht wo man
faken kann enter pool okay guter
routern oder router IP Duplicate Checking gut create der titel ist required aussprache
okay leute also ich poste das jetzt mal im chat und ihr müsst ihr müsst jetzt mal sagen
router oder router was ist richtig wie spricht man es eurer meinung nach aus wir gucken uns mal live
an, wie das Ganze hier läuft.
Results.
Mal gucken, was da rauskommt.
Oh, Router liegt.
Router führt, eindeutig.
Jetzt rollen eh alle.
Das kann auch sein.
Okay, es ist bei weitem nicht 50-50.
Es ist eindeutig Router
versus Router.
Rauder.
Rauder hört sich an wie eine
norwegische Ölplattform
oder so.
Rauder.
In Schwedisch wäre es Rauderson.
Okay, also.
Eindeutig Router.
Router hat verloren.
Also, Cisco-Leute, get out.
Okay, was hat er
hier für ein Video vormarkiert?
Opened with a fork.
Vault-Tag live pod
gun safe. Ah, gun safe.
Ah, yes.
Wir sind in
den USA unterwegs. Eindeutig.
Wo braucht man sonst einen
Live-Pod-Gun-Safe?
Das ist so
Only-N-A-Problems.
This is the lockpicking lawyer
and I have lost count of the number
of people who have requested that I feature
this product. It's the Vault-Tag
Live-Pod and there was a spike in requests
soon after it was endorsed by
fellow YouTuber Colean Noir.
Now, it's a pretty unique product.
It's the only waterproof portable gun.
Er hat keine Musik im Hintergrund, deswegen lassen wir unsere Musik einfach mal weiter.
Gehen wir weiter.
Bisschen leise oder?
Bisschen leise.
Wollen wir mal bisschen lauter machen.
Wartet mal.
The internal switch that
disconnects the mechanical backup lock.
Das bedeutet, dass der Switch
von der Mitgliedschaft YouTuber Colean Noir ist.
Nun, es ist ein ziemlich uniktes Produkt.
Es ist das einzige waterproof portable
Gun-Safe, das ich weiß, und es hat
eine... Waterproof portable Gun-Safe?
Okay.
Ich überlege mir gerade, in welcher Situation braucht man einen tragbaren Waffenschrank, der wasserdicht ist.
Im Schwimmbad.
Ja, gut, bei den Amis würde mich das nicht wundern.
Kannst du dann an die Badehose, kannst du deine Pistole mitnehmen oder was?
Ich frage, nee, ernsthaft.
Wenn man auf dem Schiff ist vielleicht und hat Angst, dass das Schiff sinkt und man muss quasi sein Rettungsboot verteidigen gegen die anderen Plebs, die da rein wollen.
Keine Ahnung, ich glaube, das sind only Kokona-Things, die wir hier sehen.
Moin Max, alles schick?
Ja, aktuell schon.
Der Chat ist wieder besonders.
Ein interner Schiff, der den mechanischen Backup-Lock nicht verbindet.
Das bedeutet, wenn dieser Schiff eingegangen ist, auch wenn ich diesen Schiff wähle, wird der Schiff nicht öffnen.
Äh, Leute, Leute, Moment.
Sieht das für euch sicher aus?
Ich meine, da ist ja eine Lücke, da kriege ich meinen Finger halb durch.
Also jetzt übertrieben.
Da kann, da, da, also, da kann ich ja, also mal angenommen, ich habe eine Brechstange oder so, kriege ich das definitiv auf.
Da muss ich, also da muss ich noch nicht mal der Lock-Picking-Lawyer sein.
Ähm, wenn ich da vorne reinkomme mit irgendwas, ähm, und das ordentlich hebeln kann, ist das Ding, ist das Ding Schrott.
So, I decided to approach the product, assuming that switch was engaged, and after examination, I discovered I could still open it up.
That's because the designers made a rookie mistake.
They failed to protect adequately the internal button that allows someone to program a new...
...new code.
And unfortunately, all you need to exploit the flaw is a fork.
I'll show you how that's done, but first, let me show you where the button is.
We need to release these clasps that hold the plastic lid against the internal gasket.
Then put the default code in.
One, two, three, four.
Huge code.
And we can see the program button, and imagine how a fork can be slipped in through the gap to push it down.
So, let's lock this back up.
Oh, nice.
Take our fork, slip it through the gap, and let's try to find that button.
Hey, Tomik, sag ich gleich was zu?
Okay, I've changed the combination to 1-1-1-1.
Moment, jetzt hab ich nicht hingeguckt.
Jetzt hab ich nicht hingeguckt, Leute.
Jetzt hab ich Chat gelesen, ich hab nicht hingeguckt.
Lock this back up.
Take our fork, slip it through the gap, and let's try to find that button.
Okay, I've changed the combination to 1-1-1-1.
Wahnsinnig secure.
Let's check the old combination.
You see, it does not work.
And the new combination does.
Huge security.
So, while this product does have a few interesting and innovative features,
the failure of the designers to adequately protect the reset button is a significant flaw.
In any case, that's all I have...
Wisst ihr, wann sowas rauskommt?
Wenn Leute ihre Produkte nicht testen lassen.
Von...
Von Leuten, die halt wissen, was sie tun.
Ja?
Wie soll das denn wasserdicht sein, wenn er da mit einer Gabel reinkommt?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage, Captain Falcon.
Das ist eine wirklich gute Frage.
Also, die meinen, mit wasserdicht ist wahrscheinlich in dem Fall nicht gemeint,
dass es quasi unter Wasser funktioniert, sondern dass es einfach wasserabweisend ist.
Aber trotzdem, es ist halt dieses Failure.
Big brain, naja, richtig.
Ähm, halt voll für'n Arsch, ne?
Wahrscheinlich ist es von AliExpress.
Also, das Ding ist definitiv nicht IP65.
Stopp, IP65, ne, warte mal.
Der erste, der erste ist Staub, ne?
IP, also 6 ist Staub und 5 ist, 5 ist bis zu einem Meter unter Wasser.
Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken.
Thank you.
Okay, interessant.
So, ähm, ähm, um jetzt noch was zu sagen, was Tom Triggs gefragt hat.
Sauber, sag mal, welche Netzwerkserver-Monitoring-Tools nutzt ihr eigentlich auf der Arbeit?
Ähm, nachdem mittlerweile nicht mehr alles von einem Team gemacht wird, was Monitoring angeht,
ist es ziemlich unterschiedlich.
Also, äh, was im Netzwerkbereich verwendet wird, kann ich dir gar nicht so genau sagen.
Das macht zum größten Teil mittlerweile irgendeine andere Firma.
Keine Ahnung.
Äh, Server-Technik ist eine wilde, eine wirklich sehr, sehr wilde Mischung aus Zabbix, Elasticsearch und, äh, Kibana und Prometheus Grafana haben wir auch noch.
Und wir haben so ein komisches Custom-Tool eingekauft, was sich, äh, Silk, Silk, Silk Performer oder so irgendwie nennt.
Irgendwie sowas.
Da kann man irgendwelche Software-Klicks automatisieren.
Ganz, ganz krudes Oldschool-Zeug.
Und wir haben noch, ähm, wie ist das?
Ähm, und dann haben wir noch Dings irgendwie, wieso heißt das?
Also, unser Monitoring ist, äh, ziemlicher, ziemlicher Fail, muss man sagen.
Das da haben wir noch.
Äh, haben die, haben die da vielleicht auch Bilder zu?
Weil das ist eines der hässlichen, der hässlichsten Web-Interfaces ever.
Boah, dieses Ding, guckt euch das mal an.
Also, das sieht aus wie 1995.
Also, wenn's nach mir geht, hätten wir nur Zabbix.
Ähm, mit, äh, Prometheus-Exporter, die mittlerweile auch im Zabbix funktionieren.
Und alles wäre gut, wunderbar.
Ja, falls man irgendwelche Dashboard-Sachen nicht machen könnte, könnte man auch einen Grafana dabei stellen.
Aber den ganzen anderen Kram ist komplett, äh.
Ähm, parallel-engineertes, äh, doppeltes Zeug.
Äh, PRTG soll aber wirklich ganz gut sein, TomTrix.
Hab ich noch nicht verwendet, aber alles, was ich bisher zu gesehen hab und auch Empfehlungen von Leuten gehört hab,
von denen ich persönlich zumindest denke, sie wissen, wovon sie reden, ähm, soll das gar nicht so schlecht sein.
Hab ich, ich hab's aber noch nie in den Fingern gehabt.
Ähm, Linux-Bereich, Prometheus und Grafana ist nicht schlecht.
Allerdings muss man sich überlegen, wofür man das Ganze einsetzt.
Ähm.
Prometheus und Grafana ist schön, wenn du quasi, wie nennen sie das, Metriken sammelst, also, quasi Statistiken sammelst.
So richtig für, für so reaktionäres Monitoring mit, ähm, nee, wie, wie nennt man das?
Reaktionär? Nee.
Also sprich, dass es einen Alarm gibt und man da drauf reagiert, finde ich Grafana und, äh, Prometheus in Kombination nicht so schön.
Ähm, weil, es ist gar nicht so einfach, mal in Prometheus zum Beispiel nen Dashboard, also, in Prometheus und Grafana, nen Dashboard zu bauen, wo man einfach nur drinne sieht, ist der Host ab oder down.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Es gibt, es ist, es hört sich erstmal einfach an, ist es aber gar nicht, weil es gibt fünf, sechs verschiedene Sachen, äh, standardmäßig schon, die man checken muss, um überhaupt dahinter zu kommen, ob Host ab oder down ist.
Es gibt Blackbox-Ping-Check.
Es gibt, ähm, den, den...
Den standardmäßigen, äh, ähm, wie heißt, wie heißt es bei, wie heißt es bei Prometheus?
Äh, Node, ähm, dass der Node antwortet.
Ähm, es gibt, ähm, dann auch die Geschichte, wenn du beispielsweise es auf dem Router drauf hast, das ist nochmal anders.
Dann hast du, dann hast du noch, äh, Node-Data received, äh, innerhalb der letzten so und so vielen Minuten.
Also einfach nur nen Dashboard, nen publisches Dashboard zu machen, mit Prometheus und Grafana, wo drin steht, ob Host ab oder down ist.
Ähm, gestaltet sich komplizierter, als man erstmal meinen mag.
Wir haben es ja auch mal im Stream ausprobiert.
Und, so, dafür ist Zabbix halt super.
Für die klassische Variante von außen gucken, was Sache ist auf dem System, vielleicht mit dem Agent drauf, finde ich, ist Zabbix aktuell, ähm, mit das Beste.
Ein großes Problem bei Zabbix ist, ich weiß nicht, ob, ob ihr schon mal das Webinterface-Demo gesehen habt, ähm, ein großes Problem von Zabbix.
Zabbix ist, dass das Webinterface grottenschlecht ist.
Weiß nicht, ob die, ob die ne Demo, ob die ne Demo haben.
Weil, keine Ahnung, ich glaub, die haben keine Demo.
Aber das Zabbix-Webinterface ist wirklich grottenschlecht, ja.
Ähm, und auch überhaupt nicht intuitiv zu bedienen.
Guckt euch, ich mein, guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist doch, das ist doch lächerlich.
Man hat hier einfach ne Webseite genommen und nen riesen Formular drauf geklatscht mit allen Optionen.
Das könnte man viel schöner machen.
Und, wenn man Zabbix verwendet, man wird total oft mit solchen, mit solchen Crap hier, ähm, konfrontiert.
Also, sprich, wenn man nen Host aufmacht, hat man hier erstmal dieses ganze Geschiss.
Latest Data, Triggers, Event, Crafts, Screens, Web, Applications, Items, Triggers, Crafts, Discovery.
Warum muss das so kompliziert sein?
Ich mein, Zabbix kann auch unglaublich viel.
Ähm, aber das Webinterface, finde ich, ist die größte Schwäche, was, was Zabbix angeht.
So, und dann hatten wir einen im Chat, der sagt, er verwendet was?
Gang, Ganglia.
Ja.
Ist das nicht irgendein Nagios Fork?
War das nicht auch irgendein Nagios Fork?
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Ne, das sieht nicht aus wie ein Nagios Fork.
Es gibt, es gibt ja im Monitoringumfeld sau viele Nagios.
Es gibt bestimmt 5, 6 halbwegs verbreitete Nagios Forks.
Ist aber auch nicht mehr das, das, äh, E-Git.
Was ist das für ne wilde, was ist denn das für eine wilde Kombination?
C, Pearl?
P-H-P-H-P, ich wollt grad sagen P-H-F.
Das sieht aus wie P-H-F.
Äh, C, Pearl, P-H-P und Python.
Das ist eine ganz ge-
Was ist das für ne Po-
Das, das sieht aus wie ne Software, die bei ursprünglich in C entwickelt wurde.
Irgendeiner, was mit Pearl oben drauf gebastelt hat.
Dann ein neues Webinterface in P-H-P gebaut wurde.
Und dann neue Programmierer an den Start gekommen sind, die keinen Bock mehr auf Pearl hatten und jetzt Python machen wollen.
Ganz wilde, ganz, ganz wilde Mischung.
So ist es auch, Max.
Ja, das heißt, es-
Das dachte ich mir, so sieht's, so sieht's ja wirklich aus, ja.
Dergo live muss er-
Nagios ist gut.
Ich mag Nagios.
Den, den ganz klassischen, klassischen Nagios.
Ich mag den.
Vor allem, ähm, die Config ist ja das, was viel, wo viel geflamed wird bei Nagios.
Aber ich finde, die Nagios Config hat damals schon die Sachen richtig gemacht.
Wenn man, wenn man da einmal durchgeblickt hat, ist das gar nicht so wild.
Vor allem kann man die Nagios Config wunderbar, äh, versionieren.
Also, Nagios ist nicht schlecht.
Alles, aber niemals Nagios.
Doch, Nagios ist nicht schlecht.
Nagios ist, find ich,
wenn man, wenn man sich mal ein bisschen mit der Config beschäftigt hat, äh, ziemlich, ziemlich simpel.
Findest 30 Millionen Plugins.
Also, wenn man einfach nur was hinstellen will, was Jahre gehen soll, ohne sich groß drum zu kümmern, ist Nagios nicht schlecht.
Aber ich bin im, wie gesagt, so generell würde ich eher sagen Zabbix.
Ähm, so das Gesamtpaket.
Ist bei Zabbix noch besser, ähm, aber Zabbix ist halt ein riesen Ding, ja.
Was hältst du von I Chinga?
I Chinga 2, das ist ja auch irgendein Zabbix Fork, äh, nee, irgendein, ich weiß nicht, Zabbix Fork, äh, Nagios Fork.
Ich hab mit den ganzen Nagios Forks nicht allzu viel gemacht, muss ich sagen.
Wir verwenden auch seit Ewigkeiten kein Nagios mehr.
Und ich sag das als jemand, der sich halt mal 2, 3 Jahre um eine relativ große Nagios Installation gekümmert hat.
Den kenne ich mich da auch noch ganz gut aus mit.
Aber das ist schon ewig her.
Deswegen finde ich es nicht so, nicht so schlecht.
Prometheus und InfluxDB, na da hatten wir es ja gerade von.
Ähm, es hat ein bisschen unterschiedliche Anwendungszwecke.
Warte mal, Prometheus und, war das Prometheus?
InfluxDB?
Ist Prometheus, Prometheus ist doch so ein eigener, die haben doch ein eigenes Datenbankformat.
Ja, TomTrix, das ist doch fast genau das gleiche.
Ob du jetzt einen Nagios nimmst oder einen I Chinga anwendest, klar.
Da hat sich...
I Chinga, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das ausspricht.
Da hat sich schon viel getan.
Aber man sieht dem Ding schon an, im Kern, dass das mal ein Nagios gewesen ist.
Ah.
Das hat...
Allein das hier, das schreit alles noch nach Nagios.
Bloß, dass es ein bisschen moderner ist.
Und man, glaube ich, mehr über das Webinterface konfigurieren kann.
Ähm.
Ich denke auch, dass man gucken muss, dass man gucken muss, was man für was verwendet.
Prometheus und Grafana ist super für Metriken-Geschichten.
Und einfach nur Up-Down.
Ähm.
Und halt...
Von außen monitoren und gucken.
Da ist sowas wie Zabbix und Grafana immer noch ganz gut.
Aber ich finde, als Gesamtpaket ist mittlerweile Zabbix unschlagbar.
Weil Zabbix kann, seit Version 4.0, kann das Prometheus importieren.
Du brauchst quasi kein extra Zeug mehr.
Du kannst quasi aus Prometheus da Zabbix-Grafen erstellen.
Das heißt, Prometheus plus Zabbix ist aktuell so das Beste, finde ich.
So das beste Monitoring-Gesamtpaket, was es gibt.
Was mir persönlich...
...ein bisschen fehlt ist, was mir leid tut, dass es sowas nicht gibt, ist, dass es keine schöne, einfache, simple Monitoring-Lösung für daheim gibt.
Die Host-Verwaltung, DHCP, DNS und eben Monitoring.
Das ist so ein schönes, simples Gesamtpaket für daheim.
Sowas fehlt mir noch ein bisschen.
Das, was der Sache am nächsten kommt, ist tatsächlich, wenn man entweder Prometheus plus Grafana nimmt, um sich da ein bisschen was zusammenzubauen.
Aber da hast du halt auch...
Es ist für den Heimbereich...
...nicht genau das, was man braucht.
Man möchte daheim weniger Metriken sammeln.
Eigentlich möchte man daheim eher wissen, der Raspberry im Keller ist abgeschissen.
Und das geht mit Prometheus auch, aber ist nicht so schön.
Oder aber...
Danke für die ganzen Subs.
Ich seh's ja hier gerade.
Clocks HD, sechs Monate.
Huge Sub.
Und dann haben wir noch den Moonbeer Desmond.
Auch vier Monate am Start.
Dankeschön.
Progras im Stream Inc.
Ja, haben wir schon lange nicht mehr gemacht, ne?
Wir haben schon lange nichts mehr programmiert.
Zumindest als Gesamtpaket finde ich das hier eigentlich am schönsten aktuell.
Was ich halt cool finden würde, wenn es irgendwie sowas richtig Simples für den Heimbereich gäbe, wo du einfach deine Hosts anlegst.
Ähm...
Monitoring...
Nee.
Ich hab schon mal ein bisschen rumgespielt, aber das ist mir zum großen Akt.
Also meine Software, wisst ihr doch, die wird eh nie fertig.
Irgendwie.
Guckt euch das Tracker-Tool an, ja?
Da hab ich Monate dran rumgebastelt und dann ist kein Bock mehr.
Ähm...
Meine Software wird eh nie fertig.
Außer ihr müsst euch den Kramland supporten.
Ja, sowas wie Uptime-Robot ist schön.
Ähm...
Oder auch die...
Oder auch diese Geschichten, wo du quasi per Conjob immer wieder aktivierst, dass du noch lebst.
Ist eigentlich ganz nett.
Aber mir fehlt, was richtig cool wäre für den Heimbereich, eine Mischung aus...
Ähm...
Hosts...
Also sprich, dort, wo ich meine Server anlegen kann, was es alles gibt.
Was für mich auch gleich DHCP, wo es es nicht unbedingt, aber DNS-Werk cool macht.
Plus einfach ein paar Häkchen für einfachste Monitoring-Sachen.
So nach dem Motto, TCP-Port ist auf, Host pingt, Platte ist...
So was ganz...
So, keine Ahnung, so 15 Standard-Checks.
Und, ähm...
Weil das reicht im Heimbereich, ja?
Einfach so ein integriertes, kleines...
Was alles kann, ja?
So was wäre cool, wenn es das für daheim gäbe.
Weil mir ist ehrlich gesagt ein Zappix daheim ziemlich overkill.
Na gut.
Ähm...
Weiter, weiter, weiter geht's.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch für Videos heute zu bieten?
Brute FPS Masterpiece created by one person.
How is this even possible?
Der Titel, der klingt ja so was von Clickbait.
Da weiß ich mir gar nicht, ob ich mir das angucken soll.
Allerdings hat es viele Views und ganz viele...
Und Likes und alles, deswegen, wir gucken mal.
Also.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie Crysis.
Cry Engine.
Könnte sein, ja?
Peter!
Ah, Unreal ist es nicht.
Nicht, nicht.
It is a game where you can combine a wide variety of skills and abilities that will unlock true talent.
Moment.
Das passt...
Warum, warum, was will der mit nem Schwert gegen den Typ mit der Piste...
Mit dem Gewehr.
So you can unleash dazzling combo attacks.
Looks like my bullets can't be...
Ey, ich würde im Leben nicht...
Ich würde niemals...
Ich würde niemals dieses komische Gewehr verwenden, wenn das Gewehr so sehr suckt gegen so eine billige Rüstung.
Wahrscheinlich Asset Store.
Asset Store Rüstung.
Wobei, wobei das Kampfsystem definitiv nicht Asset Store ist.
Monkey L.
Hä?
Was passiert da überhaupt?
FPS und das erste, was wir erstmal sehen ist FP First Person Slasher.
Warum halten die Gegner so viel aus?
Wahrscheinlich, dass die Spielzeit sonst zu kurz wäre.
Meint ihr, das sind Asset Store Models?
Oh, ah ja, ja.
Von Intuit.
Das kann man, glaube ich, schwer beurteilen, jetzt hier aus dem Video.
Es sieht aber ziemlich repetitiv aus.
So.
Promising.
Infinite was announced at E3 2019.
It looks absolutely mind-blowing.
Genau, das ist das, das ist das, wo sie jetzt einen zweiten Teil, dann ist das doch die Geschichte, die wir uns letztens angeguckt haben, wo sie jetzt einen zweiten Teil machen wollten mit mehr Geld.
...and is coming out in Fall 2020.
So I decided to revisit the first installment and I'm still having so much fun.
Can you imagine all of this is made by one Chinese developer?
Ja.
Die Sache heute ist halt...
Also, einen Level zu bauen, also, sag mal so, ein paar Wände hinzustellen, im Asset Store ein paar Models zu kaufen, ist kein Akt.
Ja, also, man kriegt das relativ easy hin, was hinzustellen, was einfach nur gut aussieht.
Die Frage ist halt, mit was es gefüllt ist und wie das Ganze zusammenpasst.
Das heißt, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wenn das zum Beispiel ein Asset Store Model ist, dann beeindruckt mich das jetzt nicht sonderlich.
Das Kampfsystem ist aber auf jeden Fall selbst gemacht.
So was kannst du nicht einfach fertig kaufen.
Kratos, also, Kratos hat sich ganz schön verändert.
Meinst du, man kann, kann man, der GoLive, so was komplett fertig implementiertes mit austauschbaren Skills und allem?
Na gut.
Das ist advanceder, als ich mir das gedacht habe.
Der muss da definitiv viel gekauft haben, weil...
...ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass ein Typ quasi alles, alles selber macht.
Ja, also, von Sounds bis Voice Acting bis Models machen, Animationen, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Die Gegner halten aber viel zu viel aus.
Erinnert mich ein bisschen an Shadow Warrior 2.
Das war auch so ähnlich vom Kampfsystem her.
Ja, aber Stardew Valley ist ja mal komplett was anderes als das.
Auf Fiverr gekauft, vielleicht.
Moment, das hatten wir doch gerade schon.
Das hatten wir...
Also, so was hier, so ein Gebiet hier zu machen, das stelle ich mir mit einem der aktuellen...
Auch früher, das stelle ich mir nicht sonderlich kompliziert vor.
Das würde ich mir auch noch halbwegs zutrauen, wenn ich einen Level-Editor hätte.
Hier so ein quasi mit Bergen abgegrenzte Ebene mit ein paar Objekten drin zu machen.
Das kriege ich auch noch gemacht.
Vom Inhalt her dann mal wieder was anderes, ja.
Die Gegner halten halt ultra viel aus.
Das hört...
Guck mal, was der Gegner aushält.
Das sind jetzt 30 Milliarden Kafferpunkte.
Erstmal looten.
Wichtig, immer looten.
Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie...
Das sieht so...
Vielleicht muss man das gespielt, aber irgendwie sieht es ein bisschen unzusammenhängend aus.
Da kam...
Kampf, Dings, Bullet, Spawn, Gegner, Spiele.
Also, wahrscheinlich muss man es gespielt haben, aber so wahnsinnig krass hypen tut mich das jetzt nicht auf den zweiten Teil.
Seltsam, man sieht nie, wie die Gegner spawnen.
Da ist immer ein Schnitt drin.
Vielleicht sieht man auch nie, wie die Gegner spawnen.
Also, im besten Fall sieht man ja auch nicht, wie Gegner spawnen, sondern die spawnen, dass man sie nicht sieht beim Spawnen.
Kannst du eine Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration empfehlen, auch wenn man Programmieren nicht mag?
Ja, wenn du einen großen Bogen drumherum machst, warum nicht?
Es gibt bestimmt einige Bereiche, wo man drumherum kommt.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen muss man sagen, dass die Sache aus Anwendungsentwicklung und Systemintegration immer größere Überschneidungen hat.
Aber vielleicht dauert es ja noch ein bisschen.
Und wenn du die Ausbildung machst, stellst du fest, dass Programmieren...
...gar nicht so schlecht ist.
Zumindest so die Basics.
Weil es ist nicht verkehrt, wenn beispielsweise irgendein Server nicht richtig tut.
Und du kannst mal einen Blick in den Quellcode werfen und weißt so ungefähr, was da wie gerade vielleicht passiert.
Das ist nicht verkehrt, wenn du zumindest so rudimentäre Basic-Programmierkenntnisse hast.
Und viele Sachen sind heute halt auch, was Serveradministration angeht...
...sehr ver-ver-ver-ver-sourced-coded, weiß gar nicht, wie man das ausdrücken soll.
Also sprich, es ist ja heute nicht mehr so, dass man ein System einfach installiert und dann sich von Hand drauf einloggt und 20 Pakete installiert, plus den Webserver konfiguriert.
Das passiert ja meistens automatisch anhand von irgendwelchen Scripts, beziehungsweise irgendwelchen Provisionierungstools, Orchestrierungstools und die haben meistens eine eigene interne Sprache.
...und die haben meistens eine eigene interne Sprache.
Ja, das Programmieren bei uns in der Schule war auch sinnlos, aber in der Realität sieht es so aus, dass es so reines Server-Administrieren noch selten der Fall ist.
Wie gesagt, die meisten Sachen sind mittlerweile heute in irgendwelche Orchestrierungs- und Professionierungssysteme eingebunden und irgendeiner muss die Dinger programmieren.
Die Basics aus der Schule, ja das was wir in der Schule gemacht haben ist voll für den Arsch.
Wir haben in der Berufsschule irgendwas mit C gebastelt, aber das ist bei mir ja auch schon ein bisschen her und der Lehrer wusste, der hat keine Ahnung gehabt was er da macht.
Also ich weiß nicht was mit dem los war, aber der hatte keinen Plan.
Das Case hatten wir doch schon.
Das Case haben wir uns doch letztes Mal schon angeguckt.
Wie kann das sein, dass wir uns das Case letztes Mal schon angeguckt haben und es erst vor 5 Tagen hochgeladen wurde?
Ach ne, oder? Moment, hä?
Achso, ne das ist jetzt wieder ein anderes Case.
Hä?
Was auch immer.
Juckt mich nicht.
Mein Pi 4 wird mit dem Lüfter drauf nicht mehr zu warm.
55 Grad, gut ist.
Oh je, jetzt ist aber viel im Chat drin.
Programmieren als Systemintegrator, hello world.
Ja wenn du damit auskommst.
Ich bin ja da auch.
Ich bin ja wahrscheinlich der Falsche den man fragen konnte, weil ihr wisst ich programmier gerne.
Wir haben ja schon genug Programmier-Streams gemacht und ich denke das Programmieren und gerade 2020 wo die Sache immer logiklastiger wird, auch was Infrastruktur angeht und
irgendwelche Sachen die man in der Cloud aufbauen muss und sonst was, wo es immer mehr darauf ankommt, dass man das
nicht mehr quasi einzeln managt.
Das ist nicht so.
Das System, sondern eher das das gesamte, dass man da an zumindest Basic Programmierkenntnissen nicht mal vorbeikommt.
Ich bin halt auch jemand der gerne programmiert, also insofern bin ich da wahrscheinlich der Falsche für.
Also so Skripten sollte man schon können als Systemadmin.
Ja, Skripten und Programmieren, das ist ja im Prinzip das Gleiche.
Es gibt ja immer noch Leute, die der Ansicht sind, dass Skript Sprachen keine Programmier Sprachen sind, was aber totaler Blödsinn ist.
Ähm.
Ich habe die Ausbildung gemacht und hatte auch Angst vor dem Programmieren. Fazit nach zwei Jahren Ausbildung.
Ich habe bis jetzt nur Skript erstellt.
Die Basics aus der Schule sind hilfreich, braucht man nur selten.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ähm.
Das in der Schule ist für den Arsch.
Am Gymnasium in der 11.
12.
habe ich schon mal was halt schon Baum und Grafen in Java programmiert.
Oh hier, Big Brain.
Also.
Kannst du was empfehlen, was man selber?
Was kannst du?
Was empfehlen?
Wenn man selber anfangen will mit Programmieren.
Ja, das ist ein Thema, das hat man schon oft.
Ähm, ich glaube.
Hatte ich nicht dazu.
Hatte ich nicht dazu sogar ein Text Dokument gemacht, weil es schon immer öfters kommt die Frage.
Keine Ahnung, wo ich das hin habe.
Ja, kann ich empfehlen.
Also das erste, was du dir überlegen musst, ist, in welchem Bereich du was machen willst.
Willst du eher Richtung Web Entwicklung gehen?
Willst du Richtung Desktop Geschichten?
Willst du Richtung Automatisierung und Linux gehen?
Und wenn du das weißt, kann man sich auch überlegen, was eine gute Sache ist.
Also eine Sache, die definitiv nicht verkehrt ist, wenn man heute tatsächlich mit ein bisschen
Web Gedöns anfängt, also sprich eine Mischung aus CSS, HTML und JavaScript.
Da hat man auch optisch direkt was, wo man, wo man gleich was sieht.
Das ist auch schon mal nicht nicht verkehrt, weil viele fangen mit irgendwelchen Konsolen
Programmen an und ein bisschen sonst und Text Gedöns.
Das ist für einige nicht.
Nicht motivierend genug, wenn sie halt nicht sehen, dass großartig was passiert.
Und HTML, CSS und JavaScript kommt man eh nicht vorbei.
Egal wo man ist und was man heute macht.
Ein bisschen CSS, HTML, JavaScript.
Muss man, muss man überall können.
Und ansonsten finde ich ist .NET Core eine super Einstiegsplattform.
Wo man, wo man, wenn man da drinnen gut ist und es einem Spaß macht, quasi sein ganzes Leben lang
drin arbeiten kann.
Was hältst du davon, mit Arduino und Co das Programmieren zu lernen?
Ja, auch nicht schlecht, wenn man, wenn man das, das ist ja das, was ich sage.
Man muss sich erst mal überlegen, in welchem Bereich man was machen will.
Also am besten ist natürlich, man hat irgendein Problem im Kopf, was man lösen will.
Zum Beispiel Ich würde gerne zählen, wie oft ich am Tag aufs Klo gehe.
Nur mal so als Beispiel.
Dann würde ich natürlich anfangen, mit Arduino und irgendeinem Microcontroller, irgendeinem Sensor
das versuchen zu programmieren, wenn ich sage Hey, ich wollte schon immer mal eine, keine Ahnung,
eine Webseite für meinen Battlefield Server bauen, wo die Leute sehen, wer die meisten
Kills hat, dann fange ich an, vielleicht mit PHP, JavaScript, HTML, CSS oder vielleicht
auch .NET Core im Backend, je nachdem, was man hostern kann.
Es kommt immer ein bisschen darauf an, was man machen will.
Wenn man sagt, ich will eine Desktop Anwendung machen, dann fängt man wahrscheinlich mit .NET
unter Windows an und und WPF oder oder oder Windows Forms oder vielleicht sogar UWP oder man muss
gucken, was man, was man machen will.
Oben rechts.
Ich sage es euch oben rechts ist immer Essen und jetzt auch hier unten nichts, aber oben
rechts immer Essen.
Wenn es nicht kompiliert wird, ist es keine Programmiersprache.
Ja, es gibt tatsächlich Leute.
Ich weiß, dass da ein, ein.
Das ist, das ist nicht so meins, aber das ist gut.
Oh Fuck, ich habe mein Chat zugemacht.
Oh Mist, Leute.
Der Chat ist weg.
Onke S, ich war mitten, ich war mitten im Chat.
Ich kann jetzt überhaupt nichts mehr beantworten.
Ich habe Refreshed aus Versehen.
Der Chat ist weg.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Ich mache jetzt, wenn man Trick 17.
Ich mache einfach hier im Hintergrund.
Ich mache meinen Stream, meinen Stream im Hintergrund an.
So, und wenn ich jetzt den Chat refreshe, mache ich das einfach, einfach auf.
Oh, guck mal da, Michael, 50 Milliarden ist auch am Start.
Ja, ich, ich, Leute, falls sie irgendwas, falls sie irgendwie mir eine Frage geschickt haben.
Letzten fünf Minuten müssen die da noch mal stellen, weil ich den Chat aus Versehen
gefrescht habe.
Pepe Hands.
So, was ich jetzt gerade noch sagen wollte.
Es ist keine Programmiersprache, wenn es nicht kompiliert wird.
Das ist tatsächlich ein Argument, was viele Leute bringen.
So nach dem Motto Ja, das ist doch nur ein Skript.
Meine Programme werden kompiliert.
Ist alles Blödsinn, alles Blödsinn.
Beim Programmieren geht es darum, Logik quasi in Programm Code zu packen, den ein Computer ausführen kann.
Vollkommen egal, wie das am Ende läuft.
Ja.
Also eine Skript Sprache, in dem der Überbegriff ist Programmiersprache, ja, und da unten drunter
mag es so was wie interpretiertes geben, sowas wie kompiliertes geben, sowas, wo man hauptsächlich
transkriptet und sonst was, wobei die überwiegend, also der Übergang ist fließend heutzutage.
Aber der Überbegriff ist Programmiersprache.
Man kann sich auch mal die Definition davon durchlesen.
Da gibt's das ist alles Programmieren.
Ja.
Wenn man, wenn man quasi irgendwie eine Logik, äh, selbst, selbst Redstone in Minecraft ist Programmieren.
Du hast gewisse Schlüsselworte, du hast einen gewissen Rahmen, den dir die Sprache vorgibt und du drückst da drin, das, was du machen willst, mit den, mit den Mitteln der Sprache, was sie dir zur Verfügung stellt, aus, dass dein Computer das macht, was du willst.
Und das ist alles weder besser, schlechter noch sonst was.
Und nur weil es kompiliert wird, ist es nicht besser.
Ein, ein Plötzchen, sind alles, ist alles Programmieren.
Ja.
Max, du hast versprochen, letzte Woche Titanfall.
Nee, hab ich nicht gemacht.
Programmiere mit CSS.
Jetzt gibt's sogar Leute, die programmieren in HTML.
html und das ist auch so was wo ich sagen muss er streng genommen streng genommen müsste man
sagen dass weder css noch html programmieren im eigentlichen sinne ist weil wirklich großartige
konstrukte um da den ablauf zu kontrollieren oder was hat man nicht aber ich sehe das bei
unseren azubis auch nicht so eng wenn da irgendwie einer sagt er programmiert html oder css
soll das halt sagen man muss sich nicht an jedem scheiß aufhängen und dazu kommt das eigentlich
html und css alleine heutzutage gar nicht mehr funktioniert man kommt also und javascript gar
nicht aus ja delphi ist heute nicht mehr so nicht mal so angesagt aber also wenn du dir mal dort
net core anguckt mittlerweile haben die da einiges haben die ganz schön aufgeholt in der richtung du
kannst mittlerweile auch dort
net core anwendung komplett self-contained kompilieren zu einem zu einem executable wo
alles drin ist es ist natürlich größer als ein delphi programm weil die ganze dotnet runtime
drin ist wenn man einfach nur was haben will was klein ist und standalone funktioniert ist
go wirklich gut also das ist für mich so der das große alleinstellungsmerkmal von go du
programmierst einmal was kompiliert das ganze läuft auf jedem linux
seit 2 4 oder so kann mir wer hier zufällig sagen wie ich gdm dazu bringe meinen ersten monitor zu
benutzen verwende gar kein display manager keine ahnung da kommen wir uns mal das ist das video
passt ja gerade zum thema how to make money with code ich erwarte mir ehrlich gesagt nicht allzu
viel bei so einem video ich erwarte mir ehrlich gesagt nicht allzu viel ich gehe mal davon aus
dass er jetzt dass der jetzt so sachen kommt wie genau pfeiffer pfeiffer werden da jetzt wahrscheinlich
Fiverr
oder was könnte er da noch erzählen
es ist gar nicht so einfach
als Programmierer
indem sie Geld zumachen, man könnte
irgendwelche Bootstrap
Templates oder so Gedöns basteln
wie könnte man
easy Geld verdienen, also ich glaube ohne Scheiß
also der einfachste
die einfachste Variante
als Programmierer
der daheim sitzt Geld zu verdienen
ist
Dr. Evil Cookie Smartphone App
ich glaube die einfachste Variante
daheim, wenn man fit ist
und ein bisschen risikobereit ist
man
programmiert sich eine Trading Bot
man bastelt sich
man bastelt sich irgendwie
eine
Crypto Trading Bot
und hofft drauf, dass man
gut programmiert hat und es gut läuft
und dann easy money
es kann natürlich auch in die Hose gehen
okay gucken wir uns mal an, was er uns erzählt
oder was auch eine super Variante ist
man macht es wie Cristiano Ronaldo
und packt auf seine Webseite
einen JavaScript Monero Miner
eine Kalle
there are tons of ways to go about this
and that's the really cool thing about learning how to code
because you're pretty much only limited
by your creativity
and there's virtually no limit to the
earning power you can create on your own
we all know about Facebook, Google, Amazon
and even things as simple as that Flappy Bird game
these were all developed by people who knew
stimmt, Flappy Bird
du kannst auch Glück haben und ein
virales Hype Game produzieren
aber die Chancen sind doch relativ gering
how to code
but telling you that you can make money from
creating the next Facebook is not super useful
so let's get to the ways that
I believe are the easiest and most profitable
first off
freelancing
freelancing, contracting, whatever you wanna call it
ja gut
es heißt im Endeffekt
arbeiten für sein Geld
um es mal auf deutsch zu sagen
hm
das ist logisch, dass man damit Geld verdienen kann
to use the classic websites like freelancer.com
Upwork or Fiverr
because even though you can definitely make some money on there
I've rarely seen any offers out there that great
and that means that
It's that the outreach
late for those projects that I've seen is fairly low
so there are two ways to do this better in my opinion
first option is to ask your family and friends
and
and find a few people that have small businesses
and then build a new website
or prove their existing website
Oh, Frontend.
Gibt es wirklich Leute, die es schaffen,
an einem Notebook, also generell an einem Rechner zu programmieren,
ohne eine Maus zu haben?
Ich weiß, die richtig krassen Pros, ja,
die verwenden auch Vim nur auf der Home-Row
und die gehen nie aus ihrem Editor raus.
Aber die Realität sieht halt anders aus,
dass man 50% der Zeit eigentlich in einem Browser verbringt
und im Browser nachgucken muss,
offizielle Dokumentation, irgendwelche Stack-Overflow-Geschichten,
weil man den Kram aus dem Kopf nicht weiß.
Und Trackpad ist halt,
in Browser-Bedienung ist es halt auch nicht schön.
Es gibt keinen gescheiten Browser in Emacs.
Wäre schön, wenn es das gibt.
But don't ask them if they want you to do this.
Just do it for them and then show up
and show them what you've created for them.
Once you've done that, you can...
Also, ich kann mir vorstellen,
wenn man die richtigen Firmen raussucht,
dann funktioniert das.
Aber wenn ich mir überlege,
bei uns, wenn ich mal hier gucke,
was es hier beispielsweise gibt, so.
Und ich war letztens auf einer Webseite von,
ich glaube, das war so ein lokaler Elektronikladen hier.
Die Seite war absoluter Shit.
Ich glaube, dem ist gar nicht mal bewusst,
dass die Seite scheiße ist.
Wenn ich da jetzt mit einer neuen Webseite hingekommen wäre,
hätte er gesagt, oh, das sieht aber cool aus.
Aber wenn man dafür Geld bezahlen muss,
dann will er es nicht haben.
You can ask them if they'd be willing to pay a certain amount
for their new and improved website.
And this would be a way in which you can build up
your own contracting business.
You essentially build a network of clients
that can then hopefully refer you to other new clients.
And this process is a bit tough to get started with.
But once you've got it going,
it can be a bit of a snowball effect.
Also,
this video is sponsored by...
Das hat er richtig businessmäßig gemacht, oder?
...it can be a bit of a snowball effect.
Ja.
Hacking, hacking, hacking, hacking, hacking, hacking.
Ach, übrigens!
Also, this video is sponsored by Kite.
Was?
Kite is an auto-completion engine for Python
that integrates...
What?
...with tons of different text editors
like Atom, Visual Studio Code, Sublime, Vim and PyCharm.
Feature number one, ranked completions.
And I sort of mentioned this,
but Kite's completions are sorted by relevance
instead of popularity or alphabet.
Macht er gerade Werbung?
Für eine KI-Auto-Completion-Engine?
Was es nicht alles gibt?
...or anything else.
And they use machine learning to determine
what would be the most relevant suggestion at this time.
And that's how they're able to come up with better suggestions
...and better suggestions.
than any other system that I've used.
Feature number two, line of code completions.
And that means that it's able to actually...
Soll ich mal was sagen?
Wenn man halt in der ordentlichen Programmiersprache programmiert,
die halt nicht eines der Hauptfeature hat,
dass sie dynamisch ist,
dann funktioniert das einfach so.
Dann braucht man keine KI-trainierte
Auto-Complete-Geschichte.
Eines der großen Features von Python ist eben,
dass es so dynamisch ist.
Und dadurch, dass es dynamisch ist,
ist es halt mit Auto-Complete an vielen Stellen nicht so einfach,
weil die Analyse-Engine im Hintergrund nicht weiß,
welcher Typ, welche Variable oder welcher Typ
gerade zurückgegeben wird von welcher Funktion.
Deswegen ist der TypeScript so beliebt,
was JavaScript angeht.
Das geht in Python halt nur bis zu einem gewissen Level.
Einfach weil es die Sprache nicht hergibt.
Nimmt man irgendwas Typisiertes,
wie C-Sharp oder, keine Ahnung, Java,
da ist es überhaupt kein Problem.
Es gibt KI-trainierte Auto-Completion-Engine.
Was es nicht alles gibt.
... Lines of Code for you.
Feature number three, Intelligent Snippets.
Using their machine learning,
they're able to actually suggest placeholder values
for when you're calling different functions.
And lastly, feature number four,
which is called Copilot.
And Copilot allows you to no longer have to Google
Python Documentation,
because Copilot allows you to see the documentation
right within your text editor or IDE.
Das kann jeder anrischlich in der Ehe.
... that you download this and give it a try.
There'll be a link in the description.
The second tip that I have is a goldmine,
if you get really good at it.
And that is to build enterprise software.
And what that means is essentially...
Enterprise, Java.
... you'll spend your time...
Enterprise Software heißt Java.
Zumindest oftmals.
... analyzing different companies
and trying to figure out ways in which you could...
Aber ganz ehrlich, zumindest hier ist es so,
die meisten Firmen, also wenn es nicht gerade wirklich kleine Läden sind,
sag mal sowas wie HardwareRat oder so,
die verwenden keine custom zusammengestrickte Software
von einem Ein-Mann-Programmiertyp.
Die kaufen entweder was Fertiges
oder die haben ein eigenes Entwicklerteam
oder lassen sich halt von irgendjemand,
von irgendwie einem größeren Anbieter was entwickeln,
wo es dann halt auch Support-Garantie
und neue Features auf Bezahlung gibt.
Wie nennt man denn solche Tools,
die wie eben rechts die ganzen Infos anzeigen?
Das ist irgendein Editor-Plugin.
Also die meisten größeren IDEs können das defaultmäßig schon.
Dann gehst du halt drauf,
und drückst dann, keine Ahnung, ich sag jetzt mal F12,
und da zeigt es dir die Dokumentation von der jeweiligen Funktion an.
Essentially you try to automate tasks for them
so that you save the company time and money.
An example of this would be something that I noticed
when I was working at a supermarket here in Sweden.
In the fruit and vegetable section,
every day they get shipments of fruit
that get scanned into the computer.
Ich mein, Funk, mit kleinen Firmen,
mit kleinen Firmen,
funktioniert das.
Ich mein, guckt euch mal an.
Bei Hardware-Rad verwenden sie ja auch das,
zwei von mir gestrickte Tools.
Das heißt, für kleine Läden geht das.
Und man könnte den Kram auch definitiv verkaufen.
Da müsste ich aber Support anbieten.
Und, äh,
ne,
das ist ja eher so ein Ding nebenbei gewesen.
...me in this case,
then takes us out into the store
and places it on the shelves.
Then at the end of the day,
one of the staff goes around and estimates
how much should be ordered of each item for the next day
and then manually types this into the computer.
But the system keeps track of sold items,
ordered items and also received items.
Meaning that if you could make a program
that just subtracts sold items from received items,
then you'll get a way better idea
of how much to order for the next day.
And if you add in a bit of...
Hab eine Idee, die viele Leute nutzen können.
Ja, das ist ja bei ganz vielen Sachen
das Grundgesetz.
Ja, das ist ja bei ganz vielen Sachen.
...Machine Learning that uses weather forecasts
and previous year stats to predict
how much is likely to be bought of each item
in the coming day.
Jetzt wird's advanced, ja.
...a software that could potentially save the store
millions in terms of out-of-date products.
And that also means that they wouldn't need
a person to go around and do the evening checks.
So you could potentially save the company
from having to pay one employee
plus significantly lower the cost of wasted fruit.
Blockchain braucht noch, ja.
The reason for...
...the reason for bringing up that example
is just to kind of showcase that
by building these systems,
it's quite easy to then reason or motivate
a certain price for that system.
Because if you can show that your system
can save that company $10,000 in a year,
then it's really easy to motivate
that they should pay you $10,000
for that piece of software.
Because yes, in the first year,
they'll still lose those $10,000.
But in the next year,
they'll be making or saving $10,000.
The next year, they'll save $10,000
and so on and so forth.
Which means that it's then pretty easy to motivate...
In der Theorie her, ja.
...for that piece of software.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob ich das kaufen würde von einem Ein-Mann-Laden.
I haven't done this myself.
Vor allem, wenn das was ist,
was mir quasi, wo es um Millionenbeträge geht.
I've thought about it and I want to do it,
but it is quite a lot of effort that goes into it.
But again, if you get good at it,
then you'll be really well off.
Next is to develop apps.
And this is something where it has crazy potential
to make you a lot of money.
But it comes with a giant if-statement.
And that is, it can make you money
if you come up with a good idea.
Else, it won't really amount to much.
Ja gut, das stimmt.
Das ist aber bei allen Sachen so.
Du brauchst eine gute Idee.
Das ist ja fast immer so.
Even though that might be a little bit of a worn-out example by now,
it's a really good example because...
A game like Flappy Bird can be created by like a 12-year-old
who's learning how to create games
and that's the first app that they create.
And Naval Ravikant talks about
the benefits of professions like this
where the inputs and the outputs are highly disconnected.
And that's exactly what this is.
Creating Flappy Bird is pretty simple.
Theoretisch, also mal angenommen,
mal angenommen, man hat ein paar Ideen.
Das Schwierige ist ja nicht unbedingt jetzt,
also aus seiner Sicht gute Ideen,
kann man viele haben.
Was schwierig abzuschätzen ist,
ob die guten Ideen, die man sich so ausdenkt,
ob die auch für möglichst viele anderen
auch gute Ideen sind.
Also sprich, nur weil ich mir jetzt was ausgedacht habe,
was ich für cool finde,
heißt das nicht, dass 50 Millionen Leute auch denken,
oh, das ist aber was Gutes.
Das heißt, theoretisch könnte man doch sich hinsetzen,
ein paar Sachen überlegen
und einfach 15 easy-billig-Apps rausbringen,
in der Hoffnung,
dass eine dieser Apps voll abgeht.
Allerdings die Chancen sind wahrscheinlich doch relativ gering.
Wahrscheinlich werden die meisten Apps keinen Menschen interessieren.
But the potential of a game like that in terms of the potential money
that can be earned from it is pretty much infinite.
And that's kind of the allure of this.
The fact that something so simple can become so valuable.
And in this case, creating a billion-dollar app
does not have to be difficult.
Coming up with the...
Wir machen einfach Coin Master.
The idea for that app, though,
that's where the difficulty lies.
I definitely think that it's worth to dabble in app development,
because it can have those outsized results,
and if nothing else,
making something that you yourself want is fun.
Moment.
And if nothing else,
making something that you yourself want...
Ich dachte erst, es ist ein Breath of the Wild-Icon,
ist es aber gar nicht.
Es sah halt wirklich sehr ähnlich aus.
Und ist fun.
Also, as an aside, you can make a decent living from having apps...
Ja, Andi, eindeutig, weil einfach nur im App Store sein bringt dir ja nix.
Es sind 30 Billiarden Apps im App Store,
und davon wird kaum eine installiert.
...in your apps, given that you make a few apps
and have quite a few downloads on those apps.
Lastly, a few honorable mentions.
Creating courses, and as soon as I hear, like, online course,
I straight away think of the Get Rich Quick-type course,
and I can't stand that.
I feel like that's sort of empty knowledge.
Yeah, das gibt's ja in Deutsch auch genug.
Du musst jetzt nur in diese WhatsApp-Gruppe kommen und wirst Millionär.
Ja, ist klar.
But you're making money by teaching them how to make money,
and it just doesn't feel right to me.
But teaching someone how to code is different.
Because you're equipping them with a skill that pretty much infinitely increases their earning power.
If they learn to code, they'll be able to make a great living.
Da bin ich nicht der Richtige für.
It's quantitative knowledge.
Tutorial-Kurse zu machen.
Get-Rich-Quick-Courses, which teach qualitative knowledge.
And then there's also coding competitions,
which I guess you can use to make some extra money.
There's pretty much coding competitions going on all year round,
so I guess that can be a good way to make some extra money.
I haven't tried it myself, so I don't know too much about it.
Das ist nicht so einfach.
Da gibt's ja Konkurrenz.
Es gibt ja immer von verschiedenen Firmen, von Google gibt's auch so was,
da könnten wir uns übrigens mal ein paar Sachen angucken.
Das ist tatsächlich ziemlich cool.
Da gibt's ja diese Capture-the-Flag-Challenges.
Es gibt einige.
Man könnte schon fast sagen, es ist programmiert E-Sport.
Allerdings muss man da halt auch mal ehrlich sagen,
die Konkurrenz ist da halt schon ziemlich krass.
Da sitzen keine Noobs, die man da verarschen kann.
Also ich würde sogar davon ausgehen,
bei diesen Competitions sitzen Leute,
die besser sind als du, ich und die meisten der Leute,
die hier so unterwegs sind.
So einfach ist das nicht, nebenbei Coding-Competition und Easy Money.
Hört sich nach mir E-Sport an, als es die OVL ist.
Overwatch, seit YouTube, ist für mich eh vorbei.
Es gibt auch WordPress-Plugins,
so kannst du ein paar Plugins für WordPress-Websites machen,
und dann kannst du einen Preis dafür haben,
und dann kannst du sie verkaufen auf der WordPress-Store.
Ich habe das noch nicht selbst gemacht,
aber ich kenne einige Leute, die das machen
und ein bisschen Geld davon machen.
Und das ist einer dieser ziemlich populären Wege,
extra Geld vom Code zu verdienen.
Aber ich habe es noch nicht versucht,
also weiß ich es nicht ganz.
Aber ja, das sind meine Tipps,
wie man Geld vom Code verdient.
Das war kein schlechtes Video,
aber es war ziemlich naheliegend.
Ich meine, im Endeffekt ging es darum,
sich was Gutes einzufallen lassen,
und es dann zu verkaufen.
Logisch, ja.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch zu bieten?
Blizzard, wir müssen reden.
Erster Eindruck von einem Linux-Smartphone,
ich glaube, das Ding suckt, Alter.
Long Range Sniping Battlefield 3.
Weiß jemand, wie Anthem 2.0,
oh, das ist gut.
Das müssen wir jetzt gucken.
Anthem 2.0, das wird wahrscheinlich auch wieder,
geht komplett in die Hose.
Weiß jemand, wie die Zuschauerzahlen sind?
YouTube OVL Viewer Count.
Aha, okay.
Overwatch League Opening Week on YouTube
fails to match Twitch View.
Das war klar.
30.000, ah, das ist schlecht.
Alter, ist das schlecht, 30.000.
Die hatten ansonsten teilweise 100, 120k und sowas,
nur auf Twitch.
Nice.
Nicht nice, ja, doch, oder je nachdem,
wie man es sieht, wenn man sehen möchte,
wie Blizzard weiter abkackt, okay.
Allerdings haben die mit Sicherheit auch viel Kohle bekommen,
dafür, dass sie das jetzt exklusiv auf YouTube bringen.
Ähm, 30k ist schon lächerlich.
Wie viel, wie viel hat Montana...
Wie viel, wie viel hat Montana Black an Zuschauer?
Ach, 30.000 weniger.
30.000 weniger.
Okay, es sind nur 30.000 weniger.
Okay, hier, ähm,
63.000.
63.000, ähm,
ja, so im Durchschnitt meine ich jetzt.
63.000, das ist halt,
das ist die Hälfte von dem,
was sie teilweise in den Opening Streams
haben, gehabt haben auf Twitch.
Allerdings, ähm,
muss ich halt sagen, dass,
ich hab's ja auf Twitch schon kaum
geguckt, allerdings
jetzt auf YouTube werde ich's
mir nicht angucken. Eines der coolsten Sachen war ja,
ist ja bei Twitch eh immer der Twitch-Tat dabei.
Mit CS muss man's
gar nicht erst vergleichen. CS war schon
immer deutlich
größer. Was,
Bundesnachrichtendienst, die haben ein Github-
Repo, allen Ernstes?
Was gibt's denn da?
...
Bundesnachrichtendienst.
Spielst du Overwatch?
Nein, schon lange nicht mehr.
Das ist inoffiziell. Ah,
Bundesnachrichtendienst Software
Reversing Malware Analysis
Recruiting Challenge.
Oder erst mal nen Zip.
Antwortbogen?
Ah, wahrscheinlich ist
hier das drinne, was man hierfür
zum Entschlüsseln braucht. Das können wir uns mal
wirklich im Stream angucken.
Ich geh aber davon aus, dass ich
es wahrscheinlich bei den höheren
Levels oder überhaupt voll verkacken werde.
Weil je nachdem, was da drinne ist.
Mal gucken,
wie anspruchsvoll der Bundesnachrichtendienst ist.
Das können wir uns echt mal im Stream
angucken. Wir schreiben das mal auf.
Die E-Karriere.
Ah, sehr gut. Gibt's nicht mehr.
Lösen Sie die
Aufgaben, soweit sie dazu in der Lage sind
und legen sie in den ausgefüllten Antwortbogen unserer
Stellanzeigemittel-Kennziffer.
Alle für die Aufgaben notfalls sowie
die Antwortbogen als PDF finden Sie
im unten verlinkten ZIP-Archiv.
Das probieren wir mal
unter Linux dann aus.
Das merke ich mir.
Das gucken wir uns mal an.
Wahrscheinlich ist das irgendein
Schau, irgendwie ne Bundestrojaner
am Start.
Anthem 2.0
Der Maurice wieder.
Die sind ja mit ihrem eigenen
Update-Programm maßlos hinterher.
Der lang erwartete Paukenschlag.
BioWare will das Spiel tatsächlich
komplett neu erfinden.
Und ich hab mir den Tobi eingeladen, um darüber
zu reden, ob das...
Wie viele Leute hat die GameStar eigentlich?
Ich guck mir öfters Videos von der GameStar an,
aber außer so drei, vier Leuten sitzen da immer
andere. Ich kenn die alle gar nicht.
... und wenn ja, wie?
Tobi, hallo. Hi, grüß dich.
Wir sind beide so ein bisschen Anthem-Geschädigte.
Wir haben das zum Release
viel gespielt.
Bisschen leise, oder?
Soll ich noch ein bisschen lauter machen?
Oder passt das so?
Vorsichtiger Hoffnung, es ist ja immerhin
noch BioWare gewesen, trotz gewisser
negativer Vorzeichen.
Erzähl doch mal ein wenig. Du hast das
sogar noch länger gespielt als ich.
Ja, BioWare. BioWare ist für mich
schon seit ein paar Jahren vorbei.
Und warum hat es dich dann
doch verloren?
Das letzte gute Spiel,
was BioWare rausgebracht hat, war
Dragon Age 1.
Oder? Mal gucken.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, was sie noch alles rausgebracht haben.
Nicht, dass ich Mist erzähle.
Ähm...
Hallo?
Irgendwie eine ordentliche Übersicht über BioWare
Games.
List of BioWare
Video Games. Okay.
Also,
was haben wir denn da alles Schönes?
Sucked. Sucked.
Äh...
Ah, gecancelt.
War ganz okay.
Ich hab's nicht gespielt.
Soll ganz okay gewesen sein, aber
bei weitem nicht das, was man sich da erhofft
hatte. Ähm...
Ist gecancelt.
Keine Ahnung.
Sucked. Also Mass Effect hat mir das
Einser ganz gut gefallen. Der Rest war echt nicht
meins. Mittlerweile
soll's ja ganz okay sein, weil sie neue Enden
nachgereicht haben und sowas, aber...
Okay, ich glaub wir fangen mal von
der anderen Richtung an.
Eines der besten Games ever.
Äh... Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum.
Was das ist. Ähm...
Auch richtig gut.
War nicht mein Fall, muss ich sagen.
Ähm...
War damals auch übelst nice.
Sagt mir nix mehr großartig.
Richtig gut.
Moment, die haben ein Sonic
Game gemacht. Ernsthaft.
Dragon Age.
Auch extrem gut.
Das war...
Ich muss euch sagen, ich glaube das hier war
das letzte, letzte richtig gute BioWare
Game. Da waren sie erst ganz
frisch bei EA und EA hatte noch nicht
mehr so viel Einfluss da drauf.
Ähm... Auf das Game.
Die kamen quasi erst am Ende
dazu. Ähm...
Und alles was danach
kam
ist für'n Arsch. Okay.
Dragon Age 1 war
finde ich echt nicht schlecht.
Es ist nicht gut gealtert, ja.
Die Grafik
sieht heute ein bisschen kacke aus.
Ich hab's letztens erst wieder gesehen bei
Dance Gaming auf Twitch.
Ähm...
Es sieht halt schon
ein bisschen in die Jahre gekommen aus.
Also
nach EA war's vorbei, ja.
Könnte man so sagen.
Was in Dragon Age halt richtig cool
war, dass du das Gefühl hattest, dass
deine Party halt gelebt hat.
So in Anführungsstrichen, ja.
Die hatten coole Dialoge, die hatten Interaktionen
und alles drum herum.
Das war halt sehr, sehr nice.
Und die haben aber das
Schöne aus etwas älteren Rollenspielen.
Weniger Rüstung
gleich mehr Rüstung.
... die 50 Stunden gespielt, was glaub ich
ziemlich lange ist.
Ich wollte, ich wollte, dass
das Spiel gut ist, weil
die Movement-Mechaniken,
das Rumfliegen, das
Sprinten, das hat sich alles echt gut
angefühlt. Es ist das Iron-Man-Spiel, das
wir immer wollten. Genau, es ist das Iron-Man-Spiel, genau.
Aber... Ich glaube, das war auch das einzige
bei Anthem, was was getaugt hat.
Ich hab's von Anfang an gesagt, dass
Anthem der absolute Rohrkrepierer wird,
also wurde es, weil das Spiel von Anfang an
so retortenmäßig ausgesehen hat.
Ein bisschen davon,
bisschen davon, und eigentlich weiß man
nicht so genau, was es sein sollte.
Und jetzt hat sich herausgestellt, intern war das
genau das Gleiche, genauso wie es gewirkt hatte.
Man hat zwar coole Trailer gemacht, aber
im Prinzip hatten sie intern auch keine Ahnung,
was sie eigentlich machen wollten.
Und genauso hat's auch gewirkt.
Was dann immer mehr mit der Zeit,
immer mehr dann auch in mein Bewusstsein
gekrochen ist, alles andere ist
halt einfach nicht gut. Das Schießen macht keinen Spaß,
die Loot...
Och Gott, wenn ich sowas schon sehe,
dieses krampfhafte Reinprügeln
von irgendwelchen
Roleplay-Mechanics, die die Spiele überhaupt
nicht brauchen, die aber dazu führen,
dass man halt schöne, schöne
Easy-Content-Updates liefern kann, dass die Leute
das möglichst lange spielen, plus halt noch
schöne
Microtransactions und
schöne DLC-Geschichten
und Content
und Abos und sonst was verkaufen kann,
das schadet den Games
mehr, als es ihnen bringt.
Überhaupt keine Abwechslung, total lahme Waffen,
alles einfach nur irgendwelche Sturmgewehre, Shotguns,
nichts Besonderes
und, naja, gut,
die Story war dann auch eher so
sehr...
Eigentlich ist es ja mal eines der Sachen, die
sowohl BioWare mal
gut konnte, storymäßig,
Blizzard hatte das auch gut drauf.
Was man von BioWare erwartet, jedenfalls.
Das war auch nicht, was versprochen wurde,
da wurde wirklich so eine Revolution...
Xeroxino, ja, es wird mal wieder Zeit, aber
Bahn funktioniert in letzter Zeit tatsächlich ganz gut.
So gut, wie es funktionieren kann.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Samus Climber!
IIQ-Sub.
Storytellings in einem Multiplayer-Spiel, also
Pustekuchen.
Das hat mich so ein bisschen verbittert, weil ich finde,
was BioWare, was EA
beworben hat...
Das sieht schon ultra lahm aus, oder?
Also, man hat uns da...
Das nächste Forever-Game versprochen.
Den Bob Dylan der Videospiele.
Das ist immer noch großartig.
Fantastisches Zitat.
Das haben die ja wirklich gesagt.
Bob Dylan der Videospiele.
So geil ist es so.
Da sieht man mal, dass
Marketing-Bullshit in keinem
Verhältnis zu dem eigentlichen Produkt stehen muss.
Man hat gesagt, ja, Spiel, das wird
euch für tausend Stunden beschäftigen.
Am Ende, für viele Leute,
war es, glaube ich, nicht mehr als fünf Stunden,
weil es sich halt...
Weil es ist nichts mehr gekommen.
Bist du an die Quest mit den Grabmählern gekommen?
Ich glaube, da sind schon viele ausgeschieden.
Wurde dann auch ein bisschen gepatcht, aber trotzdem...
Keine Ahnung, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Was war die Quest mit den Grabmählern?
War das irgend so eine
500-Stunden-Grind-Quest, um zu verstecken,
dass man kein Content mehr hatte, oder was?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe es nicht gespielt.
Aber trotzdem ihm nochmal eine Chance gegeben.
Es hat er dann BioWare eine Weile lang
versucht, sag ich mal, mit
eher kleineren, additiven
Inhaltsupdates das Spiel
wieder auf Kurs zu bringen.
Sie haben auch manche Sachen durchaus sinnvoll
gepatcht, also es ist so ein bisschen
komfortabler geworden.
Jeder Patch hat auch wieder Probleme mit sich gebracht.
Zweimal haben sie zum Beispiel die Loot-Schraube versehentlich
nach oben gedreht und haben es dann wieder korrigiert,
obwohl die Fans sie angefleht haben,
macht das nicht.
Aber das waren alles keine Revolutionen.
Und dann kam endlich, mit viel Verspätung,
dieses große Inhaltsupdate der Cataclysm.
Da hast du reingeschaut, hat dich aber auch nicht lange gehalten.
Richtig, genau.
Das war ganz nett,
aber mehr halt auch nicht.
Also es kamen dann zum Beispiel endlich mal
ein paar Waffen, die ein bisschen
more exciting waren.
Eines muss man sagen,
technisch gut gemacht sieht es ja schon aus.
Also wie sagt man so schön?
Production Value, ja?
Also das sieht schon aus, als haben da keine
Noobs dran gearbeitet.
Aber vom Inhalt her ist es halt für den Arsch.
Irgendwelche ballistischen Schusswaffen, sondern auch was mit irgendwelchen Blitzen
und irgendwas, was dann so
Klingen verschossen hat, war alles ganz cool.
Aber das Event an sich
hat halt an dem eigentlichen Problem,
was Anthem hat, nichts geändert.
Nämlich, dass
die Gameplay-Loop,
die macht einfach keinen Spaß.
Und jetzt haben sie ja tatsächlich
endlich gesagt, dass sie wirklich
größer rangehen wollen.
Interessanterweise auch, was erstmal bedeutet,
das Spiel wird jetzt auch erstmal weiter
tote Hose haben. Also sie haben
damit auch gesagt, das kann ich in dem Fall sogar nachvollziehen.
Die haben ja ihren eigenen
Content-Plan nicht eingehalten.
Sowas passiert, wenn man Programmierern
keine Vorgabe gibt.
Naja, eher umgedreht.
Wenn du
keinen Plan hast, was gemacht werden soll,
das ist ja nicht die Schuld
der Leute, die das Ganze programmieren.
Oder ja,
doch, könnte man
schon so sehen. Aber ich meine,
es ist ja nicht die Aufgabe der Leute, die die Sache
entwickeln,
das Große und Ganze sich vorher
zu überlegen, dass
was Zusammenhängendes rauskommt.
Also,
vor allem, wenn du halt morgen das machen sollst
und heute das.
Wir machen jetzt keine weiteren Seasons
oder sowas, wir konzentrieren uns jetzt voll darauf,
das Spiel wirklich in ihren eigenen
Worten neu zu erfinden.
Da muss ich ganz kurz einhaken,
da wäre es vielleicht aber tatsächlich auch der bessere
Move gewesen, von EA so eine
Schiene zu fahren. Kanalpunkte.
Ja, zum Thema
Kanalpunkte kann ich nur sagen, ich habe es mir noch nicht
wirklich angeguckt.
Ich habe das Default-Zeug
drin.
Also richtig
Loop-Style.
Ja, bei Final Fantasy XIV hat sich das gelohnt.
Final Fantasy XIV ist jetzt
ganz gut geworden.
Ich fand ja ganz interessant, die interessanteste Aussage fand ich
eigentlich, dass sie gesagt haben, diesmal werden
wir das tun, wovon wir beim ersten Mal schon gerne
mehr gemacht hätten, nämlich einem fokussierten
Team wirklich Zeit geben,
zu iterieren und zu testen.
Das ist eine Aussage,
die hätte, finde ich, viel früher kommen sollen,
weil es war allen klar, dass das nicht möglich ist.
Ja gut, aber das Game hat Geld gekostet,
das muss raus und ein bisschen Kohle.
Aether Anthem 2,
nee, das ist Season 2, das ist ein Update.
Klar, klar, klar.
Max, darf ich fragen, wo du deine
Domain her hast? Hier,
da habe ich die ja.
Es gibt aber viele, ups,
es gibt aber viele günstige
Domain-Hoster. Das ist der billigste, den ich
damals über eine Suche gefunden habe.
Das Problem bei denen
ist, dass der DNS keine API hat, das heißt
sprich, wenn man
sein, wenn man sein Crypt-Zertifikate
über DNS-Challenge machen will,
dann geht das nicht richtig.
Deswegen habe ich mein DNS jetzt auf Cloudflare
laufen.
Ich habe noch so PR-Statements,
dass irgendwie, na, das wird schon alles
irgendwie wieder und mit dem Cataclysm
werden wir euch endlich zeigen, wozu Anthem
alles in der Lage ist und so, na, war
auch gesagt. Aber trotzdem...
Hält euch mal auf, man sieht eigentlich
nur immer sinnlos Leute rumfliegen, weil das wohl
die einzige Mechanik ist, die irgendwie Spaß macht.
Das ist für einen Arsch.
Nicht schlecht. Achso, und übrigens noch was, Leute,
wenn ihr euch Domains kauft,
auch wenn man das offiziell,
sagen wir mal in Anführungsstrichen, nicht darf,
man kann sich da auch
ohne Probleme mit Fake-Namen registrieren,
weil die ganzen Domain-
Registrarer haben überhaupt kein Interesse
dran, euch
nennen wir es mal zu bannen,
wegen Fake-Namen oder das überhaupt auch nur
rauszukriegen, weil dann bezahlt ihr ja kein Geld mehr.
Das heißt, registriert euch einfach
mit Fake-Namen, dann braucht ihr kein Geld
für WhoIsProtection bezahlen.
Wird das jetzt wirklich mal solche
Aussagen ein bisschen kommen, finde ich.
Ja,
aber bisher würde ich sagen, too little, too late.
Ja, also das
da muss man ganz klar sagen,
Taten zählen, das werden
sie jetzt beweisen müssen. Sie haben gesagt,
in den nächsten Monaten werden sie
daran arbeiten, das könnte also sogar noch
einen Release 2020 bedeuten.
Die müssen ja,
das Game ist
dead, also wenn die das irgendwie
noch retten wollen, können sie sich
fünf Jahre Zeit lassen.
Aber kommen wir doch mal ein bisschen dahin,
was sie ändern wollen und was sie ändern
sollten. Und sie haben ja schon, glaube
ich, recht gut gesagt,
was so das Hauptfeedback war,
dass es zu wenig Progression,
zu wenig geile Beute und zu wenig
gutes Endgame gab.
Würdest du zustimmen, dass das auch genau
die Kritikpunkte sind?
Auf jeden Fall. Und sie sprechen ja auch, glaube ich,
später auch nochmal im Statement die
Core-Gameplay-Loop an.
Und genau, ich finde, das ist da,
wo sie wirklich ran müssen.
Dem Spiel fehlt es
jetzt, weil das, wie gesagt, ich hab's
nicht selbst gespielt, nur von allem,
was ich gesehen hab, das ist
einfach nur drumherum gedockt.
Dem Spiel fehlt's einfach
an Seele, dem Spiel fehlt's an
Identität und dem Spiel fehlt's halt einfach an
an das, was es irgendwie
rausstechen lässt. Das wirkt einfach
wie lieblos zusammengeschustert.
Und das wird man auch mit
mehr Endgame nicht großartig retten
können.
Ja, vor allem erstmal anfangen
und dann musst du dir überlegen,
was du machen willst. Willst du
Web-Anwendungen machen?
Was willst du machen?
Was ist der Grund überhaupt, warum du in Pyres anfangen willst?
Ich würde
mich freuen, wenn Anthem 2.0
wirklich ein schönes Spiel wird,
aber die haben da echt eine Menge Arbeit vor sich.
Ich glaube nicht, Anthem ist
vorbei.
Damit die Leute wieder ins Boot bekommen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie es hinkriegen,
so wie bei Rainbow Six, was ja am Anfang
auch nicht so wahnsinnig angesagt war.
Oder Battlefield 4,
oder was gab's da noch für Beispiele?
Das glaube ich nicht.
Genauso wie ich nicht glaube, dass Stadia noch die Kurve kriegt.
The real Aoki.
Twitch Prime.
Zwei Monate. Huge Prime Sub.
Ach, so geht das.
Ja, jetzt wo du weißt, wie's geht,
ist ja easy für die nächsten Monate.
Borderlands ist ein gutes Beispiel, wo die sich was abgucken könnten.
Lieber, wenn die Waffen ein bisschen
klassischer mit Kugeln und sowas,
das Kugelgefühl. Aber ich überhaupt nicht.
Und selbst Borderlands 3, finde ich,
hätte einiges gehabt,
was man auch verbessern könnte.
Dann will ich alles. Ich will Laser,
vor allem die Main Quest war nicht so gut.
Ich will Blaster, ich will Phaser,
all das, was man eben so aus solchen Settings kennt.
Das wäre für mich eigentlich das Hauptding.
Wenn die Beute so abgedreht wäre,
wie es in Borderlands 3 zum Beispiel ist,
wäre Anthem so viel besser.
Auf jeden Fall. Und...
Ich stimme dir da zu 100% zu.
Vor allen Dingen, die haben da nicht die gleiche Restriktion,
wie zum Beispiel Division 2 hat, weil das halt einfach in der Realität ist.
Da kannst du nicht mit Laser gewähren.
Noch so ein ekliges...
Ding.
Division.
Letztens, habt ihr das gesehen?
Letztens haben die die Division 2...
Was ist das?
Addon? Oder DLC?
Oder sowas.
Haben die ja letztens vorgestellt.
Und da haben sie ein paar Streamer bezahlt.
Unter anderem bei Dance Gaming,
war das zu sehen. Bei Seagull war das zu sehen.
Und...
Ihr hättet den Chat sehen müssen, Leute.
Wie die sich über das Game...
Wie der Chat über das Game hergezogen hat.
Und ich muss euch halt sagen,
der Twitch-Chat, der übertreibt gerne.
Aber in dem Fall hat der Twitch-Chat
einfach recht.
Außer mein Twitch-Chat.
Der hat natürlich immer recht, aber...
Naja, ne, auch nicht.
Der liegt öfters mal richtig.
Aber der Twitch-Chat hatte tatsächlich
komplett recht, was das angegangen ist.
Was die letzte Division 2 Erweiterung
anbelangt hat.
Es sah halt einfach ultra langweilig aus.
Hast du Bücherempfehlungen
im Bereich von
Non-Fiction-Bücher für ein technisches
Gebiet?
Boah.
Der ist aus dem Stehgreif nicht.
... von Borderlands, von Warframe,
von den ganzen anderen Spielen,
die es einfach besser machen.
Und coole Waffen, coole Loot.
Und auch die Fähigkeiten, finde ich.
Das war auch alles ziemlich lahm.
Was glaubst du denn,
was man machen könnte?
Das ist zu 0815 halt, das ganze.
Das ganze Game sah von Anfang an
einfach zu generic, zu zusammengeschustert aus.
Emoji, please.
Kommt alles noch.
Das Endgame zu retten,
auszubauen,
die langfristige Progression auch.
Ja, klar, irgendwie was
in die Richtung von einem Raid. Wär ganz cool.
Irgendwas, ich glaub, wie viel?
Vier Spiele sind glaub ich die Strongholds?
Ich glaube vier, ja.
Es gab auch nicht viele Strongholds.
Gibt's keine Raids oder kein ordentliches
Endgame-Content in Anthem?
Irgendwas mit coolen
Mechaniken, was wirklich
Teamplay
voraussetzt. Irgendwas,
wo du auch wirklich deine gute Gier
dann auch gebrauchen kannst.
Es gab ja auch wirklich sehr wenig.
Ja, Michael, dauert nicht mal lang.
Fünf Jahre oder so.
Ich mach das, ich kümmere mich um die Emotes.
Wird echt mal Zeit. Ich hab irgendwie noch 22
Emote-Slots oder so
noch übrig.
Auch sehr hilfreich wäre, wären vielleicht
ein bisschen mehr Events oder Ereignisse,
die ein bisschen mehr Zufallsfaktor
auch noch haben, also mehr Wiederspielwert.
Zum Beispiel Leute
rennen immer noch gern durch Nephalem-Portale
in Diablo 3 oder erst recht
in Path of Exile die Maps,
die halt immer komplett zufallsgeneriert sind.
Beste, beste Leute.
3D-Third-Person-Shooter, bisschen schwieriger
in einem isometrischen Raum.
Path of Exile, ich mein,
ich will nicht von der ganzen Free-to-Play-Geschichte
anfangen, ich find das trotzdem immer noch ein echt faires Modell,
aber Path of Exile macht das
Endgame-technisch extrem gut.
Der Übergang
von Story-Ende zu Endgame
hab ich selten so weich
und so
suchtfördernd
gesehen, wie sie das
in Path of Exile hingekriegt haben.
Das haben die wirklich gut gemacht.
Du hast einen Story-Charakter
und dein Charakter ist ganz okay.
Ich mein, du musst ja in der Story
nicht großartig was machen.
Und du kannst direkt mit dem Story-Charakter
nach ein paar sinnlosen Mini-Quests
kannst du direkt anfangen
mit Endgame-Content.
Und es gibt auch nicht wenig.
Erstmal minus 60 Resis.
Story ist Easy-Mode.
Ja, Story ist nicht
das kriegt man da ganz gut hin.
Du kannst dann immer noch
Game-Maps zu machen
und ein bisschen vor dich hin zu grinen.
Du hast wahrscheinlich auch schon ganz gut Währung,
kannst dir ein bisschen ordentliches Equipment kaufen.
Also der Übergang, das führt dich in Path of Exile
wirklich richtig gut da an die ganze Sache ran.
Aus Versatzstücken leichter zusammenbauen,
aber so diese
zufälligen Missionen.
Das Problem ist glaub ich bei Anthem eher auch,
es gab ja so diese Missionen, die man dann machen konnte,
die so ein bisschen immer so zufällig
zusammengestrungen wurden.
Es gab nicht genügend Versatzstücke,
war, find ich, mein Problem.
Es gab bei anderen Typen nicht genügend Umgebung,
nicht genügend Missionsziele,
nicht genügend Mechaniken.
Herz 93, naja Maps ist so
die Hauptmechanik.
Allerdings gibt es sehr viele Maps.
Es gibt den
Du musst halt
deinen ganzen Atlas ausbauen.
Dann gibt es noch ein paar Bosskämpfe,
was du quasi nach und nach freischalten musst.
Dann gibt es noch stärkere Varianten
von den Bosskämpfen.
Dann gibt es noch ein paar Tempel.
Dann gibt es noch ein App.
Es gibt relativ viele Sachen.
Es ist nicht nur Maps spammen
eins nach dem anderen.
Allerdings ist das eines der Sachen,
die man halt viel macht.
Maps spammen.
Aber es wird nicht
langweilig.
Das wichtigste, was man im
Path of Exile Endgame braucht,
ist allerdings ein ordentlicher Lootfilter.
Weil ansonsten explodiert das Gehirn.
Ohne ordentlichen Lootfilter.
Und was halt
richtig Spaß macht im Path of Exile ist,
dadurch, dass du halt 16
16 Schwierigkeitsstufen
von den ganzen Maps hast.
Ne, es ist nicht nur
Es ist nicht nur Maps laufen,
aber es ist relativ viel Maps laufen.
Dadurch, dass du halt die verschiedenen
Schwierigkeitsstufen mit den Maps hast.
Aber dadurch, dass du Maps machst,
unlockst du automatisch schon quasi
neue Progression.
Du musst erstmal die ganzen Watchstones
die du dann
kannst du dann im Atlas einsetzen
und dann verschiedene Upgrades damit auch noch
spendieren. Dann kannst du die Bossfights machen.
Den allerletzten Bossfights habe ich auch noch
nicht gemacht.
Diesen Awakener-Dings, Gedöns.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich spiele zwar viel Path of Exile,
aber ich bin Noob.
Also ich habe bei weitem auch keinen
wirklich da großen Plan
von.
Zumal ich auch ein absolutes Noob-Bild spiele.
Das heißt, ich kann mit
übelsten Crap-Gear
kann ich
T12, T13 Maps machen
ohne zu sterben.
Ich spiele halt
Summoner mit
Physical Damage
Skelette Summoner.
Das ist halt das größte
Noob-Bild, was du in diesem Spiel machen kannst.
Das ist für
den letzten Kack-Noob.
Du gehst hin, drückst einen Knopf
und wenn du Angst hast
zu sterben, drückst du deine
Skelette einfach nur in die Nähe
vom Gegner und bleibst off-screen während
deine Skelette alles killen. Du machst einfach nur
Armor an, buffst die noch.
Du kannst eigentlich
nichts falsch machen mit diesem Bild.
Ich habe zwei Sachen gespielt
dieses Season.
Ich habe angefangen mit diesem
Arc-Witch-Guide
Wir machen jetzt einfach ein bisschen Path of Exile.
Das, womit
glaube ich jeder angefangen hat
in diesem Game, habe ich mit diesem
Guide angefangen.
Damit hat jeder mal angefangen.
So, und da habe ich
die Story durchgespielt
und habe
ein bisschen Maps gemacht und hatte auch
Glück, dass mir
irgendwie gleich bei der
zweiten Map
die Level
Chest schlechthin getroppt ist.
Zweimal!
Zweimal Level Chest schlechthin
getroppt ist.
Hallo, warum zeigt das keine Sockel an?
Das Ding. Und da habe ich mir gedacht,
okay, wenn ich jetzt schon so eine gute Level Chest habe,
mache ich mir einfach noch einen Summoner
und habe
dann innerhalb von einem Tag oder so
meinen Summoner durch
Story durchgespielt und Endgame
gefarmt, quasi besser als
ich mit dem anderen Charakter
konnte, weil es halt so ein absolutes Noob-Bild
ist.
Das Ding spiele ich hier aktuell.
So.
Das ist der Bild, den ich aktuell spiele.
Das ist wirklich absoluter Noob-Bild.
Das kann
jeder spielen. Du brauchst nichts
an Gear im Endeffekt
zum Einstieg.
Du brauchst nichts an Gear
und du kannst alles
clearen.
Es ist eigentlich schon
zu OP, das Ding.
Wenn man sich anguckt, was er hier
Sample Gear vorschlägt,
das ist nichts.
Das kriegst du fast schon beim Leveln
zusammen, was der Typ hier hat.
Es ist wirklich easy.
Das einzige, was ich mir noch
gekauft habe, also das einzige,
was ich bisher getradet habe in der ganzen
League, also sprich würde ich
mehr traden, könnte ich auch einen deutlich besseren
Charakter schon haben, aber ich
verzichte erstmal drauf, weil ich
gucken will, was es alles an Game-Inhalten
gibt. Das einzige, was
ich mir getradet habe für den
Charakter ist ein
hier, ist
ein Level 20
Quality
20 Skill-Gam
dafür.
Für 20 Chaos-Orbs oder so.
Und was ich auch jedem empfehlen kann,
der Path of Exile Endgame macht,
ist
ist das Tool
beziehungsweise die neue Version,
das
trackt den Progress,
den man
an Ingame-Währungen
macht. Also sprich,
man startet das Tool,
meldet sich an,
und sagt welche
Stash-Tabs, beziehungsweise
welche, dort wo man seine Items
und Gegenstände aufbewahrt,
das Ding überwachen soll,
denn man hat oftmals
das Gefühl, wenn man quasi Endgame-Grinding
macht in Path of Exile, also nach dem Motto
es geht nicht vorwärts
irgendwie, ja, es wäre
man verliert quasi mehr
als man einsetzt, und wenn man
das Ding hier als Tracker anhat, sieht
man, dass man nach einem Tag
Maps-Grinden einfach mal
irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 1000, das ist übertrieben,
wobei, ja doch,
kommt doch hin, je nachdem
wie viel man grindet, keine Ahnung,
500 plus
Chaos-Orbs an Value gemacht hat,
einfach
durch permanentes Spielen.
Ohne den krassen
High-End-Content machen zu müssen,
einfach durch Spielen.
Und das ist halt
auch ein großer Motivator,
weil wir wissen ja, Stonks, wir mögen
alles grafen, was nach oben geht.
Und das ist wirklich sehr praktisch, das Tool.
Auch wenn es manchmal nicht ganz stimmt,
was es ausgibt.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Wulvi69, Twitch Prime,
Dankeschön.
Sub.
HiIQ Sub, Dankeschön.
Wulvi69
Doppelpack-Abo heute.
Dankeschön, ihr beiden.
So, gucken wir mal das Video weiter.
So, da
wirklich viel Abwechslung, also ich meine, das hat jetzt tatsächlich
die Nevalim-Portale, die haben auch nicht abwechslungsreich
Diablo 3 ist für mich komplett dead, ne?
Also Diablo 3
habe ich seit einem Jahr oder zwei Jahren
nicht mal angefasst.
Ich habe mal noch ein bisschen gespielt, wo die umgestellt haben
auf komplett self-found,
aber mittlerweile
Dopp.
Diablo 3 hat immerhin zum Beispiel sehr abwechslungsreiche
Umgebungen und Feindestypen, die du da
alle reinwerfen kannst. Anthem hat das ja gar nicht.
Ja, ich finde auch, die Abwechslung, also... Anthem ist ja auch ein Kack, ja.
Die Gegner waren
total austauschbar, alle.
Da war keine große Dynamik
Das ist auch was, was Path of Exile
finde ich ziemlich gut hinkriegt.
Wenige, also die meisten
Action-RPGs haben es
geschafft bei mir, dass mir
die paar Gegnertypen, die es gibt,
schon nach
keine Ahnung, nach zweimal
durchspielen so auf den Sack gehen,
dass man die Gegnertypen
gar nicht mehr sehen kann. In Path of Exile
gibt es erstens relativ
viele verschiedene Gegnertypen,
aber es ist auch endlich, ja, es ist
kein allzu Riesenpool.
Aber das Schöne an Path of Exile finde ich, ist, dass
die, dass der
die Geschwindigkeit vom Gameplay
so hoch
ist, dass
es eigentlich fast egal ist, was man
für Gegner weg
hackenslayt.
Man nimmt das kaum noch zur Kenntnis,
ob man da jetzt irgendwelche
Dämonen killt
oder irgendwelche Tiere
killt oder irgendwelche
Geister
wegbasht. Da ist eigentlich überhaupt
kein Unterschied. Einfach alles
wegstelzen und Loot
abgreifen.
Super agile Javelin, der
super coole Flugmanöver machen konnte,
aber es war egal, weil die Gegner haben sich eh nicht
bewegt. Im Prinzip, du bist ein bisschen gestraft
und hast geschossen und auf was du dann geschossen
hast, war dann egal. Und das Gleiche
ist auch die Umgebung. High Enter ist halt voll
verarscht.
Was die Overworld angeht
und that's it. Da war irgendwie
nicht ne Wüstenlandschaft, ne Eislandschaft,
die Klassiker halt. Ja, Eis,
Feuer, Wüste,
Regenwald. Allein,
wenn sie diese drei Biome schon
irgendwie in diese Welt integriert hätten, das wäre schon mal
ein großer Zugewinn gewesen, aber nein.
Ich mein, man sieht, dass technisch
das Spiel echt gut ist.
Guckt euch das mal an, das haben
keine Noobs gebastelt.
Das ist technisch schon
nicht schlecht. Das Problem ist halt, dass dem
Spiel komplett die Seele und
die Identität fehlt.
Irgendwie nicht ne Wüstenlandschaft, ne Eislandschaft,
die Klassiker halt. Ja, Eis,
Feuer,
Regenwald. Allein,
wenn sie diese drei Biome schon irgendwie
in diese Welt integriert hätten, das wäre schon mal
ein großer Zugewinn gewesen. Aber nein, es wird überall
nur grün. Ja, halten wir also
fest, wir würden uns erwarten bessere
und vielfältigere Loot, was Waffen und Fähigkeiten
angeht. Mehr Abwechslung
im Endgame. Abwechslung
ist glaub ich der Punkt, schlechthin
wo man sagen kann, Anthem braucht mehr
Abwechslung. Richtig. Mehr Tiefe und mehr Abwechslung.
Genau, also abwechslungsreichere Aktivitäten
im Endgame und auch eben abwechslungsreichere
abwechslungsreichere
Umwelt in Sachen Welt und
Gegner. Jetzt muss man aber finde ich schon sagen,
es gibt ein paar, also
zum Beispiel abwechslungsreichere
Loot ist jetzt, ich sag mal
leicht ist das falsche Wort, aber ist machbar.
Da brauchst du glaube ich auch gar nicht so
viel Personal dafür, um
ein paar coole Waffen zu coden,
ein paar Effekte dazu zu basteln.
Auch Gegnertypen würde ich sagen,
kannst du auch, sag ich mal, mit einer
du brauchst keine volle Entwicklermannschaft
überhaupt mehr, um neue Gegnertypen zu
basteln und du brauchst ja auch gar nicht
so unglaublich viele, wenn du ein paar hast,
die cool sind, die bisschen vielfältig sind, die du dann
so mix and matchen kannst in Zufallsevents.
Schwieriger sehe ich halt so die
ganze Sache mit Welt
und auch Aktivitäten, weil da
müsstest du ja wirklich viel
dazu basteln bei Anthem.
Vor allem du brauchst halt auch,
das ist halt auch eines der, nennen wir das mal
in Anführungsstrichen Probleme, wenn du so ein
Triple A
Production Value Monster
hast, ja, also sprich wo an jeder Ecke
halt was drinnen stecken,
was gemacht werden muss, du kannst nicht
einfach mal
irgendwie großartig Content mit ein paar Mann
einbauen, du musst
das Zeug muss ordentlich geschrieben sein, du brauchst
Synchronsprecher, du brauchst Leute, die das
animieren, du brauchst Zeug, das macht, also
das ist nicht mal einfach gemacht, wie
irgendwie in einem Ein-Mann-2D-Projekt,
so nach dem Motto, ah, ich hab jetzt eine neue Map
erstellt, ein bisschen Text und eine Quest ist fertig.
Da steckt halt schon ein bisschen
mehr dahinter. Und das jetzt mal so
quasi raus aus dem Ärmel
schütteln, eh nicht.
Und die Frage ist halt, wie viel die
auch noch bereit sind an
Geld da rein zu investieren
in ein Game, was halt so
abgekackt ist.
Und ich fand tatsächlich auch immer, das war für mich
eines der größten Probleme von Anthem, wie es
dieses Kernversprechen, die ganze
Story war ja auch darauf ausgelegt, eine
Welt, in der alles passieren kann,
die sich ständig ändert.
Und dann hast du eigentlich nach zwei Stunden auch
alles gesehen, auch jeden Missionstyp, jeden
Gegnertypen, da ist, da konnte überhaupt nicht
alles passieren.
Es gab doch vor einem Jahr oder
zwei Jahren war ein neues MMO
total gehypt,
wo die Entwickler
auch wieder behauptet haben, so nach dem
Motto, die komplette Welt lebt und
hier Events und nie werden Spielgebiete
obsolet und
Player-Driven Events und
alles mögliche, wo ich
damals schon gesagt habe, ja, ja, das
erzählen sie alle und am Ende ist es halt
ohne weiteres gar nicht
Nein, kein
BDO, kein Destiny, kein No Man's Sky,
irgendein MMO war
das, wo ich auch schon damals gesagt habe,
so ein Blödsinn, das erzählt hier alle,
kriegt es aber nicht hin, weil
da auch so handfeste Gameplay-Sachen
im Weg stehen.
Das, nee, nee, nee, Ples war das
nicht, Ples war dieser Asia Rock
irgendwie, nee, nee, nee, irgendwas
anderes, irgendwas anderes.
Ich weiß nicht, was das war.
Es ist ja
auch schwierig, Gebiete in einem
MMO zu bauen,
die quasi für alle Level
relevant sind.
Das ist nicht einfach, wie willst du das machen?
Es könnte Crowfall, es könnte
vielleicht Crowfall gewesen sein, ja.
Und viele MMOs haben es auch schon
probiert mit Welten, die quasi
sich permanent ändern.
Es gibt halt Sachen in MMOs, die
verweisen sich. Will ich eine Story
erzählen, ist eine
Welt, die sich auf
Spieleraktionen
ändert, also eine persistente Welt,
die für alle gleich ist, die sich auf Spieleraktionen
ändert, in Kombination mit
Story, geht halt
nicht. Wenn die Welt zu einem gewissen
Story-Zeitpunkt in einem gewissen Zustand
sein will, dann kann ich keine persistente
Welt für alle spielen. Das funktioniert
so nicht. Da muss ich
anfangen mit solchen Geschichten wie,
dass sich nur Spieler sehen können mit
gleichem Level oder beziehungsweise
zumindest mal gleicher Story-Progression.
Das ist halt nicht, was für mich
quasi irgendwie MMOs
richtig ausmachen.
Mir fehlen eh die großen
MMO-Releases.
So zur Zeit, wo vor WoW,
nach WoW, da kam ja quasi
jede Woche ein neues MMO raus und jedes
MMO war der WoW-Killer und jedes MMO
war besser und sonst was. Die meisten
waren halt Crap, aber waren auch ein paar ganz
gute dabei.
Es gibt keine guten MMO-Releases
mehr. Auf das Amazon-MMO bin
ich tatsächlich mal gespannt.
Dadurch, dass es eben ein bisschen weniger
Story-fokussiert und
Kampagnen-fokussiert sein wird, sondern mehr
Player,
mehr Sandbox und mehr
Player zentriert sein wird.
Ja,
selbst Elder Scrolls Online ist ja
weiß ich,
es hat sich wohl viel zum besseren
geändert, aber Elder Scrolls
Online ist ja wohl auch so ein
Hybrid aus, wir versuchen
ein bisschen die PvP-Leute
anzusprechen, aber das,
wobei ich weiß nicht, wie es aktuell ist, muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen. Das PvP-Gebiet
hat zumindest am Anfang ziemlich gefailt in
Elder Scrolls Online
und so wie ich das beobachtet habe,
ich habe ja schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr gespielt,
hat
sich Elder Scrolls Online mehr
zum Singleplayer
MMO geändert, als zu
einem eigentlichen
großer, großen
World
Group-Content-Spiel.
Aber da weiß ich nicht, wie das jetzt ist.
Ich habe lange nicht mehr gespielt.
Wie die von Anthem.
In Diablo 3 kann mehr
alles passieren als in Anthem
und das ist ein Iso-Rollenspiel.
Und was ich auch
schwierig finde, ist
eigentlich müsste BioWare auch
an der Story, finde ich, noch mal
einiges schrauben, weil
A haben sie da auch viel versprochen,
B ist das auch ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal
von ihnen. Das ist eigentlich ihre Stärke.
Das ist auch, was viele von ihren
klassischen Fans erwartet haben.
BioWare konnte
gute Storys früher.
Allein die ganzen Voice-Actor zu bezahlen,
die Animationen
für die Zwischensequenzen, das ist unglaublich
viel Geld, was das verschlingen würde.
Und am Ende ist glaube ich aber tatsächlich
Story der Punkt, der am wenigsten
Spieler zurückbringen würde.
Weil die müssen einmal
das Fundament, was sie geschaffen haben,
was glaube ich nicht besonders gut ist,
müssen sie aufbauen. Ich weiß nicht,
ob man da noch was Cooles draus machen kann.
Keine Ahnung. Ich glaube das Wichtigste ist wirklich
Gameplay. Gutes Gameplay schaffen.
Das scheint ja auch ein Fokus zu sein.
Story erwähnen sie ja nicht mal
in diesem Entwickler-Poster.
Ich bin immer noch überrascht,
dass das Game wirklich
so rein handwerklich, sieht das wirklich
gut gemacht aus.
Was am Anfang gut gewesen wäre drinnen, hätte halten können.
Weil du vielleicht sagst so, okay,
das Endgame ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so geil,
aber durch die Story finde ich diese Welt so cool,
dass ich da gerne drin bin.
Aber jetzt hast du wahrscheinlich recht, dass es...
Ich finde bei diesen Service-Games,
ich meine, man muss sich auch hier nur wieder
die Konkurrenz angucken, was bringt denn die Leute
immer wieder zurück zu einem Warframe?
Was bringt die Leute immer wieder zurück zu einem Diablo?
Was bringt die Leute zurück zu einem Destiny?
Die Story von Diablo 3 war auch gottenschlecht.
Das ist einfach nur, weil diese Spiele
eine sehr solide Gameplay Group haben.
Weil es Sachen zu ergrinden gibt.
Weil der Grind Spaß macht, würde ich sagen.
Also ich finde, Destiny,
der Grind macht Spaß. Bestimmt nicht jedem,
aber einen Großteil der Community.
Gut, das ist der Grund, warum Leute Destiny...
Ah, Moment, wir müssen...
Moment, wir müssen mal wieder
unsere wöchentliche Sache
Stadia Destiny Player
Count.
Oh!
Moment, von wann ist das?
Von wann ist das? Das ist viel zu hoch.
20. Dezember, das ist zu hoch.
Das ist mittlerweile viel weniger.
Das ist viel weniger.
Wie hieß dann, wie hieß dann dieser Bot nochmal?
Destiny Bot...
Irgendwas Charles oder so?
Ah ne, wie hieß dann dieser Bot?
Äh, Stats Website, wo man schön
gucken konnte, wer auf welcher...
Wer auf welcher Plattform spielt.
Wie hieß der irgendwie? Charles, Charles
noch was?
Ah hier, das da.
Äh, das da.
Destiny
Stats.
Besteuern?
War das...
Äh.
Ah, wo ging das nochmal?
Hier?
Hier.
Da, hier oben ist Stadia. Guckt mal, 0%.
Leute, ich zoome euch ran,
dass ihr es besser seht. Hier.
Also,
Stadia Spieler.
Äh, man erkennt, man erkennt das
gar nicht so wirklich.
Da reicht die Auflösung von diesem Graph
hier für dich.
Das ist insgesamt, also,
hm, ähm,
ich würde nicht sagen, dass der Stadia Player Count
irgendwie hochgeht, ja.
Also ich vermute mal,
dadurch, dass das 0% ist,
wird das abgerundet werden.
Also sprich, das ist
unter 0,5.
Wir gehen jetzt einfach mal davon aus, dass sie es ab 0,5
aufrunden würden.
Also sagen wir, es ist unter 0,5.
Ähm.
Leider gibt es hier, glaube ich, keine Zahlen
insgesamt an Spielern,
sondern nur die Verteilung.
Also falls jemand eine bessere Statistikseite
kennt, müsst ihr mir sagen.
Ich weiß, ich kenne nur die.
Ähm.
Wenn wir jetzt die insgesamte Player Count
wissen, also sprich, es ist irgendwas,
ich sag mal, um eine Million, ja,
ungefähr um eine Million.
Und das heißt so, keine Ahnung,
990.000
Spielen auf allen
anderen Plattformen und 10.000 auf Stadia
oder so. Das ist halt der Witz.
Obwohl Stadia eines der
Aushänge-Launch Titel, ähm,
Destiny eines der Aushänge-Launch Titel
war mit Stadia.
Voll verkackt.
Da gibt's coole
Sachen zu erfahren.
Was ich schon toll finde,
dass im Destiny Video so oft andere
Spiele gezeigt werden, weil Destiny, äh nicht Destiny,
äh, Anthem, im Anthem Video
oft andere spiele gezeigt werden was im prinzip ja gerade das heißt das entern bis zum zugucken
langsam ist hast du schon vom teaser für den battle royale mode in battle in modern warfare
mitgekommen ja habe ich aber ich habe nicht geguckt hat einer mal einen link dann gucken
wir uns dennoch an bist du froh dass du dein stadion gecancelt hast nee eigentlich nicht ich
würde es ich würde es gern mal ausprobieren und ich probiere es wahrscheinlich auch mal aus mit
mit dem chrome und was mich auch eher interessiert hat ist ob man nicht irgendwie custom firmware auf
das gerät auf diesen chromecast vielleicht draufklicken das für was anderes gutes verwenden
kann aber ich musste stadia cancel ich musste ich konnte das ich konnte es mir einfach nicht
geben dass bei einem produkt was man vorbestellen kann was ich von das edition nennt das ist drei
wochen nach release kommen sollte das habe ich nicht eingesehen dass ich musste das cancel ich
kenne ganz wenig wie sieht es eigentlich bei teso aus weil ich habe ewig kein teso gespielt
auch immer so die die atmosphäre der welt und sowas wichtig und persönlich lege ich
sehr viel auf die atmosphäre der welt und sowas wichtig und persönlich lege ich sehr viel auf
die atmosphäre der welt und sowas wichtig und persönlich lege ich sehr viel auf
die atmosphäre der welt und sowas wichtig und persönlich lege ich sehr viel auf story aber du hast objektiv
story aber du hast objektiv
story aber du hast objektiv recht dem meisten service game spieler sind
recht dem meisten service game spieler sind
recht dem meisten service game spieler sind nicht so wie ich oder zumindest bin ich
nicht so wie ich oder zumindest bin ich
nicht so wie ich oder zumindest bin ich meine ich spiele auch gerne so ich spiele
meine ich spiele auch gerne so ich spiele
meine ich spiele auch gerne so ich spiele jetzt spiele ich die abo 3 auch nicht mehr
jetzt spiele ich die abo 3 auch nicht mehr
jetzt spiele ich die abo 3 auch nicht mehr für die story sei mal ehrlich und ja gar
für die story sei mal ehrlich und ja gar
für die story sei mal ehrlich und ja gar nicht mehr hat doch immer nicht so der
Hammer, die Cutscenes waren geil.
Diablo 2 hatte eine gute Story.
Aber du hast da natürlich recht.
Naja, also komm,
die Story von Diablo 2 war jetzt auch
nicht der Wahnsinn.
Ich mein,
ich bin alt genug, ich bin wahrscheinlich ungefähr
in seinem Alter, vermute ich mal, mit
35.
Diablo 2 hatte für die
damalige Zeit halt eine coole,
düstere Story mit
für die damalige Zeit halt coolen
Zwischensequenzen. Also im Prinzip
ein bisschen das, was Diablo 3
in der heutigen Zeit hat.
Jetzt wirklich
herausragend war die Diablo
2-Story nicht.
Finalenpunkt vielleicht,
wie schätzt du denn die Chancen ein, dass
Anthem 2.0
nochmal eine Hochzeit für das Spiel
einläuten kann?
Ja, also jetzt muss einfach
BioWare abliefern. Für mich
sind das bisher einfach nur,
für mich ist das einfach nur ein bisschen PR-Blabla.
Hatten wir in der Vergangenheit schon genug davon.
Und wie du gesagt hast vorhin, es müssen jetzt
Taten folgen. Ich würd's mir
wünschen, weil ich hätte wirklich
Lust, nochmal ein gutes
Anthem zu spielen, ein motivierendes Anthem
zu spielen. Ich will Anthem gar nicht spielen.
Ich würde mir die Frage stellen, wieso hat sich jetzt
EA entschlossen,
nochmal, nicht einfach Anthem
fallen zu lassen und zu sagen, okay,
das war's. Wir machen jetzt
irgendwie
Weil sie hoffen,
ein bisschen wie bei Fallout 76,
aus den verbliebenen
Leuten, noch ein bisschen Kohle rauszukriegen.
Die wollen
irgendwie gucken,
dass das nicht komplettes
Desaster ist.
Ich glaub, da muss man zu
Origin Access gucken. Ich glaube,
EA will jetzt damit nochmal
vielleicht ein bisschen Wert schaffen für
Alter, was ist mit dem Sammlauge los?
Also, wenn das mein Auge, wartet mal,
wenn das mein Auge machen würde beim Spielen,
dann hätt ich echt ein Problem.
Und ich glaub, da muss man
zu Origin Access gucken.
Ich glaube, EA will jetzt damit
nochmal
Alter, was wird da mit seinem Auge los?
Vielleicht ein bisschen Wert schaffen für
für Origin Access.
Okay, wenn der Monitor explodiert, ist das auch sehr ungesund.
Den Dienst damit nochmal zu pushen.
Den Pass quasi, weil es
viele Publisher pushen ja in Richtung
ihrer Pässe gerade. Er hat gesumt, genau.
Enhance hat er gemacht, Enhance.
Ubisoft hat ja zum Beispiel ein
starkes Loot-Shooter-Service-Game in Form
von The Division. Genau.
Division ist auch so ein Game.
Leute, ehrlich, ich meine,
ich will's nicht trashen oder flamen zu sehr.
Spielt jemand von euch Division 2?
Und wie ist das?
Weil für mich, ich hab ja den ersten Teil
ein bisschen mit dem Fabian gespielt,
für mich ist das auch so ein typisches
Ubisoft-Game, so nach diesem 0815,
mittlerweile muss man das ja sagen,
nach diesem 0815 Ubisoft-Gebiet erobern,
Punkte einnehmen und auch irgendwie
ein Stück weit, ich weiß nicht,
ein Spiel, was sich sehr seelenlos anfühlt.
Neues da machen, versuchen wir nochmal mit Anthem.
Das ist, glaube ich, ein guter Punkt,
weil, wenn es funktioniert,
so eine Art von Service-Game ist ja genau
das, was Leute in so einem Pass auch hält.
Und es ist dann auch noch so,
dass Leute auch nicht unbedingt
sich jetzt Anthem neu kaufen müssen,
wenn das jetzt nochmal gefixt wird.
Weil das, weiß ich nicht, ob viele Leute
das noch machen würden, aber wenn du es eh schon
in deinem Pass drin hast, guckst du vielleicht
nochmal rein. Ja, und vielleicht lässt du den Pass
weiterlaufen.
Das ist standardmäßig.
Das ist standardmäßig vorhanden.
Richtig, richtig. Und ich glaube, dass
ein weiterer Punkt dabei, vielleicht bin ich da auch
zu idealistisch, vielleicht überschätze ich den,
aber ich glaube, wenn ein Studio, wenn ein Publisher
wie EA, und das ist jetzt schon eine Weile her,
aber ein Studio wie BioWare kauft,
dann kaufen sie ja nicht nur
talentierte Entwickler, sie kaufen einen
prestigeträchtigen Namen, wo sie auch dann
sagen können, guckt mal, das nächste
BioWare-Spiel, damit wirkt man dann.
Und ich glaube, wenn du jetzt gesagt hättest,
also der Name ist eh schon beschädigt durch
Mass Effect Andromeda davor, wenn du jetzt
gesagt hättest, okay,
Anthem hat sich, war kein großer Erfolg,
wir stampfen es einfach ein,
dann wäre dieser Name BioWare so
hart beschädigt gewesen, dass
für EA da auch ein Teil ihrer
damaligen Kerninvestition,
dieses Studio zu kaufen,
also sehr den Bach runtergegangen wäre, weil
du hättest nicht mehr das Prestige
Studio BioWare in deinem EA-Katalog,
du hättest das Studio BioWare, das
dieses scheiß Service-Game gemacht hat, auf das niemand
Bock hatte und das wir dann eingestampft haben, als es
nicht genug Geld verdient hat.
Frag mich, ist es eh nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis
BioWare nicht gemacht wird?
Aber den Namen behalten sie bei.
Und so weiter und so fort.
Du wärst da richtig schlecht dagestanden.
Und ich glaube,
manchmal überschätze ich so diese
Ruf- und Prestige-Wirkung, aber ich glaube,
gerade EA ist auch nach der Battlefront-Geschichte
vielleicht ein bisschen sensibilisiert.
Unternimmt ja auch ein paar Schritte
in letzter Zeit, also hat wieder ein Singleplayer-Spiel
gemacht. Angeblich ist sogar Battlefront 2
mittlerweile ganz gut spielbar.
...in order.
Und hat Battlefront
ja sogar gespielt.
...gerettet.
Was finde ich auch nochmal ein schöner Beweis ist, dass es
eigentlich immer geht.
Also bei allem Pessimismus über Anthem, du kannst fast
immer, wenn du nur genug reinsteckst, alles noch retten.
No Man's Sky, Battlefront 2, alles.
Da muss ich dir vollkommen recht geben.
Also ich hoffe auch, dass EA wirklich jetzt nicht sich
auch wirklich sagt, okay, der BioWare-Name muss wieder
zu seinem einstigen Ruhm, sag ich mal, verholfen werden.
Spackhack oder Hack.
Fünf Monate, dankeschön.
Big Prime Sub.
...wir wirklich den Leuten zeigen, hey, wir wollen, dass Anthem doch noch ein gutes Spiel wird.
Und ich hoffe, dass EA auch da den, wie bei Battlefront 2, das Ruhre rumreißen kann.
Ich würde es mir wünschen.
Ja, ich persönlich auch, weil ich immer noch das...
Wisst ihr, was mir nicht gefällt?
Ein Trend, der mir überhaupt nicht gefällt.
Auf der einen Seite finde ich das gut, dass so Sachen wie Rainbow Six gut laufen,
dass For Honor, also sprich, oder auch Battlefield 4 und sowas,
dass die Sachen, wenn sie in einem scheiß Zustand rauskommen,
nicht komplett eingestampft werden.
Das finde ich ja prinzipiell ganz gut.
Dankeschön, Heinrich.
Fünf Monate, Twitch Prime.
Huge Prime Sub.
Das finde ich ja eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich finde bloß den Trend nicht gut,
Spiele rauszukotzen heutzutage,
vollkommen egal, in welchem Zustand sie sind,
und sich darauf zu verlassen,
ah ja gut, wir können das ja danach noch irgendwie,
gerade biegen.
Wo sind wir hingekommen, dass heute quasi Early Access Triple-A-Spiele,
also von der Qualität her und vom Fertigungsstand teilweise,
Early Access als veröffentlicht wird?
Ja, also, ne.
Das finde ich keine gute Entwicklung.
Ich mag immer noch das Versprechen von Anthem.
Ja.
Und ich hatte durchaus Spaß in dem Spiel.
So ist es ja nicht.
Also, ich fand es einfach so, mal ein, zwei Kämpfe zu machen,
so als cooler Mech da rumzischen,
bisschen ballern und so, das hat Spaß gemacht.
Also, ich mochte so das Grundkonzept so,
dass du ein Mech mit Zauberkräften bist, der fliegen kann.
Hast du das GameStar-Video zu Wolzen Wolzen,
wie auch immer man das ausspricht, gelesen, gesehen?
Ne, hab ich nicht.
Ähm, und...
Ich hab's aber mitgekriegt, das ist die, wo sie gesagt haben,
sie haben ihnen angeblich die falsche Testversion geschickt,
und im Nachhinein muss man ja sagen,
das Spiel ist trotzdem noch sehr verbuggt.
Ich hab Dance Gaming geguckt auf Twitch,
und bei ihm ist das Game,
vom Wechsel auf Akt 2 zu Akt 3,
hat seine Story-Progression zurückgesetzt auf Anfang Akt 2,
anstatt auf Anfang Akt 3.
Von daher drück ich da auch wirklich die Daumen,
und ich mag ja auch, ich will ja auch, dass BioWare wieder BioWare wird.
Also, ich will ja wieder, das ist überhaupt,
Anthem ist eigentlich nicht die Art von Spiel, die ich von denen mag,
aber ich will, dass BioWare wieder der Name wird, der es mal war.
Wobei ich finde, Anthem war schon immer ein schlechter Fit für BioWare.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, da gäbe ich ihm recht.
Generell verbinde ich BioWare auch jetzt nicht mit rumfliegenden Mac-Shooter-Dingern.
Können ja auch gute Spiele so entstehen,
nicht das, was ich direkt von BioWare will, aber kann ja funktionieren.
Jetzt haben wir viel über Anthem geredet.
Wir drücken ihm die Daumen.
Jetzt interessiert uns natürlich noch, was ihr davon haltet.
Kann euch Anthem 2.0 zurückbringen?
Irgendjemand im Chat hat gesagt,
Irgendjemand im Chat hat gerade geschrieben,
das Game hat so viel Seele wie das letzte COD oder Overwatch.
Beim COD gebe ich dir recht,
aber eins kann man Overwatch wirklich nicht vorwerfen,
dass es nicht irgendwie herausstechen würde,
dass es keine Seele hat,
beziehungsweise irgendwie nicht seinen eigenen Flair hätte.
Das hat Overwatch definitiv.
Overwatch hat aber andere Probleme.
Das kann man Overwatch wirklich nicht vorwerfen.
So, und was wollten wir jetzt noch gucken?
Warfare Battle Royale.
Oh Gott, das war ja...
Oh, das hat echt noch gefehlt jetzt.
Nach was muss ich denn da gucken?
Teaser?
Oder nach was muss ich da suchen?
Stream kaputt?
Nee, ich sag bloß nichts.
Oh!
Oh, MonkaS.
MonkaGiga.
Unity Media wieder.
Oh Gott, Unity Media.
Oder Twitch, eins von beiden.
MonkaS.
Was ist da los?
Unity Media, please.
Ich blende das jetzt so lange ein,
bei Unity Media, bis es funktioniert.
Das backt immer noch rum.
Ich sehe es genau.
Hi Max, sorry, hab mal eine Netzwerkfrage
und bin Noob auf dem Gebiet.
Was für Nachteile hätte ich,
wenn ich meine Fritzbox IPv6 umstelle?
Laut meinem Provider habe ich Dual-Stack-Betrieb mit NAT.
Das ist DSLine, ja genau.
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, heißt das,
ich habe eine öffentliche IPv6 und eine private IPv4.
Also...
Moment.
Hoffen wir mal, dass das Ganze wieder funktioniert.
Ähm...
Als Hintergrund, warum ich das machen will,
ist, dass ich mein NAS und Raspberry extern erreichen will.
Kannst du nicht machen. Geht nicht.
Du hast keine Chance.
Zumindest über IPv4,
deine... ähm...
dein NAS von außen erreichbar zu machen.
Was du machen kannst, ist,
das Ganze über IPv6 machen.
Weil der Unterschied von Dual-Stack zu Dual-Stack Lite ist,
äh... Schwachsinn.
Ja doch.
Der Unterschied von Dual-Stack zu Dual-Stack Lite ist,
dass du bei Dual-Stack eine externe oder eine public IPv4 hast
und eine echte IPv6-Adresse.
Zwei ganz normale externe IPs.
Bei Dual-Stack Lite ist es so,
du hast nur eine IPv6-Adresse
und dein IPv4-Traffic wird getunnelt über IPv6.
So.
Wenn du jetzt umstellst komplett auf IPv6,
kannst du...
äh...
Wenn dein Endgerät,
von dem du auf dein NAS zugreifen willst von extern,
auch IPv6 kann,
kannst du direkt zugreifen.
Funktioniert.
Mit IPv4 hast du überhaupt keine Chance.
Das Problem ist,
wenn du auf IPv6 umsteigst komplett
und manche Seiten nicht IPv6 können,
dann...
gehen die Seiten nicht.
Aber zum größten Teil,
die...
die meisten...
größeren Seiten...
und die meisten Seiten
sollten eigentlich mittlerweile mit IPv6 gehen.
Aber es gibt bestimmt genug Sachen,
die einfach nicht funktionieren werden.
Also du hast die Auswahl zwischen Pest und Cholera.
Du hast die Auswahl zwischen...
Du stellst auf IPv6 um.
Du kannst super von extern auf dein NAS zugreifen.
Funktioniert.
Firewall-Freischaltung machen gut ist.
Ähm...
Dafür hast du das Problem mit Seiten,
die du benutzen willst,
die kein IPv6 können.
Bei wie vielen Seiten ist das?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe es noch nie ausprobiert.
Ähm...
Wahrscheinlich ist es sogar mittlerweile besser,
als ich mir das vorstelle.
Oder das andere,
du hast keine Chance zuzugreifen von außen auf dein NAS.
Was du machen kannst ist,
du kannst,
wenn du irgendwo die Möglichkeit hast,
einen externen Server zu betreiben,
kannst du dich tunneln.
Du kannst dich tunneln,
quasi über IPv4,
über den DSLite-Tunnel,
auf deinen externen Server
und von dort dann wiederum zurück auf dein NAS zugreifen.
Funktioniert.
DynDNS geht doch.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das Problem ist keine DNS-Auflösung.
Das Problem ist,
dass du mit IPv4,
dass dein IPv4 terminiert auf einem NAT-Router deines Providers.
Und auf dem Router,
beziehungsweise auf dem NAT-Endpunkt deines Providers,
kannst du halt keine Port-Weiterleitung einstellen.
Weil du gar keinen Zugriff drauf hast.
Manche DynDNS tunneln doch von V4 zu V6.
Das hat nichts mit DynDNS zu tun.
Okay, Leute.
Unity Media spackt wieder rum.
Geht's wieder?
Also, Leute,
ich lasse das jetzt so lange hier eingeblendet
mit Unity Media Shit.
Guck mal,
was die für schlechte Auflösung haben.
Ich lasse das jetzt so lange eingeblendet,
bis der Stream wieder funktioniert.
Genau.
Also,
um es nochmal zu sagen,
wahrscheinlich habt ihr das da gar nicht,
ähm,
gar nicht mitgekriegt,
weil das Riemen rumgespackt ist.
Also,
Easykiller hat gesagt,
manche DynDNS tunneln doch von V4 zu V6.
Das hat mit DynDNS nichts zu tun.
Also,
Leute,
ich lasse das jetzt so lange hier eingeblendet
mit Unity Media Shit.
Also,
mein Provider hat das Angebot für 2 Euro im Monat
mehr eine öffentliche IPv4 zu geben.
Ich schätze,
das ist einfacher als die Möglichkeit,
die du gebt hast.
Ja,
würde ich machen.
Habe ich bei Unity Media auch.
Unity Media hat mich ein bisschen scamast.
Ich bezahle glaube ich 4,
ne,
2,99 Euro bezahle ich im Monat glaube ich
noch doppelt jetzt mal.
Also,
2 mal 2,99 Euro,
also,
ich bezahle im Endeffekt
auch nochmal 2,99 Euro für eine externe IP v4 Adresse
bei Unity Media,
daß ich jetzt richtig echten
Dual Stack habe.
Weil Dual Stack Lite ist eine
komplette Zumutung.
Guten Morgen.
Im Rahmen meines Physik Studiumns
haben
wir gerade
Pageldstangen ein kleines bisschen gelernt
und ich habe,
sagt mir bescheid,
wenn der Stream
wieder ordentlich funktioniert,
dann kann wir weitermachen,
ne?
그리고
Und ich habe
gerade
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass viele richtige Informatiker Python eher belächeln. Woran liegt das genau?
Weil es überhebliche Deppen sind.
Ich kann es einfach. Da gibt es nichts zu belächeln.
Python hat seine Stärken und Schwächen wie jede andere Programmiersprache auch.
Stream läuft wieder? Okay.
Wublan. Das klingt wie ein Emote von mir.
Wublan.
Das schreibt bei uns, es ist umgedreht.
Die Telekom kackt die ganze Zeit, weil Unity Media läuft.
Es kommt auf die Region an.
RJ45-Keks, genau.
Herz39 sagt, hier wird das Ganze doch erklärt.
Okay, was wird denn hier erklärt?
Um was geht es überhaupt? Was wird erklärt?
Das ist ein Piehole-Video.
Hä? Was genau?
Wow. Ah, es ist ein Semper-Video. Das hört man schon sofort am Intro.
Was genau hat das jetzt mit dem Thema zu tun, was wir eben besprochen haben?
Okay, hören wir mal rein.
Hören wir mal rein, was der Meister der Betonung von sich gibt hierzu.
Der spricht die Sachen immer so super korrekt aus.
Ich kann das schlecht nachmachen.
Der spricht dann irgendwie so...
Der sagt das irgendwie immer so komisch, so nach dem Motto...
Und bei Unity Media müsst ihr dann euch auch auf euren Router connecten.
Okay.
Er spricht das alles immer so super korrekt aus.
Hallo, in diesem Video nur ganz kurz gezeigt, wie Sie das Piehole eventuell doch im eigenen Netzwerk nutzen können.
Piehole hört sich halt irgendwie schon ein bisschen unanständig an vom Namen her.
Obwohl Ihr Router ist eigentlich...
Router, Router, nicht Router.
...nicht zulässt, dass Sie das Piehole im eigenen LAN als DNS-Server bekannt machen.
Okay, also wer auch immer das Video gerade gepostet hat, Herz93,
das hat mit dem Thema, was wir gerade diskutiert haben, nicht zu tun.
Das hat mit dem Thema, was wir gerade diskutiert haben, nicht zu tun.
Okay, wollen wir das trotzdem gucken?
Es geht nur sechs Minuten.
Da kann ich meinen Senf dazu geben.
Falsches Video, glaube ich.
Ja, sieht so aus.
Sieht so aus.
Komm, sechs Minuten können wir trotzdem gucken.
Ich finde, das ist ein ganz guter Channel.
Kann man mal zeigen.
Das Video geht zurück auf viele Nutzer, die uns geschrieben haben,
dass sie das Piehole nicht nutzen können,
weil zum Beispiel die Unity Media Connect Box genau das eben nicht zulässt.
Ich zeige jetzt...
Ich zeige jetzt hier natürlich die grundlegende Vorgehensweise,
damit ihr eigentliche Hardware nicht zur Verfügung steht,
aber das Prinzip...
Hä? Warum haben die Leute das Problem,
dass sie ihre DNS-Gedöns nicht...
Nur, dass ich das jetzt verstehe,
weil es manche Router gibt,
vor allem die Dinger, die du vom Provider kriegst,
wo man keinen Custom-DNS-Server eintragen kann,
oder was ist das Problem?
Vermute ich mal.
Dr. Evil Cookie sage ich auch gleich was zu.
Und kann man diesem Unity Media Router nicht wenigstens beibringen,
welchen Upstream-DNS er verwenden soll?
Alternativ kann man einfach auf seinen Clients selbst einstellen,
welchen DNS-Server sie nehmen sollen.
Oder man verteilt das über DHC...
Mal gucken, was er vorschlägt.
Es gibt verschiedene Varianten, was man machen kann.
Die Frage lautet, wer sorgt für Ordnung im LAN?
Ordnung im LAN.
Das ist immer der sogenannte DHCP-Server.
Der spricht die Sachen so geil aus.
Der DHCP-Server.
Wenn Sie mit Ihrem Computer oder Handy sich im LAN oder WLAN anmelden,
dann brauchen Sie bestimmte Informationen vom Netzwerk oder vom Router.
Zum Beispiel, gib mir eine freie IP.
Wie lautet die Gateway-IP, damit ich ins Internet kann?
Und eben, wie lauten die DNS-Server?
Jeder Router, auch Vorkriegsmodelle, haben einen eigenen DHCP-Server an Bord.
Glücklicherweise hat auch unser Pi-Hole einen DHCP-Server.
Der Pi-Hole ist ein großer DHCP...
Ach, sorry.
DHCP, nicht DNS.
Aber hat's auch.
Wie ich eben schon sagte, erklärt der DHCP-Server allen Geräten unter anderem den DNS-Server.
Wenn wir nun den DHCP-Server im Router, also in der Connect-Box, abschalten können,
dann schalten wir einfach den DHCP-Server im Pi-Hole ein und wir sind wieder im Rennen.
Für die Unity-Media-Connect-Box haben wir jetzt einfach mal die Anleitung...
Okay, das müssen wir uns nicht angucken.
Das ist relativ naheliegend.
Das können wir uns sparen.
Also, da ist jetzt nichts großartig Neues für uns bei.
Geht der Stream noch?
Ja, gut, sehr schön.
Also, wir wollten uns den Modern Warfare Battle Royale-Teaser angucken.
Wo, wo, welcher?
Was ist der richtige, Leute?
Das da?
Ist das Terminal?
Ja, sieht ein bisschen aus wie Terminal.
Wird jetzt wiederbelebt.
Erstmal gerätzt.
Price.
Something's wrong in Vodansk.
They're targeting their own...
We need to find out why.
Send fighters I can trust.
Ghost out.
Ghost ist tot?
Warum ist Ghost wieder da?
Weil sie alles ausschlachten müssen, was irgendwie da ist.
Hä?
Oh Gott, es ist Battle Royale-Modus.
Oh, fuck, ey.
Das haben wir jetzt echt noch gebraucht.
Muss das sein?
Hat das die Welt gebraucht?
Hat da die Welt drauf gewartet?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Ja gut, wem's gefällt, warum nicht?
Warum nicht?
Dann bin ich denn schon on.
Drei Stunden schon.
Bin ja ganz schön lang heute.
Gab's nicht schon Battle Royale in Black Ops?
Doch, doch, klar.
Witcher 3 modded on Switch.
Leute, wollen wir uns noch eine Runde Battlefield 3 Top Plays angucken?
Gut.
So eine Runde Battlefield 3.
Ich find das immer sehr entspannend.
Und wir wissen ja schon, im Prinzip, im Prinzip könnten wir das Ganze ohne seinen Commentary gucken, weil er eh immer das Gleiche sagt.
Und wieder dieselben Kommentare, na klar.
Oh, das war ein, ein nicer Snipe.
Hello and welcome to the Battle Royale.
Oh, ein huge, huge, äh, Berg im Hintergrund.
Wahnsinns, Wahnsinn.
Battlefield 3 Top Plays.
In today's episode we're gonna be taking a look at some of the longest range sniping clips that I've had sent in.
Oh, auch noch in doppelten, hier.
Auch noch hier einmal Collateral über die halbe Map.
Ne, über die ganze Map.
Aber er hätte, er hätte schon mal 360 machen können davor.
Also, das kann ja jeder sonst.
Das ist das richtige Video.
Okay, also, zeig mal her.
Man erreichen trotz DS Lite.
Okay, Leute, das gucken wir uns mal vorher an.
Da kann ich nämlich meinen Senf dazu geben.
Das müssen wir uns trotzdem mal vorher angucken.
Hallo, in diesem Video nur ganz kurz gezeigt,
eine einfache Möglichkeit für IPv6-Dual-Stack-Lite-Kunden,
ihr Heimnetzwerk zu erreichen.
Und für alle, die jetzt noch nicht wissen,
was denn das Problem mit Dual-Stack-Lite ist...
Das ist so geil, wie er die Pause immer macht.
Für alle Kunden, die mit Dual-Stack-Lite-Probleme...
So geil.
...ganz kurz grafisch dargestellt.
Das ist das normale LAN, also ihre Geräte und ihr Router.
Und ihre Daten gehen halt rein und raus.
Die Aussprache, das ist so geil.
Inhaltlich sind die Videos meistens gut,
aber ich finde die Aussprache einfach immer so geil.
Ihr Router.
...mit dem Handy mal draußen sind
und wollen zum Beispiel auf die Nextcloud
in ihrem eigenen LAN zugreifen,
dann geben sie im Grunde über die App zum Beispiel
die IP ihres Heimrouters an
und schon sind sie im eigenen Netz.
Haben wir schon hundertmal in anderen Videos gezeigt.
Wenn du Portweiter-Reitung hast, schon.
Natürlich, es gibt das Problem der sogenannten dynamischen IP,
in der sie von ihrem Provider regelmäßig eine neue IP...
Das ist eine andere Aussprache vom R.
Also der sagt dem Motto Router.
Rammstein würde eher sagen Router.
Die rollen das eher.
Der rollt das nicht.
Der ehrt das irgendwie so.
Also die Nummer, die jetzt hier beispielhaft gezeigt wird
mit am Ende 7.139,
die ändert sich eventuell alle 24 Stunden.
Dafür gibt es aber entsprechende Dynamic-DNS-Dienste,
haben wir auch alle schon gezeigt.
Insoweit, ja, man kommt relativ einfach ins eigene Netzwerk.
So, jetzt kommen die Kunden,
die eigentlich vom Provider eine IPv6 bekommen.
Das ist quasi die IP der Zukunft.
Aber die Provider haben nicht ganz alle Hausaufgaben gemacht.
Deswegen müssen wir die Grafik jetzt hier ein bisschen abändern.
Denn streng genommen sitzen wir gar nicht mit unserem Router direkt im Internet.
Das stimmt.
Es ist eher so, dass wir im Laden des Providers sitzen.
Das Ganze würde also eher so aussehen.
Das heißt, ich habe hier meine Internet-IP,
am Ende immer noch die 7.139
und hier sind die anderen Kunden des gleichen Providers
eben mit mir in der Internet-IP.
Das heißt, ich habe hier meine Internet-IP, am Ende immer noch die 7.139,
und hier sind die anderen Kunden des gleichen Providers eben mit mir in der Internet-IP.
Das heißt, ich habe hier meine Internet-IP,
und hier sind die anderen Kunden des gleichen Providers,
in diesem Provider-Laden.
Und alle Geräte gehen dann am Ende an diesen Router,
der quasi beim Provider steht.
Und dann geht es erst ins Internet.
Da das Netzwerk aber ein vollständiges IPv4-Netzwerk ist,
würde entsprechender Traffic, den ich eben jetzt hier an...
Äh...
Ist das so?
Reden wir jetzt von IPv6 oder 4?
Ja.
Weil mit Duels der Kleid,
ist das meines Erachtens
nach nicht
so. Warte mal kurz, Leute.
So, ich bin wieder am Start.
Also
aber auch bei
IPv4
ist das, ja doch, doch, bei IPv4
ist das so. Genau, wenn man jetzt nicht
von DS Lite ausgeht, sondern wenn man
rein mal von IPv4 ausgeht, dann ist das
so. Allerdings wird hier nichts
genuttet an der Stelle, sondern
man hat wirklich eine richtig echte
gültige IPv4
Adresse, nur dass halt der Next Hop
ein Provider-Router ist.
Das ist doch vollkommen normal.
Immer so. Irgendwo muss man ja
Ist das nicht
Carrier Create NAT? Ne, das hier noch nicht.
Das hier sieht nicht
Carrier Create NAT aus.
Mal gucken.
Das ist doch vollkommen normal.
Wenn ich den da oben erreichen wollen würde,
mit einem Ping zum Beispiel, ja, das würde hier
einfach nur durchgeleitet werden, weil das
eben alles quasi IPv4
ist. Das Problem ist jetzt
IPv4, es gibt nicht genug Zahlen,
weswegen einige Provider eben
um den Mangel
auszugleichen, IPv6
Adressen verteilen.
Und wenn alles IPv6 wäre,
dann wäre das auch kein großes Problem.
Das heißt,
mein Router, der
bekommt also jetzt eine IPv6.
Übrigens, mir ist aufgefallen, das Ganze funktioniert doch so nicht.
Also je nachdem.
Wenn die Dinger wirklich
im gleichen Netz wären,
dann
müssten alle an dem gleichen Router hängen,
weil du kannst, also was du bei einem Router
nicht machen kannst, ist, du kannst nicht das gleiche Netz
an zwei Interfaces haben.
Zumindest nicht so
ohne weiteres, weil ein Router ist dafür da,
von einem Netz ins andere zu routen.
Und äh, wenn du das gleiche Netz an beiden Interfaces hast,
dann weiß der Router nicht, was er machen soll.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Das geht dann immer nur aus einem. Also,
dafür ist es im Router nicht, aber im Großen und Ganzen,
je nachdem, wie ich es gewählt habe, ist es richtig.
IPv6-Adresse, das bedeutet...
Ich habe übrigens übelst Hunger.
...und dafür bekomme ich die, und
im kompletten
Provider-LAN, ebenfalls
alles IPv6-Adressen.
Jetzt wird es natürlich den einen oder anderen geben,
der schon in die Kommentare geschrieben hat,
wo soll hier das Problem sein?
Dann wird einfach eben die IPv6-Adresse
in der App angesprochen
und schon leitet der Router hier alles durch.
Ja, das würde so sein,
wenn der Provider IPv6
Dual-Stack ohne das
Light gewählt hat, denn
sein Provider IPv6-LAN
hier, ist
nur über IPv4
an andere Netzwerke angeschlossen.
Ja, das ist natürlich dann falsch. Ja, das ist natürlich dann falsch. Ja, das ist natürlich dann falsch. Ja, das ist natürlich dann falsch.
Ja, das ist natürlich dann falsch. Ja, das ist natürlich dann falsch.
Aber ist es nicht so, dass du bei Unity Media
eine wirklich richtig
von außen erreichbare IPv6-Adresse
hast? Ich bilde
mir einen schon. Das Problem ist
nur, wenn dein
Endgerät kein IPv6 kann,
dann musst du über IPv4 gehen
und dann hast du das Problem.
... und der Router
hier ist mehr oder weniger
genauso konfiguriert wie ihr Heimrouter.
Wenn jemand von hier aus auf ihr Handy
zugreifen wollen würde, dann wird
ihr Router in der Standardeinstellung natürlich
sagen, nein, hier kommt keiner
rein. Ich bin ja so eine Art Firewall.
Schutz der eigenen
Geräte. Und genau das gleiche
ist auch hier. Wenn Sie jetzt eben
dieses Gerät hier ansprechen wollen würden,
dann wird der Router hier sagen, ich lasse
hier keinen rein. Ja, genau wie
an Ihrem Router. Wenn Sie hier rein wollen, von
zu Hause aus, dann müssen Sie in Ihrem
Router eine ganz spezielle Ausnahme
konfigurieren, dass eben
die Daten reingelassen werden.
Das Problem ist, es ist
so groß und das stimmt schon.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du es auch nicht tiefgreifend erklären.
Das Problem ist gar nicht so sehr,
wenn du eine NAT hast,
gar nicht so sehr, dass
der Router
das irgendwie aktiv blocken würde oder so.
Der Router hat schlicht
und ergreifend keine Ahnung,
wo du hin willst.
Also stellt euch mal vor,
lassen wir mal das ganze IPv6
Gedöns weg. Angenommen,
du willst von deinem
Endgerät hier drauf, auf
deinem Notebook.
Und du sprichst von deinem Endgerät,
wir gehen jetzt mal davon aus, das hier wäre eine öffentliche IP.
Du würdest diese IP ansprechen,
dann hat der Router keine Ahnung,
dass du eigentlich zu dem willst.
Woher soll der Router das wissen?
Deswegen brauchst du ja Portweiterleitungen.
Umgedreht ist es kein Problem.
Von innen nach außen. Aber von außen nach innen,
dein Router kriegt das Paket,
der weiß nicht wohin.
Willst du dahin? Willst du dahin?
Woher soll er das wissen? Er hat ja keinerlei Informationen
darüber.
Deswegen braucht man Portweiterleitungen.
Umgedreht ist es kein Problem.
Von innen nach außen.
Von innen nach außen greift man ja von einer privaten
IP auf eine Public IP zu.
Das kann sich das NAT merken
und erkennt das dann an der Antwort
passend zu dem, der die Anfrage gestellt hat.
Aber umgedreht, wenn quasi die
Verbindung aufgebaut werden soll, von außen
nach innen, dann hat der Router keine Ahnung,
wo er es hinschicken soll.
Den man dann auch entsprechend konfigurieren
müsste, mit einer Weiterleitung.
Der ist natürlich nicht konfiguriert.
Den können sie auch nicht konfigurieren, weil
auf den können sie gar nicht zugreifen.
Der Provider könnte den konfigurieren,
macht er aber nicht. Wozu auch
die Arbeit. Deswegen, da ist
also das Problem. Aber dafür
gibt es ja ng-rock.
Um das Ganze jetzt hier praktisch
zu zeigen, habe ich mich jetzt hier mal
auf meinen Raspberry Pi
verwendet.
Ich habe das Glück, dass ich meine
Lifetime IPv4
Adresse bei dem
schlechtesten Provider
aller Zeiten habe.
Mit der schlechtesten VM aller Zeiten.
Aber für 35 Dollar Lifetime
eine IPv4 Adresse gekriegt habe.
Und alles was ich tunneln müsste,
tunnele ich immer über meinen Server
per SSH. Ganz easy.
Einfach über die externen
IP getunnelt.
Im SSH Tunnel.
Port Weiterleitung. Gut ist.
Also man kann ja
mit SSH wunderbar
sogar Ports weiterleiten. Von außen nach innen.
SSH kann alles.
Also einloggen.
Und die entsprechende Durchleitung
die lege ich mit ng-rock
unter ng-rock.com
Ich brauche da einen Account. Den habe
ich jetzt hier schon erstellt.
Ich erst mal nebenbei was.
Im ersten Login steht hier direkt die
Installationsanleitung dabei.
Ist relativ einfach.
Für meinen Pi muss ich
jetzt hier die Software runterladen.
Machen wir das hier mal ganz schnell.
Ganz fertig.
So.
Die Datei wird ausgepackt.
Es gibt ein paar
solcher Dienste.
Und ich gehe davon aus, dass man das öfters
braucht. Insoweit werde ich das...
SSH hat aber viel Overhead beziehungsweise
niedrige Band. Das stimmt.
...verschieben in mein Benutzerverzeichnis.
Also raus aus dem Downloadsverzeichnis.
So habe ich jetzt gerade
eingefügt. Da ist die Datei.
So nun wenn ich eben jetzt...
...einen Anzip machen könnte und gut ist...
... dann kann ich da relativ
leicht drauf zugreifen.
So. Die entsprechenden Befehle, die sind
alle in der...
...seite zu sehen.
So. Auspacken.
Gut. Habe ich jetzt gerade gemacht.
Und danach müssen wir uns mit unserem Account
verbinden. Und dazu wird
ein spezieller Authentifizierungstoken...
Ja. Man kann auch bei SSH
glaube ich sogar sagen, für solche Zwecke will man
die Verschlüsselung ausschalten.
...und ja.
Wenn eben das Video online ist,
ist die Nummer schon geändert. Also das
Ganze mit Steuerung A, Steuerung C.
Ok. Kopieren
geht aber jetzt nicht. Ich muss da mal reinklicken.
Ist ein bisschen kompliziert hier aus irgendeinem Grund.
Ich glaube ich habe alles.
Steuerung C.
Das wird dann
hier entsprechend eingefügt.
Ok.
Ich hatte davor das Dollarzeichen noch
über Copy & Paste eingefügt. Insoweit das
kommt weg. Also einfach die Zeile nochmal
eingeben. Aber...
...mit dem heutigen Verzeichnis.
So. Dann wird
dieser Authentifizierungstoken
in die Datei geschrieben.
Und nun können wir
den Dienst nutzen.
Und jetzt...
Ich möchte
den HTTP-Tunnel.
Der läuft auch auf Port 80, weil
da läuft ja hier mein Nextcloud.
So. Also.
ngrok.
Dann das Protokoll. Und dann der Port.
Das ist einfach.
http.
Und der
Port ist 80.
Schicken wir das Ganze ab.
Dann verbindet sich
die Software mit dem entsprechenden Account.
Und hier haben wir jetzt die
http-Adresse,
auf die wir uns verbinden können.
Und die wird weitergeleitet an unseren
Localhost Port 80.
Bevor ich allerdings jetzt
darauf zugreife. Eine kleine Besonderheit
für... Man muss sich mal überlegen, was
für ein abgedrehter Tunnel das jetzt eigentlich ist.
Das ist im Prinzip gar kein
Unterschied zu, wenn man einen externen
Server hat und
sich da drüber tunnelt. Nur dass der externe Server
halt nicht hier von einem selbst betrieben wird,
sondern von ngrok.
Da muss ich mal überlegen, was für ein krasses rumgetunnelt
der ganze Scheiß ist. Du hast
intern IPv4. Das wird
eingepackt über IPv6 an
Unity Media.
Unity Media macht dann carrier create NAT,
schickt dich per IPv4 wieder raus.
Das heißt, dieser Tunnel ist auf jeden Fall immer
dazwischen. Dort
gehst du weiter auf einen ngrok Server,
machst einen Port auf, worüber
dann die Antworten wieder zurückgetunnelt werden.
Das ist voll für'n
Arsch, dass das überhaupt notwendig ist.
Cloud hatten wir in dem entsprechenden
Video angesprochen. Nextcloud... Dann lieber
2€ im Monat bezahlen für eine Public IPv4
und V6. Unbedingt, dass man über eine fremde
Domain darauf zugreift.
Deswegen kennt Nextcloud die
sogenannten vertrauten Domains
in der Konfigurationsdatei.
Und wenn wir da nicht drinstehen, dann funktioniert
natürlich der Zugriff auf den Web-Server.
Aber Nextcloud lässt sich
nicht bedienen. Deswegen
jetzt hier ganz kurz...
Ja gut, das müssen wir uns mal angucken.
Das kann man machen. Gibt
ein paar Varianten, wie man sich da durchtunneln kann.
Ähm...
Aber gucken wir jetzt mal weiter
bei IPv4. Hast du Unity Media? Ja.
Reicht es einfach, wenn man Unity Media
anschreibt, dass man ein Dual-Stack haben möchte?
Du musst
Power-Upload buchen bei Unity Media. Aber
schreib den Twitter-Support an. Die sind immer schnell
zu finden.
Wer in Linux, wer unter Linux mal kurz
seine SSH, äh nicht seine SSH,
seine Shell-Session sharen will,
der kann das hier verwenden. Das ist auch
ganz praktisch. Das da.
Instant Terminal Sharing.
Da kann man einfach seine
aktuelle Shell-Session freigeben.
Auch über so einen Sharing-Link ist auch
recht praktisch.
Sekunde.
Das ist doch gestellt, oder?
Das ist doch gestellt.
Das ist doch gestellt. Warum steht der Typ so blöd da und macht
nichts?
Das ist doch,
also das ist doch gestellt, oder?
Leute, ernsthaft.
Was macht der Typ da?
Der schießt nicht, der fliegt einfach nur, dass er
gesniped werden kann.
He's aiming at players that are spotted.
He's shooting them because he knows on the reticle
exactly where to aim. That's completely
fine. But just something about
the clip. And the fact that he sent three
clips from exactly the same spot on
Caspian Border Battlefield 3. It just,
I don't know. I think it's
probably fine. I like to give players the benefit of the doubt.
But do let me know down below. You always
know me. I tend not to include clips
if I'm not sure. And if I'm not sure, I'll let you know.
Guck mal, die stehen da einfach nur rum und machen nichts.
Opening up the top plays
to cheaters. Die stehen da einfach nur rum, machen nichts.
und gucken in seine Richtung.
Ne, das glaube ich nicht.
Simply isn't right. This though, it could be a
legitimate clip. And either way, it does look
pretty damn impressive.
Ne, die stehen einfach nur sinnlos rum und machen
nichts. As he just nails players
at this long range. Headshots as well
for the majority of these shots, which
is absolutely insane. If that's legitimate,
well, that's just incredible.
Nein. Guck mal, nein, nein, nein,
nein, nein, nein.
Strictly not a sniping
clip, because, yes, it's a tank.
But the range
that he manages to get is
incredible. Jesus is one of the best players
in Battlefield.
And look at that. He actually hits two
air vehicles.
Jets in the distance and the helicopter. We watch it
again. Just enjoy this absolutely
incredible clip. Okay, das war,
das war,
eigentlich hat er predicted,
der fliegt jetzt runter.
Guck hier, der schießt da hin und er hofft, der fliegt jetzt
runter. Tank clip. Hat er aber nicht
gemacht.
So. Und dass der da jetzt
trifft, das ist definitiv
Glück.
Was ist denn das für eine Sniper?
Ah, die China Sniper.
Ist das Battlefield
3? Oder 4?
Ich erkenne es gar nicht mehr genau.
Was ist es denn?
Battlefield 3?
3?
Gab es so viele chinesische Waffen
in Battlefield 3?
Ist das Thalarmarket?
Weil die Chinesen gab es in Battlefield 3
doch gar nicht.
Und was gab es denn für Fraktionen
in Battlefield 3?
Es gab diese Terroristen-Fraktionen,
es gab die Amis,
es gab die Chinesen,
es gab, ähm,
Franzosen, glaube ich, ne?
Ach, klar.
Russen und Amis, ja.
Mehr nicht? Okay.
Gab es nicht?
Gab es nicht noch diese Terroristen-
Fraktion da?
Noch nicht, ja.
Wären die jetzt schnell gewesen
beim switchen, hätten sie
an den Piloten switchen können.
Das stimmt.
Ich glaube, diese Waffe habe ich nie
gespielt in Battlefield 3.
Auf jeden Fall nur Russen und Amis.
Kann sein, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau.
Was hat man auf Terran Highway gespielt?
Hat man da auch Russen vs. Amis gespielt?
Echt?
Was hat man auf Terran Highway gespielt?
Hat man da auch Russen vs. Amis gespielt?
Echt?
Was hat man auf Terran Highway gespielt?
Hat man da auch Russen vs. Amis gespielt?
Echt?
Was hat man da auch Russen vs. Amis gespielt?
In der Tat würde ich sagen, dass das eine der Maps ist, die ich hoffe, in einem zukünftigen Battlefield-Game wiederhergestellt wird.
Es gibt etwas darüber, nur die Ästhetik des gesamten Maps, das macht mich wirklich leid.
Die Ästhetik des gesamten Maps, das macht mich wirklich leid.
Aber spielt der mit 15 FPS oder was ist da los? Guckt euch mal an, wie sehr das rumleckt.
Die Ertrennung von Scream und zwei Clips. Der erste muss ein Eishochter-Clip oder ein Youtube-Clip sein.
Der erste muss ein Eishochter-Clip oder ein YouTube-Clip sein.
Die Meteorite.
Du wolltest was zur Medias arteries.
Was soll das tun?
sagen, oh, oh, oh, äh, schreib
nochmal, ich hab's nicht mehr in der
History.
Spaß!
Die Gegner sind wieder richtig
hängen geblieben.
Mir fällt immer wieder auf, wenn ich
Battlefield 3 und teilweise auch 4 Clips sehen,
wie gut sich das Game auch einfach
anschauen lässt, obwohl das 10 Jahre
alt ist oder so, oder?
Gar nicht ganz, aber fast.
Man kann es einfach gut angucken.
Hätten die mal,
hätten die da mal Squad Rush
zu einem ordentlichen eSport
tauglichen Modus ausgebaut?
Ich sag's immer wieder, ähm,
die müssen, die müssen einfach nur gutes,
gutes, äh, Squad Rush bringen.
Das wäre ein richtig
guter Modus, eine richtig schöne
Kombi aus dem, was die Leute aus
Rainbow Six können, aus dem, was die Leute aus CS
kommen. Squad Rush ist einfach was,
was ich, finde ich, mehr wie jeder
andere Modus in Battlefield für eSport
eignen würde.
Vor allem, weil es kein Aufguss ist von
einem Modus, den es schon in anderen Games gibt,
sondern was eigenes ist, was Battlefield auch
gut repräsentiert und man
auch gut umgesetzt
richtig schön zuschauen könnte.
Ich wollte
ein paar Tipps haben, worauf man achten muss,
wenn ich Medien wie Fotos und Filme
in meinem WLAN zur Verfügung stellen möchte, was
Sicherheit angeht. Ja, als erstes natürlich
mal ein ordentliches WLAN-Passwort
äh, und ansonsten
du musst
den Dienst ja aufmachen, also du musst
den, du willst ja darauf zugreifen.
Äh, du könntest, du könntest
sofern es deinen Router hergibt, natürlich noch
einstellen, wenn du mehrere WLANs, mehrere
LANs, sonst was hast, wer genau darf,
welches Netzwerk darf, welches Netzwerk nicht darf.
Ähm, aber ich gehe mal davon aus,
du willst vom WLAN in das WLAN zugreifen,
also quasi von Geräten im WLAN auf den
Server, der im WLAN steht oder eine IP aus
dem WLAN hat, ähm,
das Einzige, was du noch
machen könntest, ist,
hier bei einem ordentlichen WLAN-Passwort,
ähm, du könntest so Geschichten machen, wie
wie, wie, wie ein MAC-Adressfilter,
wobei das halt nicht, ähm,
wirklich
das sicherer macht im eigentlichen Sinn, aber es
macht es halt ein bisschen komplizierter,
ähm, was du machen könntest, ist
auf dem jeweiligen Server, wo du das Ganze
laufen lässt, also auf deinem NAS,
ich würde halt gucken, dass ich dort
alle Ports dicht mache,
die nicht notwendig sind für den
Fileserver. Also ich würde dort, wenn es
keine Ahnung ist, sagen wir eine Raspberry Pi mit einer
Platte dran ist und, ähm,
da läuft was drauf, ich würde alles dicht machen,
ich würde SSH dicht machen,
ich würde alles dicht machen, außer den Fileserver
und nur Zugriff erlauben aus
dem internen Admin-Netz.
Achso, und dann eine dicke USB-Platte
an den, ach, du willst die
Platte an den Router machen?
Oh, da kann ich dir nichts zu raten,
das habe ich nie ausprobiert, ich weiß nicht, was die Fritzbox
da für Möglichkeiten bietet.
Gescheites WLAN-Passwort
dürfte wahrscheinlich das Wichtigste sein.
Ich weiß, dass es keinen Unterschied
macht mit der MAC-Adresse, kann man aber
machen, es ist, ich sage ja, das, wirklich bringen
tut es eigentlich nichts.
Ähm, es ist ein ordentliches
Passwort, ja, ansonsten
fällt mir da auch nicht allzu viel ein. Und wenn du es auf
ein extra System machst, wie gesagt,
falls du eine Raspberry hinstellst mit einer Platte oder so,
ich würde alles dicht machen, außer
den Port, also lokal,
auf dem jeweiligen Gerät, würde ich alles
dicht machen, ähm, was du
dicht machen kannst. Ich würde irgendwie IP-Tables
einschalten, oder, äh,
wie heißt das neue?
Nicht IP-Tables, wie heißt das?
Nee, äh, hab vergessen, wie das
neue heißt.
Ähm, alles dicht machen,
außer vom Admin-Netz aus,
außer dem, außer dem File-Sharing-Port,
den du brauchst.
Nein, nicht File-Port, wie heißt denn das Ding?
Ähm,
Tables,
Nachfolger,
NF-Tables, meine ich, ja,
NF-Tables, äh,
ja, also, die Fritzbox ist kein,
definitiv, also, auf jeden Fall kein gutes NAS,
ähm, das schafft irgendwie
3 oder 4 MB die Sekunde, wenn überhaupt, das ist
wirklich lahm, also, der USB-Anschluss
und generell das Ganze, äh,
es ist eher, es ist
eher ne, ne
Funktion, die
RVM zur Verfügung stellt, weil es geht,
nicht, weil man sie benutzen sollte.
Also, NAS über Fritzbox keine
gute Idee.
Dann stell dir lieber
nen Raspberry Pi hin, der auch zwar nicht
wahnsinnig gut ist für NAS,
aber zumindest hinkriegt, Gigabit
halbwegs, halbwegs
Gigabit, äh, zu sättigen, ja.
Oh, das sind deutsche
Spieler, erhört.
Irgendwohl.
W3 macht einfach Bock zu gucken.
Oh, die Map, die Map war nice.
It can be very difficult
to push, but if you have a player like
Urbina, who's not afraid to
use the smoke to his advantage and push
through the enemy lines,
you're gonna do it right. A really nice
spraydown, switching out to his secondary
when required, and then a couple of kit switches.
Der pusht in die falsche Richtung.
Ach, das ist, Moment.
Doch, das ist doch Rush, oder?
Weil der ist doch Defender.
Der pusht, der pusht gerade in den
Spawn der Attacker rein.
Ja, das ist so ein Fail in Battlefield 3,
dass das in dem Ausmaß möglich war.
Guckt euch mal, guckt euch mal
Grand Bazaar an.
Oder TDM? Ah, TDM. Okay, dann,
dann ist gut. Weil das ist auch die gleiche
Stelle, wo man Rush spielt, ne, am Anfang.
Schon von Wolzen gehört, ja,
hab ich das ziemlich verbuggt, das.
Ähm, das war halt ein bisschen problematisch.
Oder, denkt mal, die Rush
Spawns in Grand Bazaar.
Das ist auch mal eine Lieblingswaffe
gewesen in dem Game.
M416, beste.
Was ist mit den Gegnern los?
Die Gegner sind wieder komplett
planlos, ja.
Hehe.
Boah, das ist cool.
Das ist cool. Ist das auch wieder Setup?
Die Gegner stehen einfach so dumm rum und bewegen sich nicht.
Na gut, der liegt halt einfach da und kämpft
sich halt ab.
Finishing off today's episode, it's one of the best
infantry clips. We've had some really, really
skillful clips in today's episode. Some awesome
infantry plays as well. This is Resh
playing on Norshark Canals,
a real arena to test your skills
out on Battlefield 3.
And he goes on an absolute rampage.
Spielt eigentlich in anderen TDM-Maps
noch irgendjemand?
Außer, ich mein, es war doch von Anfang
an immer Norshark Canals.
Just dominating enemy players.
Selbst Close Quarters
wird kaum noch gespielt.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
Ich muss aber langsam
die Waffe aufheben.
Alter, du hast keine Muni mehr.
Oh, die sind low, die kannst du schön wegsprayen.
Oh, die Noobs, die Noobs.
Ah, ist Battlefield 3
schön anzusehen, ja.
Diese weggesprayt werden, die
Kacknoobs. Guckt's euch mal an, wie sie da rumliegen und nichts
checken. Du kannst in dem
Game die Leute so ultra zerstören.
Oh, da hat er Glück
gehabt, dass er das überlebt hat.
Oh, die Taschenlampen.
Lampen. Hat sich wieder voll verdrängt.
Aber man merkt, dass er lange
ein bisschen nervös wird auf seinem Streak.
Jetzt ist es vorbei.
Thanks for watching this episode of the
Battlefield Top Players. If you did enjoy, leave a like
down below. If you didn't, feel free
to leave a dislike. You can find the
players channels in the description down below.
Leute, ich hab noch was zu essen da.
Wir gucken einfach noch ein Battlefield
Video. Zumindest den Anfang.
Wir gucken jetzt noch ein Battlefield Video, bis ich fertig gefuttert
bin.
Und dann gucken
wir noch was anderes. Wobei, eigentlich
brauche ich schon ganz schön lang on, hä? Oh ne.
Der Stream hat rumgespackt. Ich seh's.
Ich bin schon fast... Ich bin drei... Okay.
Oh ne. Stream.
Jetzt wieder.
Wir lassen es jetzt schon mal auf.
25 Minutes of best
footage.
Ist das Konsole?
Ne, oder die Auflösung ist
zu hoch für Konsole.
Aber das ist Blur. Warum hat er Blur? Was ist da
los?
Wieso wird gesprayt
werden?
Alter, krieg ich dir aus dem Maul.
In your face.
Spielt der mit Blur?
Allen Ernstes?
Keiner der Leute, die gut sind.
Spielt mit Blur?
Warum?
Oder ist das gar kein Blur?
Liegt das daran, dass er mit mehr FPS
spielt und... Ne, ich glaube, das
liegt an der, entweder an der Aufnahme, weil
das ist auf jeden Fall Motion Blur drinne.
Entweder liegt es an der Aufnahme oder an dem
ähm...
Wie er das gerendert hat, vielleicht.
Ja, du kannst ja in Vegas beispielsweise auch
Zwischenbildberechnungen machen.
So, ich weiß nicht, ob das Blur ist, der...
Aber doch, das ist, das müsste Blur sein, der
ingame entsteht, weil irgendwie so Sachen wie
hier Waffen und so die Kanten sind auch
verschoben. Das müsste schon ingame Blur sein.
Wobei der Killfeed, ne, der Killfeed oder
der Killfeed, aber guck mal, hier unten verzerrt
nix. Vielleicht ist es doch Post Processing Blur.
Ist ja auch egal!
Die Musik dabei!
Da stehen, sonnen ми weg gesprayt werden.
OH, Slow Mo Effekte hier!
Ich mein ganz ehrlich, so nen Feeling wo es,
wo es um dich übelst... Das hatte ich außer
in Battlefield 3 und teilweise in keinem
T... Battle.... Bad Company eins, zwei...
ähm... Battlefield 3, Battlefield 4.
Danach hatte ich das nicht mehr.
So geile Dinger hier.
Vor allem, des war ja gar kein DLC, des war ja bei Release,
dabei obwohl es dlc hieß ist ja was ich gut finde dass der typ gar nicht dabei
kommentiert das ist mir sogar viel lieber oder das kommentar von dem kerl
dabei max warum so wenig viewer fiel's batman muss den viewport anmachen
die musik im hintergrund passt zu null zum gameplay metro das war auch eine
sache die battlefield 3 richtig gut gemacht hat das muss man über die map
von drucken bis hin zu leiten bis sonst was permanent drauf lohnt sich das
noch neben mittlerweile nicht mehr die server sind ziemlich leer
wir gucken mal so essen wir gucken mal kurz
battle log bf3 was ist da noch so gibt
da ein noch selber selber browser
ist kaum kommen kann noch spieler
drauf
es gibt rasch classics mixed mode ich das wäre der einzige server für mich
hier rasch classics was soll ich denn filtern
nach was soll ich filtern das ist habe ich habe gar keinen filter an das müsste doch
eigentlich alles sein können nach allem filtern
rasch
spielt
warte mal spielt squad rasch noch irgendjemand
oh
rasch es gibt es gibt gut abends abends kriegt man vielleicht drei oder vier
server voll jetzt ist ja mittags kriegt man vielleicht drei vier server voll
aber das war es dann auch mehr gibt es nicht
hier kommt eine sagt gucken wir noch was was haben wir noch schönes links you can
make from old dead laptops
äh
was soll man aus alten laptops machen können man kann man kann aus dem display kann man so ein projektor machen da war ich aber schon immer zu faul dafür was kann man aus alten laptops sonst noch so machen ich meine für den server ist wahrscheinlich jeder raspberry pi besser geeignet als ein alter laptop nicht unbedingt von der rechenleistung her sondern einfach falls kein laptop rumstehen braucht gucken wir gucken uns mal wir gucken uns mal was man alles aus dem alten laptop machen kann
wir gucken uns mal was man alles aus dem alten laptop machen kann
But if they break or just get too old and too slow to do und
anything productive with
doesn't matter
new
reports
parts
of head of 10
of 10
Das waren auch die alten massiven Sinkpads hier, mit Metallscharniere und sowas.
Die waren richtig stabil.
Damit konntest du Leute erschlagen im Zweifelsfall.
So, let's get creative.
Oh, Zellhaut am Start.
Das wäre mir viel zu anstrengend, schon den ganzen Kram auszubauen.
Wie hat er das Sinkpad überhaupt so kaputt bekommen?
Wahrscheinlich hat er es schon kaputt gekauft.
Und wenn nicht, vielleicht ist er drüber gefahren.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, eine Sache, wie man das tatsächlich kaputt kriegt, so wie das ist,
wenn du es auf die Erde gelegt hast, also mal angenommen, du hast irgendwie eine Werkstatt oder irgendwas,
oder irgendwo, wo es einfach nur unordentlich ist, du hast es auf die Erde gelegt,
es liegt halt was drunter.
So, dass es quasi schräg liegt und du trittst drauf.
Dann kann es schon durchbrechen.
Oh, Speakers.
2008? Ich habe noch ein Notebook von 2008.
Das einzige Notebook, wobei, doch, nee, nee, das ist neuer.
As they're usually built into their own sealed enclosures,
you don't need to build a speaker box for them, and they can be used as is.
My particular ones are even ported for extra bass, which is very cool.
Bass.
Now, as they're physically quite flat and make an interesting shape when placed together,
I glued them to each other and soldered them up to a mini Bluetooth amplifier,
which I also glued in place.
As this amplifier...
Was ist das für ein Controller, den er da hat?
...
Mach mal den Finger weg, ich will sehen, was das ist.
Man sieht es nicht. Hat man das vorher gesehen, was es für ein Controller ist?
Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nicht, was das ist. Was ist das?
Keine Ahnung.
Erkennt es nicht.
Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nicht, was das ist. Was ist das?
Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts. Ich
aus, muss man ehrlich gesagt sagen.
Es sieht okay aus.
Es geht, glaube ich, hier eher darum, dass
man halt was draus bauen kann. Wenn man wirklich
USB, äh, Bluetooth-Lautsprecher
haben will, die man an die Wand hängt, man findet
bestimmt qualitativ deutlich besseres
für nicht viel Geld,
wenn man, wenn man,
sagen wir mal so, selbst auf AliExpress.
Und wahrscheinlich klingen die
auch noch besser, aber
für selbstgemacht ist das echt okay.
Ja, Alter, so eine Arbeit reinstecken,
anscheinend slaps auch noch der...
Ich glaube, wenn man wirklich
solche Do-it-yourself-Geschichten macht,
ähm, da geht's
auch mit um den Weg dahin, dass man
das, äh, quasi gut hinbekommt.
Das ist genauso, wie ich hier im Haus meine Controller
hab, äh, beispielsweise im Keller
für, äh, am Stromzähler und sowas.
Da hab ich auch sehr viel Arbeit reingesteckt.
Wahrscheinlich hätte ich mir was Fertiges kaufen können.
Aber
es ist einfach nice, wenn man
halt sieht, dass man ein schönes 3D-gedrucktes Gehäuse
hat, selbstprogrammierten Microcontroller
drinne und das funktioniert.
Wobei ich mir, nee, ich hätte mir nichts kaufen können,
weil, ähm, sowas Individuelles
äh, gibt's nicht zu kaufen. Fertig.
Ja. Siehste, Leute?
Hört sich doch gar nicht so schlecht an.
Kappa. HD.
Was für einen 3D-Drucker hast du?
Ich hab einen
i3-me...
What the fuck?
i3-Mega-S
hab ich.
Den da.
Moment.
Den da hab ich. Ja, genau.
i3-Mega-S
So einen Würfel
hab ich da noch nie drauf gedruckt.
Wenn man so einen Würfel da drauf drucken würde,
druckt das auch einen Monat oder so.
Die Dinger wären, also,
diese Sorte von 3D-Druckern wären...
umso langsamer, umso größere Sachen, man druckt.
Zufrieden, ja.
Ja. Für mich als 3D-Drucker-Noob
wunderbar.
Was macht der jetzt?
Baut der einen Föhn?
Will der jetzt einen Föhn bauen?
Das ist überhaupt nicht warm genug dafür
und nicht genug Luft.
Und als meine tatsächlich 10 Watt
an Kraft verwendet haben, würden sie sehr schnell
auf den 3D-Drucker anbauen, wenn sie auf den 3D-Drucker anbauen.
Der will LEDs kühlen.
Aber, wenn er auf den Heat-Plug montiert ist...
Das ist tatsächlich keine blöde Idee.
Ich hab ja an meinem 3D-Drucker
auch so einen Ring unten dran,
dass ich im Dunkeln sehe,
ähm, was er macht.
Ähm, naja.
Nee, äh.
Also ich hab mir bei AliExpress einfach so einen...
So was hier, genau.
Ich hab mal so eine... Nee, nee, ja.
Ja, so ähnlich.
Ich hab mir bei AliExpress so einen Ring bestellt, so einen LED-Ring.
Und das hab ich einfach mit Kabelbinder
so was hier in der...
So was hier. So was hier.
Sieht fast genauso aus.
Hab ich mir bei AliExpress bestellt
und, ähm, dann mit Kabelbinder
so hier.
Mit Kabelbinder unten an 3D-Drucker gemacht.
Und jetzt kann ich im Dunkeln sehen,
ähm, mit der Kamera,
die daneben steht, quasi wie weit er ist
und wie es aussieht, weil es immer gut beleuchtet ist.
Die Frage ist nur, was mach ich jetzt damit?
Ich hab gekühlte LEDs.
Und, und jetzt?
Nein.
Das sieht doof aus.
Das sieht nicht cool aus.
Na, ich weiß nicht.
Das gefällt mir nicht.
Oh, RIP.
...Diffusion Sheets,
Fresnel Lenses
and an acrylic back panel.
These work together,
to spread out the backlight evenly.
And to take advantage of them as is,
you can leave them inside the screen casing
and wire up the PCB on the back
to trigger the screen's built-in backlight.
...to trigger the screen's built-in backlight.
This leaves you with a soft, diffused light source
that you can then put to a variety of uses.
Innergründlich beleuchtet halt.
...you could use it as a tracing backlight.
Or mount it onto the wall to be a fake window.
You could even print your favorite pictures onto thin paper.
...you could even print your favorite pictures onto thin paper.
Damit kann ich mich identifizieren.
Fake window, größer, echtes Window. Fake window, größer, echtes Window.
Für weniger Kontakt zur Außenwelt.
Pretty neat.
For help wiring these up to work like this,
I do have a separate dedicated video on the topic,
which you can find a link to in the description.
Now, if none of these strike your interest,
you can take the various layers out
and make use of them with LED strips.
As these have adhesive on the back
and can be cut to any length,
one idea is to stick a short length
to one side of a diffusion sheet from the screen.
Adding some double-sided tape opposite this,
allows the sheet to be looped around
to create a cylinder,
which, once mounted onto a wall,
diffuses the light emitted from the LED strips
so that it significantly reduces the glare from it
and turns it into a pretty slick wall light.
Even better, though, is using the Fresnel lenses instead for this.
As the lenses bend the light
and cause quite interesting distortions,
they, when wrapped around the LEDs,
make a really nice sparkly rainbow effect
that changes depending on what angle you look at it from.
This is still easy on the eyes,
but now it looks really nice visually as well.
As for the screen's acrylic back panel,
well, this is where you can get really creative.
For this, cover the sheet in masking tape
on both sides
and then trace a pattern or shape onto it.
Now, roughly cut around this
Oh, so'n Ding hab ich mir gekauft, Leute!
Es war eines der letzten Werkzeuge,
wo ich nur noch nicht hatte,
quer vor 2 Wochen hab ich mir einen gekauft hier.
ein Ding.
cake- cookении
cake- cookienie
cake- cookie
Die Tape kann dann weggepeilt werden, leaving you with your shape.
Now to make this extra special, we're going to light it up, for which we'll be using a couple of small LED-Filaments.
These work off around 3V of power, so are safe to touch and are cool running.
The first thing to do is to make some slots for these LEDs in the spot, and then cut out a base shape around them.
I stained mine to give it a bit more character.
The LED-Filaments can now be soldered onto some wires and pushed through two holes that need to be made in the slots.
Once wired up, they'll illuminate, which means that the last job is to glue the acrylic cutout in place.
The lights from the LEDs enter this cutout at the bottom and get scattered around, meaning that the whole thing gets lit up internally, giving you a pretty awesome little feature light.
The creative possibilities here are endless.
And could make a lot of money.
I think it looks really cool.
I don't really need it, but it looks really cool.
Now if your screen is not smashed, instead of dismantling it, you may want to get a separate driver board for it, which would allow you to use it as a standard independent computer monitor.
I again have a few videos about how to do this, after which they can be used to make, for example, a dual-screen laptop.
No, I don't know.
That looks pretty helpful.
Especially when you put it together.
That's like this laptop with the seven monitors.
Yeah.
That's just a little overkill, right?
First pack the suitcase for the notebook.
Yeah, optimal for the mobile work in the bar.
With that you're on the lawn of the king.
You don't do lawns anymore today.
Prices, prices are not available for this, by the way.
That's probably so expensive that they thought, we can't tell people right away.
And for increased productivity and improved ergonomics.
Ticken lauter kann man machen.
Or even a smart mirror, where you can watch YouTube videos as you do your teeth or have a shave.
As usual, there are links to these in the description if you're interested.
Now the next project we're going to make requires the use of one of the smallest discrete components you can find in a laptop.
And its location can vary, so you will have to do some hunting.
But what you are looking for is a little cylinder with two small walls.
Wires attached, and this is in fact a microphone.
Oh, huge, huge quality microphone, wahrscheinlich.
Good proof of which is that the little lavalier microphone that I'm wearing right now was made out of a laptop microphone that I disassembled several years ago.
And it sounds so good that I've just used it in almost every video I've made since then.
So that's hopefully testament to how good they can potentially sound.
Now, as most of you won't have a use for a little lavalier microphone, I will instead.
I will be showing you how to make a little clip-on communication microphone that you can clip onto your headphones and use for extremely clear calls or even communicating well with your teammates and friends.
Making this is quite simple, first requiring the microphone's wire.
Ähm, müssen wir gleich mal gucken. Modmix? Gibt es eigentlich neue Modmix?
Ich habe die Sache jetzt nicht mal so verfolgt, weil diese mittlerweile so unglaublich teuer geworden sind.
Ähm, ja, Medphones, Microphones.
So sehen die jetzt aus, okay.
Die sind schon krass teuer geworden mittlerweile, ey.
Ich habe noch das alte Modmix, was einfach nur einen, ja, so in diesem Preisregion, was einfach auch einen Klinkestecker hat.
Ähm, so eins da.
Der Richtung habe ich, aber ich habe noch Modmix 3, glaube ich, ist das.
Die hören sich nicht wahnsinnig gut an, aber für Ingame-Kommunikation und auch für...
Sprachaufgaben vollkommen okay.
Und man kann halt Kopfhörer seiner Wahl verwenden.
Das ist halt echt praktisch, ja.
Weil ich sage es immer wieder, Gaming-Headsets sind zum größten Teil crap oder halt richtig teuer.
Ähm, wenn man ein gutes haben will.
Die beste Kombination ist immer noch ein guter Kopfhörer und wenn man dann, und so ein Modmix.
...to be soldered to a shielded audio cable.
This shielded cable prevents...
...buzzing and interference noises, so it's quite important.
Now we can thread this wire through a small piece of plastic tubing,
leaving a short length of wire at the end for adjusting the microphone's position.
To mount it to your headphones, the easiest way is to mold a small clip out of the screw.
Once dried, the tube can be slid in place and adjusted as needed.
While that's essentially it for the headset, the microphone still needs amplifying,
as computers typically don't have very good microphone preamps,
so their microphone inputs...
...usually...
...usually introduce a lot of hiss into the audio signal.
The preamp I recommend can work off the 5 volts provided from a USB port,
and it's easy enough to wire up.
Looking closely at it, you should be able to see a few little jumpers.
These allow us to adjust the behaviour of the amplification,
controlling both the overall volume and also the reaction speed of the board's auto gain control.
This auto gain control can reduce the volume if the input is too loud,
so you'll never get sound...
...and it will be much less performing if you talk too loudly or shout.
Once covered up, this can be plugged into a computer's USB port and microphone input...
...for end use as a decent sounding budget microphone.
So, how does it sound?
Personally, I think it sounds pretty good.
Wenn man sonst nichts anderes zu tun hat in Game.
Ja, das Zalman-Mikro, das geht, aber das klingt wirklich nicht gut.
Also, wenn du nur Russen beleidigen willst in CS, dann ist das Mikrofon okay.
Warum hat er so eine gute Quali damit?
Ja, weil die Platzierung ganz gut ist.
Ich würde sagen, die Platzierung ist ziemlich gut.
Weil er ein echter Hacker ist, genau.
Sprache, ganz ehrlich, Sprache aufnehmen, so ganz normales Gelabere in einem halbwegs normalen Raum, das kannst du mit fast jedem Mikro machen.
Das hört sich mit allem ganz okay an.
Wenn man das dann aber mal vergleicht, wenn man die Stimme von ihm zum Beispiel mal hört, wenn man das mit einem ordentlichen Mikrofon aufgenommen hätte, dann sieht man erstmal den Unterschied.
Hört man den Unterschied.
Wenn der Drive in einer sinnvollen Kapazität ist, dann sollte das wirklich sein Hauptvermögen sein, denn es ist einfach das, was es am meisten nützlich ist, um Daten zu steuern.
Nun, wenn der Drive gebrochen ist, oder vielleicht nur zu klein in Kapazität, um etwas anderes zu nutzen, dann gibt es hier einige interessante und lustige Projekte, die man machen kann, indem man einen ausmantelt.
Um einen reinzunehmen, braucht man einen passenden Schraubendreher, der normalerweise in einem Multi-Bit-Set ist, und wenn du rein bist, siehst du die Platte und den Kopf-Array.
Wenn du das aufmachst, ist in der Regel das Ding im Arsch, hat er auch gerade hingeschrieben.
Als die Platten ziemlich schnell spinnen, gibt es einen Trick, einen Ring von Sandpapier auszuschneiden und es an die oberste Platte zu kleben.
Dies kann dann für die Kleidung oder die Schärfung von Dingen wie einem Pencil genutzt werden.
Bitte! Auf die Idee muss man erstmal kommen!
Den Festplatten du Schleifer!
Um ehrlich zu sein, ist das ein bisschen gimmicky, da es viel schneller ist, als nur einen Pencil-Schraubendreher zu benutzen, aber es ist immer noch sehr novel.
Du kannst aber diese Platten nicht abschneiden.
Die Idee ist, die Idee ist so abgedreht, dass ich die schon wieder cool finde.
Ne, da reicht, da reicht Pfeifert nicht aus.
Da brauchen wir mindestens ein Six-Head.
Siehst du, sie sind sehr glänzend.
Da sie eigentlich auch einen schönen Ring haben, kannst du mit ihnen ein bisschen Windschneiden machen.
Und sie verbreiten die Lichter schön, wenn es im Sonnenschein ist.
Glänzend?
Was für ein Game ist das, wo irgendein Mob oder irgendein Ingame-Fisch die ganze Zeit sagt,
Oh, shiny!
Du kannst sogar einen kleinen, gebildeten Analog-Klopfen mit einem machen,
was für jemanden, der sich in ihre Technologie interessiert, ein schönes Geschenk wäre.
Nun, gehen wir zurück zum Drive, da bleibt der Kopf-Array.
Nun, sein Bewegung ist von einigen Kreisen unter diesen mächtigen Magneten.
Also, wenn du ein paar Kreise zu diesen Kreisen schlägst, kann der Kopf zurück und zurück gefordert werden, indem du eine Voltage anmachst.
Wenn wir einen Audio-Amplifier dazu rücken,
wird es so, dass es sich um die Kraft des Kopfes handelt.
Es wird tatsächlich mit dem Sound-Signal vibriert, genau wie ein Hörer.
Wenn du dich fragst, ist es audibler, aber es klingt sehr dünn.
Ein kleiner Papierkopf verbessert die Sache, aber während seine Basis nahe hoch ist,
fällt es schnell ab und klingt wieder dünn, weiter weg und zurückkommt zu einem schrecklichen Geräusch.
Das ist nicht unser Ziel, denn wir haben schon einen Hörer gemacht, und der aktuelle Plan ist viel cooler.
Also, um zu beginnen, brauchen wir einen kleinen Laser-Punkter.
Was?
Jetzt, Leute, Leute, ich sehe schon, jetzt, jetzt.
Wirklich, äh, Exploding-Brain angesagt.
Was, es leckt?
Unity Media, please.
Was machen die bei Unity Media dann wieder?
Ich kann nichts dafür, dass der Stream ruckelt.
Ich kann nichts dafür, Leute.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es an Twitch liegt.
Ihr seht es ja da unten, ob es funktioniert oder nicht.
Es funktioniert nicht.
Ich bin da voll am Abspacken.
Haben wir es heute nochmal, Unity Media?
Na?
Ne.
Das ist keine Minecraft-Musik, das ist die Epic Chill-Step Collection 2020.
Oh, jetzt ist es RIP.
Leute, es ist vorbei.
Manchmal hilft ein Router-Restart.
Ich mache jetzt garantiert keinen Router-Restart.
Nur, weil es Unity Media nicht gebacken kriegt.
Ich mache einen Router-Restart, wenn ich dann, wenn ich dann off gehe.
Stimmt.
Wie war diese Seite nochmal?
Alle Störungen oder so?
Wow.
Oh.
Okay.
Try-Fi.
Endlich lohnt sich mein neues Emote.
Scheint wieder zu funktionieren.
Okay, scheint wieder zu gehen.
Okay, dann gucken wir das Video mal weiter.
Wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben hier?
Was, wie der F?
Ist wieder, ist wieder kaputt?
Ist wieder kaputt?
Geht wieder.
Ähm, Basti, weh, bei mir gibt es kein Gigabit.
Sonst würde ich das auch machen, aber gibt es nicht.
Noch nicht?
Okay.
Wir können es an die Head-Array verbinden, damit es auch mit dem Sensor vibriert.
Kannst du sehen, wo es geht?
Nein, kann ich nicht.
Das Zeichnen an einer Wand erzeugt einen visiblen analogen VE-Meter, der mit dem VE-Meter folgt.
Oh, Big Brain.
Es sieht wirklich cool aus im Allgemeinen.
Und ich denke, es ist ein guter Anwendung eines Dead Drive.
So, jetzt ist es Zeit, über Batterien zu sprechen.
Nun, die meisten älteren Laptops haben tatsächlich eine Batterie-Pack, die von individuellen 18650-Batterie-Zellen hergestellt ist.
Das ist eine tolle Nachricht für uns.
Das sind die gleichen Dinger, die man auch in E-Zigaretten reinmacht.
Denn diese sind wirklich einfach zu repurposeieren und zu anderen Verwendungen zu geben.
Jedoch die Challenge ist, dass sie Plastik sind und sie sich entfernen.
Nun, du hast den Risiko, die Batterie-Zellen zu puncturieren.
Das ist eine schlechte Idee.
Also die Dinger, die können echt ordentlich in die Luft fliegen.
So ein Akku.
Oder auch so eine einzelne Zelle.
Oder auch so eine Batterie, die unter 2,8V ist.
Weil meine alle sicher über diesen Wert sind, ist es gut, sie wiederzuverwenden.
Während du diese in jeder Menge Projekte verwenden könntest, musst du die Sicherheitszwecke implementieren, damit du sie nicht überdischargen kannst.
Vor allem, du brauchst vor allem auch etwas, das das Chargen nicht ausmacht.
Also das Handling von Akkus ist gar nicht so ohne.
Das kann ziemlich kompliziert werden.
Also empfehle ich stattdessen ein paar leere Einzelzellen-Batterie-Zellen.
Gibt es eigentlich ein neues Elektro-Move-Video? Ja, gab es vor ein paar Tagen.
Diese sind super günstig und haben die Sicherheitszwecke verbaut, die sie auswählen, wenn die Zelle 2,8V erreicht.
Du kannst sie dann verwenden, um deine Geräte zu schalten.
Oder du kannst Dinge wie das Sprecher-Projekt, das wir vorhin gemacht haben, anbieten.
Batterie-Zellen können ziemlich teuer sein.
Also einfach die Verkleidungen und die Verwendung...
Vor allem ist das unglaublich ineffektiv.
Je nachdem, was du für Controller betreibst.
Weil die meisten Controller sind ja intern.
3,3 Volt, das ist total...
Das über USB und...
... und so alte Laptop-Batterien wie diese sind ein guter Weg, Geld zu sparen.
Also so weit haben wir schon einige interessante Dinge gemacht.
Aber bevor...
Dieses Ding für die Wand fand ich ganz cool.
Aber die Lampe, nee.
Vor allem hat die dann auch noch...
Dann hat die auch noch einen Lüfter dran.
... alte, aber sonst noch funktionierende Laptops.
Ich will über diesen Video-Sponsor Squarespace sprechen.
Squarespace.
Okay.
Skippen das jetzt mal kurz.
... noting that if you're new to website design and need some help, find a link to that down below.
So again, that's...
... the one that will save you the most amount of money.
Which is actually repurposing laptop webcams and using them to make a home security system.
What?
This is fairly easy to do, as laptop webcams usually use the USB protocol.
Meaning that they can just be soldered up to a USB cable.
After which they can be used on any PC as a standard video input.
These can then be placed at various locations around your home.
Which can be done discreetly, as they're so tiny and un...
Das Problem bei den Dingern ist...
Du hast ja da keine Möglichkeit Nachtsicht und sonst was zu machen.
China wird hellhörig.
Nee, ein großer Vorteil von...
... auch Billy-China-Cams ist ja, dass du da...
... dass du da zumindest so eine...
... für Indoor eine gewisse Nachtsicht-Funktion auch eingebaut hast.
... obtrusive.
Once hooked up to a computer running some software like Contacam, the webcams can be monitored and recorded.
And the software can even notify you by email of any movement caught by the cameras.
For more info there is, you guessed it, a link to a thorough video on the topic in the description.
Now the computer that these webcams...
... can be...
... plugged into doesn't have to be particularly powerful.
So this is actually a great use of an older one that still works, but you don't know what to do with.
Some more ideas, particularly if the operating system is old as well, is to use it as a retro gaming machine, as some games don't work on modern PCs.
Old laptops can also be a bit of a lifesaver for specific old hardware.
Rides, break the house, but the accompanying software only works on older 32-bit versions of Windows, so it needs to be run on older hardware to use at all.
Another thing you could do is use one as a media PC.
I actually took one apart a while ago for this task, and to make it a bit nicer looking, I transplanted the hardware into a new scratch-built case...
... so that it wasn't an iSoft computer.
... living room.
The last thing...
If anyone wants to turn it into a complete DIY, get yourself a Raspberry, although...
... speed-wise it's the best thing you can do in the current living room.
I was gonna suggest that you literally just give it away to someone who doesn't have a PC.
Whether it's a young person who needs to learn about how computers work, or an old person who just needs access to emails...
There are really people who don't have a PC but already want a PC.
Most older people I know who don't have a PC...
haben, die wollen keinen PC. Und alle, die einen PC haben wollen, die haben eigentlich
einen.
Ja, okay, haben wir. Alles gut.
Waren ja ein paar ganz gute Sachen
dabei, ja.
So, was macht der hier? Der übertaktet seine
Switch. Okay, gucken wir mal.
Nochmal kurz.
Boah!
Alter, sieht Witcher auf
der Switch scheiße aus.
Ach du Kacke.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Der Switcher.
Der Switcher. Oh Gott, sieht das schlecht aus.
Der sieht aus wie ein
Spiel von...
...von 95.
Der Switcher. Oh je, oh je.
Das tut weh.
Wie kein Bild.
Ist wieder RIP?
Nee, oder?
Alles gut.
Schon was gibt für...
Was, was braucht man dafür?
Oh, unofficial Switch-Route.
Hm.
Okay, ich weiß, was wir demnächst machen werden.
Oh, huge.
Ist das Monka-Toss?
Darf man das on-stream machen?
Die Switch-Flashen?
Oder ist das Monka-Toss?
Ich meine, ich darf ja, es ist ja nicht verboten, ich darf ja mein Eigentum auch zerstören, wie ich lustig bin, ja?
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, ob Twitch da was dagegen hat.
...as an example then, I wanted to explore the options on the table.
With full access to its menus, can we improve its visuals?
Can we push this game to higher resolutions and what about attaining a smoother framerate?
Up to 60 frames per second in a game that's already pushing Switch hard at 30 FPS?
Let's find out.
...on chipset, tackling games that are built for far more powerful systems.
Seemingly impossible ports like The Witcher 3, Wolfenstein 2 and even Mortal Kombat 11
were made possible with some smart engineering choices.
Though, of course, always with trade-offs next to the PS4 or Xbox One counterparts.
In every case...
Boah, sieht das kacke aus.
Alter, sieht das kacke aus.
...kacke aus.
Guckt euch das mal an!
Uah!
...needs a...
...kiefkind.
Sechs Monate am Stück.
Dankeschön.
Huge sub.
...samskramer!
Beeindruckend genug, dass es auf Arm-CPUs läuft.
Ja, okay, aber es sieht kacke aus.
...careful balancing act to optimize the Switches GPU and CPU clocks, as determined by Nintendo early on.
Zumal, ein Problem hat das Spiel ja auch noch.
Es sieht erstens ziemlich schwammig aus.
Und es ruckelt auch noch.
Also das Spiel ist halt einfach nicht für die Switch gemacht.
Das merkt man auch an allen Ecken und Enden.
Ich meine, es ist ihnen zugute zu halten, dass sie fast nichts entfernt haben, dass der Content-mäßig halt so bleibt, wie es ist.
Das sieht halt einfach so verschwommen aus.
Das ist vielleicht ein Teil durchs Hochskalieren, aber zum größten Teil, dass das so schwammig aussieht, ist einfach, weil es schwammig aussieht.
Man sieht das auch teilweise, dass sich die Auflösung dynamisch verändert.
Das ist halt schon krass verschwommen.
Da fehlen auch hier Büsche und Büsche und so.
Das wird halt viel später geladen.
Ich meine, es ist cool, dass sie es zum Laufen gekriegt haben auf der Switch.
Vor allem im kompletten Umfang.
Du kriegst ja das komplette Game.
Und du kannst zum ersten Mal, wenn du das Spiel auf der Switch hast,
zum ersten Mal mobil spielen.
Aber es sieht halt nicht gut aus.
Warum taktet sich das Ding im Dock nicht einfach hoch?
Ich würde sogar sagen, macht es doch, oder?
Macht es, glaube ich, auch.
Allerdings nicht maximal.
Also, du hast im Dock auf jeden Fall mehr Leistung als mobil.
Weil manche Spiele, also, vermute ich einfach mal,
weil du manche Spiele einfach besser und höhere Auflösung und flüssiger spielen kannst im Dock als mobil.
Guckt euch das mal an jetzt.
Oh, du bist, äh.
Das ist nicht durch hochskalieren.
Das sieht einfach kacke aus.
Ich meine, das sind halt Kompromisse, die muss man eingehen, damit es läuft.
V.a. wenn man nur Switch-Docks unter der TV spielt,
was ist der Fokus für diese Analyse?
Die gute Neuheit dann,
eine modifizierte Switch kann die Shield-Klöcke an der Maschine restaurieren,
ein 75%-Eingriff auf die CPU und 20% auf die GPU.
An der Witcher 3 als Beispiel dann,
der erste Test ist, was das Overclock-Test gegen den Standard-Playthrough macht.
Die Witcher 3 ist natürlich ein interessanter Test-Subjekt,
ein Spiel, das beide CPU und GPU intensiv in verschiedenen Bereichen benötigt.
Saber...
dass das so verschwommen aussieht, liegt nicht an irgendwelchen Post-Processing-Sachen,
würde ich sagen, sondern einfach, weil es dynamische Auflösungen hat
und die Auflösung halt ziemlich niedrig ist, entweder.
Ist doch Quatsch, Switch und PC zu vergleichen.
Naja, nee, wenn es das gleiche Game ist, nicht.
Ich meine, es ist low.
Es ist logisch, dass das auf der Switch nicht so gut aussehen wird, wie auf dem PC.
Sie fragen nur, ob man damit leben kann.
Also ich finde, es ist echt an der Grenze, das Erträgliche.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist ja...
Ist das Ocarina of Time oder was?
...like Novigrad could struggle with the high character counts and lots of draw calls.
With an overclock in place, the goalposts move in time.
Vor allem dann droppt das auf 20 FPS runter.
And yes, as I'll get onto later,
that means Headroom to improve the visuals ourselves.
Es ist halt schlicht und ergreifend nicht gemacht für die Plattform.
Das merkst du an allen Ecken.
So, first up, this is docked play on regular Switch GPU and CPU clocks.
Die Lösung, Stadia.
Hahaha.
In dem Fall tatsächlich, ja.
In dem Fall wäre Stadia tatsächlich nicht schlecht.
Aber ich glaube, Witcher 3 gibt es auf Stadia nicht.
...are left as standard.
This is what we have out of the box.
I'm simply unlocking the frame rate here to go up to 60, what's happening.
I've also kept some useful diagnostics at the top with frame times on the CPU and GPU on show.
Oh, and plus, there's a rolling update on what resolution is actually being used at any point.
This is all fascinating stuff.
It shows how, well, dynamic that dynamic resolution system really is.
And that actually we're rarely tapping into a full 720p native res.
More often than not, and going by the numbers here, we're lurking at 548p in real time.
548p in places like the Krupp Back Bog.
Off-Time.
Or 636p in that Gryphon battle.
It's always in flux and rarely at 720p in reality.
It does, though, reveal the kind of tussle that goes on behind the scenes
to keep its frame rate at the intended 30fps target.
Oh, huge Auflösung. 840x480.
Huiuiui.
The frame rate stats are still a big part of the story.
This classic Novigrad run shows the range, a
regular switch on standard clocks goes through.
Outside the city, most spots go above 30fps.
Even galloping at full speed shows plenty above the head.
Dadurch, dass die Auflösung relativ hoch bleibt, heißt das auch, dass es eindeutig
CPU limitiert hier in der Stadt und nicht GPU.
To just keep the game running fluidly with a cap.
This is a crucial point, though.
If there's enough headroom to go much higher than, say, 35fps,
the GPU power is instead put into raising the resolution until it gets to 720p.
And that kind of makes sense, doesn't it?
To focus on image quality and make the most of Switch's resources.
That level of adaptability is essential to getting this game working,
to adjust to every scenario.
Now, later I'll be showing what happens once you switch dynamic resolution scaling,
or DRS, off entirely.
The way it looks and how it impacts performance.
But with the enabled margin...
Yeah, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Aber ganz ehrlich, viel wird das nicht bringen.
Also selbst wenn ja die Switch übertaktet, sagen wir mal, auf den normalen Takt,
da kriegst du vielleicht, pfff, keine Ahnung, 4, 5, maximal, 5fps mehr.
Da wirst du nicht viel kriegen.
Es geht ja nicht darum, dass du quasi in Szenen, wo du eh schon viel FPS hast,
noch mehr FPS kriegst.
Es geht ja hauptsächlich darum, dass du in Szenen, wo es ruckelt,
Quasi die FPS anhebst, weil wenn du 20 FPS hast, dann einen riesen Unterschied, ob du 20 oder 24 oder 25 hast.
Das macht halt schon einen großen Unterschied.
Und da kriegst du, ich würde mal sagen, 2, 3, 4, maximal 5 FPS kriegst du durch das Übertakten mehr.
Eher, eher, eher, vielleicht sogar weniger.
Ich warte noch bis der Bauer, der Bauer soll mal ein Video machen.
Switch overclocking.
Äh, Xeo, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass sie das schon geschafft haben, das auf die ARM-Architektur richtig zu portieren,
weil wenn du das emulieren würdest, das würde ja gar nicht laufen.
Das frisst ja viel zu viel.
Und sie werden das ja auch nicht wirklich groß ver...
Compiler können ja auch für ARM...
ARM-Binaries erzeugen.
Und, äh, ich denke mal, sie werden es so angepasst haben, dass das eben lauffähig ist.
Und dann, ja, es wird nicht einfach gewesen sein.
Je nachdem, was du für Spezialitäten der jeweiligen Plattform verwendest.
Wobei ich weniger, ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob das große Problem an der CPU-Architektur liegt.
Weil...
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, die Low-Level-Geschichten, wo sie da von Hand irgendwelche CPU-Instruktionen...
gebastelt haben, das wird sich in Grenzen halten.
Die ganze Switch-Architektur drumherum könnte...
dürfte viel eher das Problem sein, dass man eben mit den Limitationen zurechtkommen muss
und deswegen sein Game anpassen.
Ich glaube, das eigentliche lauffähig machen auf der Plattform war gar nicht...
Kann sein, dass ich...
Ich weiß nicht, wie das Spiel unten drunter funktioniert, ja?
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das...
dass...
dass es lauffähig ist.
Also ich meine damit, dass es einfach startet.
Äh, und dass man...
dass man es spielen kann, dass das gar nicht so der große Akt war.
Aber das Spiel anzupassen, so dass es eben erträglich läuft, dass das das eigentliche Problem war.
Ein Draw-Call hat nichts damit zu tun, dass die CPU irgendwelche...
irgendwelche Objekte...
äh...
ändert.
Ein Draw-Call ist, wenn ich...
wenn ich quasi neues Zeug zu meiner Grafikkarte hochlade und sage, sie soll malen.
Oh, Basti Iwe abonniert Twitch Prime und Xyzo...
äh, Xyzo CS abonniert auch Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön, Leute.
Huge IQ...
Subs.
Es ist nur wenig Zeit, um exklusive Emotes zu verdienen.
Monka-S.
Guckt's euch an.
Der Hypetrain!
Ich bin schon ganz...
ganz aufgeregt hier.
94%
Skammas, Alter!
Ja, dann mach mal.
Moment, hat der in 7 Minuten erzählt, dass er seine Switch übertanken wird und um sie dann 2 Minuten lang zu übertanken oder was?
Hier haben wir's.
Das gleiche Szenario, die gleichen Bestandteile, aber mit derpowered-CPU zu 1785 MHz
und mit derpelled-CPU zu 1785 MHz und mit derabled-CPU zu 1785 MHz und mit derabled-CPU zu 11 Nakto.
Das ist übrigens gar kein Overclock, das sind die normalen Specs.
Das Switch ist runtergetaktet.
Kann man den Hypetrain manuell deaktivieren?
Keine Ahnung.
Nee, der sagt bloß, ich soll Abos verschenken, dass der Hypetrain erfolgreich ist.
Mein Twitch-UI auf Englisch, ja.
Weil mein Browser auf Englisch ist.
Ja, guckt Leute.
2-3 FPS höchstens, war klar, dass da keine Wunder zu erwarten sind.
Das ist klar.
Ja, das ist klar.
2-3-4 FPS, genau das, was ich vermutet habe.
Da ist ja nichts grundlegend unterschiedlich jetzt.
Es ist halt ein bisschen schneller.
Das ist klar, dass wir da keinen großen Unterschied sehen.
Die Auflösung ist einfach nur höher.
Man müsste das ausschalten und mal gucken, was passiert.
Das ist klar, dass wir da keinen großen Unterschied sehen.
Sonst, in Bezug auf die Framerate, ist es nicht immer so viel.
Zum Beispiel, diese GPU-intensive Cutscene mit vielen ICFX-Effekten,
zeigt eine Delta von ca. 3-4 FPS, aber nicht viel mehr.
Was wir hier bekommen, ist immer noch ein Upgrade.
Die wilde Jagd ist 15 FPS und noch halb so wild.
In den großen Städten ist das der Stand-out-Punkt.
Die leckere Jagd ist das.
Aber das dürfte am CPU-Übertakt liegen,
weil die Grafikkarte in Novigrad wahrscheinlich nicht das Limitierende ist.
Ich meine immerhin, die CPU ist 40% oder so schneller.
Nicht eine große Distraktion, aber etwas, das man sich vorstellt.
Diese Konsole hat einen kleinen Vent am Top,
und je kleiner die Jagd und je höher der RPM,
desto mehr Geräusch bekommt die Maschine.
Wenn man so eine Switch spielt, möchte man vielleicht in einen Adapter investieren,
um die Konsole außerhalb des Docks zu halten.
Aber im Allgemeinen hatte ich keine Probleme mit über 10 Stunden Spielzeit.
aber im Allgemeinen hatte ich keine Probleme mit über 10 Stunden Spielzeit.
Die Überklappe löst dann ein großes Problem.
Das war ein großer Unterschied.
Guck dir das mal an!
Hier kommst du alles an.
Hier unten sind Büsche geladen, hier nicht und trotzdem ist es da hinten halt einfach
boah.
Moment, wie lange sind wir eigentlich heute schon on?
Oh, 4.40, Leute, es wird mal langsam Zeit, da darf ich off gehen.
It's a bit of work, but worth it.
Oh ja, oh ja, guckt euch mal hinten die Viecher an, das ist schon ein ordentlicher Unterschied
mit dynamischer Auflösung zu festen 720p, das sieht schon deutlich weniger verschwommen
aus wie das.
Ja, man sieht das schon, dafür ruckelt es wahrscheinlich rechts.
Äh, Herz 93, ich kenne mich nicht so gut aus mit Trading, bis auf eine Sache habe ich
nie was getradet.
Du kannst das, du kannst das glaube ich mit, du brauchst glaube ich den Premium Stash,
aber nagel mich jetzt nicht darauf fest, ich glaube du brauchst einen Premium Stash, dass
du das listen kannst.
Ja.
Aber guck lieber mal vor rum, ich weiß es nicht.
Die lagge Jagd ist da.
Hm.
Ah.
Ja.
ohne stash du kannst im trade channel wahrscheinlich rumspammen ich weiß es
nicht keine ahnung ich habe noch nicht getradet großartig in poe
du kannst dir aber auch das starter pack kaufen für glaub 20 euro das war glaube ich ganz gut
vom value her ich weiß es nicht ich hab's noch nicht gemacht
ok als jetzt ist es in standard clocks gegen overclock mit fester mit festen 720p das heißt
jetzt sehen wir was es oder ja jetzt sehen wir was es wirklich für einen unterschied macht
eigentlich so gut
das ist ein interessantes experiment aber es gibt einen direkten wege den visual settings zu verbessern
dank einer verbesserten mod daraus hat sich die game directory geändert, du kannst tatsächlich mit einem
mehr geblasen graphics option im menü spielen, das ist immer noch ein funktionierender prozess, die meisten Toggle
die man bei einem pc findet, funktionieren tatsächlich nicht bei switch der textur zum beispiel befindet sich
in einem sächsischen
Moment, es gibt schon irgendwelche Witcher 3 Switch-Grafik-Mods?
Wahrscheinlich aktivieren die einfach nur Sachen, die schon im Game drin sind.
Das hat einen effektiven Effekt auf die Leistung, aber das Volley-Setting ist extrem mächtig.
Es will einen der wichtigen Probleme, die ich mit dem Spiel hatte, in der Ebene von Pop-In lösen.
Guck mal, ein Wiesel mir.
Der ist wirklich einfach aufgeploppt.
Du bekommst vier Presets von Low zu Ultra, obwohl man sich daran erinnern muss, dass die Switch-Grafik-Mods am hohen Setting bei Default läuft.
Und so ist die Skope für Verbesserung nicht so groß, wie man es erwarten könnte.
Auch so, der Jump von Low zu Medium zeigt, dass es die Densität des Gras auf dem Boden beeinflusst.
Ja, Riesenunterschied, Riesenunterschied, aber mit dem Unterschied, es ruckelt ja jetzt schon.
Warum soll ich die Grafik noch weiter hochschrauben, es ruckelt ja jetzt schon unspielbar.
...over the base game, and you can see just a little more detail added all around.
One thing to note, this does incur the biggest performance hit of any of the settings.
Going from Low to Ultra, you can lose up to 3 to 4 frames per second on average, so not a twist to take lightly.
Und es ruckelt eh schon.
Still, it's fascinating to see the game play.
Another tweak that makes a tangible change is the sharpening filter.
It's popular in the modding community, and the performance hit is really quite minimal.
Sliding it on and off, high contrast points are boosted, and on a native set of the image here,
it gives the impression of a sharper image.
There's more shimmer as a result, but a neat option to have nonetheless.
The anti-aliasing toggle is there too, if you want to go all the way.
Not recommended, obviously.
But an option if you want to see the game's framebuffer roar, and if you dislike the way the anti-aliasing works.
Now, sadly, there are points which I wish could be solved here.
For example, due to the size of Switch's cartridge, texture assets remain compressed compared to PS4,
though at least it does exist to restore its original audio.
We also still have NPCs running at a lower framerate on the distance,
meanwhile texture filtering is on the blurry side, though with time I believe that could be solved.
...and I have to comment on that.
mit Low-FPS-NPCs, wo teilweise die Köpfe und die Körper und so von den NPCs nicht zusammengepasst haben.
Könnt ihr euch da noch dran erinnern, an Unity, wo die NPCs voll im Arsch waren?
Right now we do at least have a boosted resolution, better foliage and post-effect toggles to enhance the visuals.
Also der Unterschied ist wirklich groß. Also der Unterschied ist riesig.
Guckt euch das mal an links und guckt euch das mal an rechts. Das sieht viel, viel, viel, viel besser aus rechts.
Mit dem Unterschied, dass es wahrscheinlich grottenschlecht läuft auf der rechten Seite.
There's one last thing to try here. With the ability to fix the resolution at any number and tweak the foliage to any setting,
what if we gave up on image quality altogether? What if we traded it all in for the 60-inch stream on Switch?
It seems impossible on the outset, given 30 is enough of a challenge.
But with an overclock in place, we're closer than you might think.
Now, dropping the post-effect settings doesn't help much, but foliage draw does.
And so here I put that to low. Meanwhile, the dynamic res is now fixed at around 832x468, though this can still fluctuate very slightly.
Das sieht aus wie Majora's Mask, ey.
Oder so pixelig ohne Ende.
The lowest point the DRS can drop to while docked.
And yet, is this all enough to make 60 FPS a reality?
Okay, das sieht, das sieht, das, das, keine Ahnung, mir fällt gar kein Vergleich ein dazu.
Ich meine 60 FPS, yeah, aber wie das ausschaut, ey, das ist, mir fällt kein Vergleich zu ein,
weil die Sache ist, die effektmäßig und drumherum sieht das halt viel, viel besser aus als alte Games, ja.
Aber auflösungs- und klötzchenmäßig sieht das aus wie, wie, wie irgendein uraltes,
wie Metal Gear oder so.
The results, as you can see, are pretty mixed.
The White Orchard area is the most impressive showcase for how close it gets.
We're largely between 55 and 60 FPS most of the way around.
A bit plain and barren, yes, but it's still remarkable how smooth the game suddenly becomes.
Where this idea starts to unravel is later areas.
The outskirts of Novigrad are between 45 and 60 FPS, and even with the fluctuation,
it still feels far better to play than the regular games.
All of this, of course, is predicated on the game being too cube-out, however,
and using the lower resolution as a crutch to get a better framerate.
It's a flawed approach, really.
When you factor in big towns and cities, it's a very flawed approach.
When you factor in big towns and cities, where the CPU frame time is the bottleneck.
At lowest, we're back down to 30 FPS anyway in Novigrad's city center,
and likewise for the village in the White Orchard.
Switch just can't do either of these consistently.
The rule of thumb, then.
Outdoors areas benefit hugely from the dropped resolution,
while city spots have negligible gains.
60 FPS is just within reach in the right spots, then,
and it makes a difference to gameplay.
Ja gut, also in der Burg, da ist ja überhaupt nichts drumherum.
Exactly, but I think this is also a good thing.
Also, in der Burg, da ist ja überhaupt nichts drumherum.
Something we can't see on PS4 or Xbox One right now.
If you can stomach the degraded image quality,
an overclocked Switch can stretch to some remarkable feats,
all the more so given how unlikely it felt
we'd see The Witcher 3 running on it at all.
The Switcher.
Stretching the console in all these ways, though,
to a fixed 720p, to better visuals, to 60 FPS,
all points to the same verdict here.
CDPR and Saber Interactive,
for all the cutbacks and tweaks made on the Switch version,
made the right calls in optimizing
the game. On the hardware standard
clocks, it's hard to see how much
more could have been added.
Das finde ich so geil. Die NPCs
in der Witcher, die schleichen
immer nur um die Gegner rum. Auch die Gegner
schleichen so um dich rum.
Ja, Geralt geht da ab, so bam, bam, bam, hit, hit, hit,
blub, blub, blub, blub, blub. Und die NPCs
da-dum, da-dum, da-dum, mal ein bisschen
um das Monster rum schleichen, mal ein bisschen um das Monster,
haha, einmal treffen, um das Monster rum schleichen,
um das Monster rum schleichen. In der Zwischenzeit ist Geralt
da am Start, bam, bam, bam, hit, hit, hit,
weiter hier, fünf, zwei im Kreis gedreht.
Der NPC hat zweimal geschlagen.
Gut, also wir wissen jetzt,
es lohnt sich nicht.
Ich glaube, es reicht.
Genug zu heucheln, wir sind jetzt wach.
Und noch eine Runde
Witcher 3 Soundtrack.
Ich gehe jetzt off.
Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Stream.
See you.